WE'RE HEARING THE HUMAN SERVICES
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE.
WE WILL HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER EACH ISSUE.
SO PLEASE REFERENCE WHICH ISSUES
YOU'RE SPEAKING TO AS OUR
MULTIPLE ONES UNDER.
EACH ISSUE.
A SUGGESTION AS TO DELEGATE
SUBJECTS IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
SPEAKERS.
WE'RE GONNA BE HAD GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY I'M GOING TO ASK
EACH AGENCY OR DEPARTMENT TO BE
SO ST.
GIVEN THE VOLUME OF ISSUES WE
NEED TO COVER.
BUT ALSO PLEASE BE COMPLETE IN
YOUR COVERAGE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS.
THIS IS THE ONLY OPPORTUNITY
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO LEARN ABOUT
THE PROPOSALS.
AND HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT INPUT
BEFORE WE TAKE ACTION NEXT
TUESDAY MAY TWENTY FIRST.
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE WITH THE
PANELISTS PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
CAN I PLEASE GET MADAM CHAIR --
MY NAME IS MATCH YOU ARE ON THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
OFFICES SYSTEMS INTEGRATION I'M
GOING TO HANDLE THE FIRST ITEM
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND THAT'S THE
STATE VERIFICATION HUB.
ACTIVITIES.
AND THE STATE VERIFICATION HUB
IS A MULTI DEPARTMENTAL PLANNING
EFFORT TO STREAMLINE AND
MODERNIZE THE VERIFICATION
PROCESS. FOR PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS -- WITHIN AGENCY --
THAT ARE OVERSEEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
AND AS AS SUCH AS A JOINT
PROPOSAL BETWEEN OUR THREE
ORGANIZATIONS.
SO THE ROLE OF THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION IS TO DO
INITIAL PLANNING FOR THE
TECHNOLOGICAL -- SOLUTION FOR
THE STATE VERIFICATION HUB WHICH
IS ENVISIONED. TO BE A SYSTEM
THAT CONSOLIDATES AND
FACILITATES VERIFICATION
INFORMATION BOTH DATA AND
DOCUMENTS.
IN ORDER RESULT IN BETTER
OUTCOMES.
MORE TIMELY MORE ACCURATE
VERIFICATIONS.
IT HAS A NUMBER OF PROGRAMMATIC
BENEFITS BUT PRIVATE PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT.
ONE IS BETTER ACCESS AND A
BETTER EXPERIENCE AND BETTER
RESULTS FOR CLIENTS.
SO AS SUCH OVERSIGHT IS ASKING
FOR ONE POSITION AND CONSULTANT
RESOURCES.
IN ORDER TO DO A SOME OF THE
MORE INITIAL PLANNING FOR THAT
TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTION -- WE'VE
ALREADY SUBMITTED A STAGE ONE
BUSINESS ANALYSIS WHICH
ARTICULATES THE BUSINESS NEED TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THAT WORK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LIKE SPEAKER PLEASE.
HI THERE MY NAME IS MARKHAM EACH
I AM THE ACTING DEPUTY SECRETARY
FOR PROGRAM IN FISCAL AFFAIRS AT
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
AND I HAVE WITH ME THEM THIS
AFTERNOON DR NEEDING BURKE
HARRIS WHO'S CALIFORNIA'S FOR
CERTAIN GENERAL AND SHE WILL BE
TESTIFYING ON A COMPONENT OF OUR
PROPOSAL -- SO I WILL BE
SPEAKING TO BOTH OF THOSE AND
THANKS TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
AGENDA USING THIS AND OUR
SINCERE APOLOGIES TO YOUR STAFF --
FOR WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
GETTING THAT DOCUMENTS AND WE
WILL BE GETTING THOSE TO THEM
THIS AFTERNOON -- BUT OUR
APOLOGIES FOR NOT GETTING THOSE
TO THEM IN ADVANCE OF THIS
HEARING APOLOGY ACCEPTED BUT WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO RECEPTION
ABSOLUTELY -- SO WE HAVE TWO
COMPONENTS -- WE HAVE TWO
COMPONENTS ONE IS -- A REQUEST
FOR TWO POINT FIVE TWO POINT
FIVE S. SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A
NINE POSITION WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD.
INITIATIVES AND THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH --
AND I WILL TURN OVER TO DOCTOR
BURKE CHARICE WHO CAN TALK IN A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE
VISION OF HER OFFICE AND WHAT
SHE HAS BEEN CHARGED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO DO.
I'M SHE CAN MUCH MORE ELOQUENTLY
EXPLAINED IT THAN I DO AND I CAN
GO INTO THE OTHER COMPONENTS IF
IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU.
YES THANK YOU.
HI MA'AM THANK HERE IT'S A GOOD
TO HAVE YOU HERE AND AGAIN I I
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR
POINTING YOU.
IT'S HIGH TIME WE HAD OUR OWN.
SURGEON GENERAL AND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED THAT IT IS YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S A
PLEASURE AND HONOR TO SERVE AND
THE THE VISION OF THE OFFICE OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL IS REALLY.
TO THEY DO A COUPLE OF THINGS
NUMBER ONE IS TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE AS A KEY PUBLIC HEALTH
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND TO DO A DEEP DIVE IN SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST CHALLENGING
PRESSING AND INTRACTABLE PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES -- PARTICULARLY AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT ISSUES OF
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
AND ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND TOXIC STRESSED.
THINGS THAT AFFECT -- LARGE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS AND
HAVE SIGNIFICANT EFFECTS ON
HEALTH.
AND THE ROLE OF THE OF MY ROLE
AS SURGEON GENERAL IS TO BE NOT
ONLY A PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATE
BUT ALSO TO BE AN ADVISER TO THE
GOVERNOR AND TO BE.
YOURSELVES THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALSO -- ED TO TO BE A KEY
SPOKESPERSON AND AND HEALTH CARE
STRATEGIST IN ADVANCING THIS
WORK AND SO AS SUCH I'M I AM
INCREDIBLY EXCITED TO BE IN THIS
ROLE. TO BE LEADING THESE
EFFORTS AND LEADING A PUBLIC
HEALTH CAMPAIGN IN CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS THESE CRITICAL ISSUES.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLACE.
AND I'M CHAIRMAN AT THE THE LAST
ITEM ON YOUR AGENDA IS THE
REORGANIZATION OF THE OFFICE OF
THE SECRETARY -- AND WE ARE IN
THAT YEAH REQUEST FOR ASKING FOR
SIX PERMANENT POSITIONS AND
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
OUT WE ARE BASICALLY LOOKING --
TO REPURPOSE OR REEF PURPOSE THE
FUNCTION OF THE OFFICE OF THE
SECRETARY TO FOCUS ON SOME
STRATEGIC INITIATIVES THAT OUR
APPLE FOR BY THE GOVERNOR AND
THE SECRETARY I'M AND I'M HAPPY
CERTAINLY TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL
AROUND EACH OF THOSE COMPONENTS --
AT IT AS YOU SEE FIT.
WHAT FOR THE AGENCY
RESTRUCTURING HOW WILL THIS
REORGANIZATION CHANGE POLICY
OUTCOMES THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION -- I THINK THE DOCTOR
GALLEY -- IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
LOOKING AT KEEP PRIORITIES THAT
WE AS AN AGENCY FOCUSED ON SO
THESE ARE NOT ONLY HIS
PRIORITIES BUT OUR COLLECTIVE
PRIORITIES AS A STATE IN MOVING
TOWARDS A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
AND SO I THINK HIS EXPECTATION
IS THAT WE HAVE CLEAR OUTCOMES
AND DRIVING TOWARDS PARTICULAR
OUTCOMES ON EACH ONE OF THOSE
PRIORITIES.
AND SO I THINK WHAT YOU WILL SEE
WITH THESE RESOURCES IS THAT
IT'S NOT JUST SHUFFLING THE DECK
AROUND BUT REALLY STRATEGICALLY
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE
LEVERAGE EXISTING RESOURCES WITH
A COMBINATION OF THESE IN YOUR
RESOURCES TO SAY.
WHAT IS IT THAT WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE IN THE NEXT YEAR AND HOW
WE CAN ACHIEVE IT AND HAVING
THESE RESOURCES REALLY LEVERAGE
THEIR VARIOUS TALENTS ACROSS OR
TWELVE DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES
TO BRING TO FRUITION?
THOSE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE HOPING
TO CHIEF COLLECTIVELY.
CAN YOU OFFER A FEW POTENTIAL
EXAMPLES OF INTEREST.
ABSOLUTELY NEW SET OUT ONE ONE
PARTICULAR AREA IS A MASTER PLAN
ON AGING -- I THINK THAT -- WE
COLLECTIVELY RECOGNIZE THAT --
IT IS TIME FOR US TO ALL COME
TOGETHER AND THINK ABOUT HOW WE
ADDRESS THE AGING -- SITUATION
IN CALIFORNIA A LOT OF PEOPLE
COLLEGES YOU KNOW I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S SUCH A BAD TERM BECAUSE I
I I THINK IT'S NOT A BAD THING I
THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD THING
THAT PEOPLE ARE AGING WELL.
BUT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SECRETARY EXPECT THAT WE PULL
TOGETHER PUT PULL TOGETHER
MASTER PLAN THAT'S ACTIONABLE
AND SO THESE RESOURCES REALLY
WOULD BE DESIGNED TO HELP US
ENSURE.
THAT WITHIN A YEAR NOT ONLY DO
WE HAVE A PLAN BUT THE PLAN HAS
ACTIONABLE OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT
TO TRACK OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT DECADE.
AND THINK ABOUT HOW WE MOVING
THE NEEDLE BOTH AS A GOVERNMENT
BUT THEN ALSO OUR PHILANTHROPIC
AND ARE FOR PROFIT PARTNERS SO
THAT WE'RE ALL CREATE MOVING IN
THE DIRECTION OF CREATING AGING
FRIENDLY COMMUNITIES.
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE
HOMELESSNESS IS ANOTHER AREA
THAT I THINK THAT THE
SECRETARIES VERY MUCH FOCUSED IN
ON SO THAT THE PROPOSAL ON MY
APOLOGIES AGAIN FOR YOU NOT
HAVING IT -- WE LAY OUT THE KEY
PRIORITIES OF THE AGENCY AND I
THINK THAT WILL.
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
INSIGHT AND WE ARE AVAILABLE TO
YOU AND YOUR STAFF TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE AS A
FOLLOW UP.
WONDERFUL I WOULD ASSUME THE
TWINS WE DO GET THAT WE THERE
WILL BE OTHER QUESTIONS -- SO I
WOLD ASK THE TO WE WILL MAKE
OURSELVES AVAILABLE ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
BRENT METZ GO AWAY -- WE
REVIEWED THE FIRST PROPOSAL
RELATED TO THE STATE
VERIFICATION HUB ACTIVITIES AND
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS.
AND I'M SO NAY PICK FROM THE LA --
REGARDING THE SECOND TWO
PROPOSALS AS HAS JUST BEEN NOTED
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF DETAIL
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ONCE WE'VE
REVIEWED -- THE PLAN IN MORE
DEPTH WILL IT WILL BE SURE TO
LET YOU KNOW IF OUR OFFICE HAS
ANY CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
TIGER WOODS POUND FINANCE
NOTATIONAL COM AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE REGARDING H. H. S..
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MECCA WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT -- THE
REQUEST FOR AGENCY FOR THE
RESOURCES TO REORGANIZE ALONG
THAT THE VISION OF DOCTOR GALLEY
I THINK IT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
NEEDED.
OUR CLIENTS DON'T LIVE IN SILOS
AND THE WAY ROUTE WE MAKE THEM
HEALTHIER ME HELP THEM THRIVE IS
TO THINK ACROSS OUR SYSTEMS.
WERE PARTICULARLY EXCITED AS YOU
ARE ABOUT THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
AND THE PARTICULAR NOMINEE AS
WELL -- OUR WORK IN CHILD
WELFARE IN PARTICULAR BUT ALSO
IN FIGHTING POVERTY AND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES HAS BEEN REALLY
INSPIRED BY.
THE RESEARCH THAT'S BEEN DONE
REGARDING ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND FRANKLY -- IF WE
DON'T ADDRESS IN A SYSTEMATIC
WAY CHILDHOOD BURSARY AND TOXIC
STRESS WE'RE NOT GONNA GET THE
OUTCOMES FOR KIDS THAT -- THAT
YOU WANT AND SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE NEW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
THAT PRIORITY AND TO POSSIBLE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON WITH YOU
W..
ASKED ME WE REPRESENT HUNDRED
TEN THOUSAND AYE HSS WORKERS
WANT TO ST SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S REQUEST FOR
THE FUNDING -- BOTH FOR THE KEY
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND THE
REORGANIZATION IN THE OFFICE OF
THE SECRETARY.
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO SEE SOME
DEDICATED.
STAFF -- WHOSE JOB IS -- AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ACTIONABLE ITEMS COMING
OUT OF ALL THIS WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COMMON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT ADDITIONAL STAFF
FOR THE SECRETARY SPECIFICALLY
AROUND THE ALZHEIMER'S TASK
FORCE AND THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING [inaudible]
Q..
MARTY MOTO CALIFORNIA DISPLACING
YOUR COMMUNICATION NETWORK
CALIFORNIA PERSON CENTERED
ADVOCACY PARTNERSHIP FAMILY
MEMBER STRONG SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS FOR
RESTRUCTURING AND QUICKLY ON THE
OF FOCUS ON OUTCOMES.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL FEEL
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TERMS OF
MEASURING OUR PROGRESS.
AND ALSO AGREED WITH ALL MY
COLLEAGUES YOUR PREVIOUS
STATEMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD -- BEFORE BRING BACK
TO TO THIS TO MY COLLEAGUES I
WOULD LIKE TO STEP WAS QUORUM.
REYES HERE FRAZIER MATHIS.
PATTERSON RAMOS.
RUBIO [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
FROM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES DOCTOR WOULD.
YES A QUESTION UNDER THE
STAFFING RESOURCES FOR THE
REORGANIZATION.
I NOTICED THAT -- YOU THERE'S A
ADDITIONAL STAFFING BEING ASKED
FOR FOR THE SINGLE PAYER
COMMISSION.
THERE WAS A FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE LAST BUDGET ALLOCATED FOR
THAT COMMISSION WHY THE REQUEST
NOW.
DOCTOR WHAT THANK YOU -- FOR
THANK YOU FOR THAT ACT PEACE AT
THAT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WAS
ONE TIME DOLLARS CITING
CERTAINLY A PIECE OF IT BUT THE
THE INTENT IS THAT THIS WORK IS
GOING TO BE ONGOING WORK AND SO
I THINK THAT.
THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE STAFFING RESOURCES
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THIS IN
PERPETUITY.
I GUESS I WOULD JUST.
THINK THAT THAT'S MAYBE A LITLE
PREMATURE LIKE I SAID YOU'VE GOT.
THE FIRST FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
UP WAS ALLOCATED IN LAST BUDGET --
IT.
AND AND I SHOULD CLARIFY SO WELL
ONE COMPONENT CERTAINLY IS --
THAT THE THE IDEA REALLY IS THAT
WERE ITERATIVE WITH THESE
RESOURCES SO RIGHT NOW THE THE
RESEARCH HAS WOULD BE DEDICATED
TO THIS WORK AROUND -- COVERAGE
EXPANSIONS ACCESS TO CARE AND
QUALITY -- AS WE CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE AND THINK DIFFERENTLY
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE RESOURCES
AND YOU PARTY'S COME ON THE
TABLE OUT WE WITH THIS THESE
ASSISTANT SECRETARIES WHICH
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR POLICY
DEVELOPMENT.
COULD BE SHIFTING ON TO
DIFFERENT ASSIGNMENTS DEPENDING
ON WHAT IS HAPPENING SO
CERTAINLY THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
HAVE PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF CERTAIN
POLICIES -- WE WOULD BE
LEVERAGING THOSE RESOURCES ARE
FOR FOR BUDGET YEAR IN
PARTICULAR AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WE ARE LOOKING FOR
THIS PERSON TO BE DEDICATED
TOWARDS -- THIS SINGLE AT THE
CAN TO HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL COMMISSION -- YEAH BUT AS
PRIORITIES CHANGE THAT
INDIVIDUAL BE LAB. FOR OTHER
RESOURCES [inaudible]
SEE.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO DEPARTMENT OF AGING
.
THE DEPARTMENT CAN BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
I WAS FORCED OUT APARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE'RE REQUESTING ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME FUNDING TO LOCAL LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS
FROM THE STATE HEALTH FACILITY
CITATION.
COUNTIES ACCOUNT PURSUANT TO
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
I JUST FOR YOUR REFERENCE THE
PROJECT THE CURRENT YEAR ENDING
FUND BALANCE OF THAT PHONE TO BE
APPROXIMATELY NINE POINT NINE
MILLION.
WHICH IS ABOUT THE SIX MILLION
DOLLAR THRESHOLD CONTAINING THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT SPEAKER.
JOE RODRIGUEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE USED TO
SUPPORT THE WORK OF LOCAL
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS PROVIDING
SERVICES TO RESIDENTS OF LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES.
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORT TO
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM AND LOOK
FORWARD TO USING THESE DOLLARS
TO BETTER SERVE OUR RESIDENTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT SPEAKER.
THOMAS KAMAN DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND I HAVE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
CAN YOU PUT A JACQUI BRAZIL
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
AS MUCH BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THIS IS LARGELY A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT THAT WAS
ANTICIPATED PER PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU CHAIR THIS IS A IS A
COMMON CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND WHEN
WE ARE THANKFUL THIS IS A AT AS
AS YOU POINTED OUT A TECHNICAL.
OF THE PROGRAM BENEFITTED FROM
THIS FOR THREE YEARS AND THEN
DID NOT GET THE MONEY LAST YEAR
SO WE ARE THANKFUL TO HAVE IT
BACK.
AND THEY DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THE ONE TIME ONLY NATURE OF
THIS MONEY DOES DOES PUT SOME --
CONDITIONS ON HOW THE PROGRAM
CAN USE THE MONEY AND MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR US TO USE IT
FOR STAFF.
BUT WE ARE STILL NONETHELESS
VERY GRATEFUL FOR IT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON WITH
UT W. WANT TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
WITH THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO WE WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION
.
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THIS IS ELISE BOUCHARD APARTMENT
FINANCE AGAIN -- WE'RE
REQUESTING ONE POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND -- TO
REFLECT THE TWO YEAR LIMIT TERM
PROVIDER RATE INCREASE INCREASE
FOR SUPPORT EMPLOYMENT SERVICES.
EFFECTIVE JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THIS REQUEST
WITH A LINE VOCATIONAL
REHABILITATION SUPPORT
EMPLOYMENT RACE WITH THOSE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES -- JUST
FOR ADDITIONAL DETAILS -- THIS
COST DOUBLES TO TWO POINT SIX
MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THEN DROPS BACK DOWN TO ONE
POINT THREE MILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THOSE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION FIGURES ON THE HALF YOUR
COSTS.
OF THE TWO COUNT TWO YEAR.
A LIMITED TERM PROVIDER RATE
INCREASE.
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
ARNOLD IF CULTURE -- I FIFTEENTH
DEPUTY I THINK BUT ADMIN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF DARPA'S DEPARTMENT
REHABILITATION -- THOUGHT THIS
IS FOR SPECIFICALLY FOR
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT YEP COACH.
FOR JOB COACHING YES.
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
HI MY NAME'S MARK ROTHMAN AND
THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND EMPLOYMENT DIVISION AND I'M
HERE VIçT.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER SUNNY
PADDOCK LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE -- GIVEN THAT THE
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT RATES IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF RE OF
REHABILITATION FOLLOW THE RATES
THAT ARE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
IF THE LEGISLATURE DECIDES TO
APPROVE THE RATES ON THE GDS
SIDE OF THINGS THAN THIS --
PROPOSAL IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION MAKES SENSE THE
QUESTION WHICH WE WILL JUST BE
DISCUSSING LATER IS -- WHETHER
OR THE RATE PROPOSAL -- PUT
FORWARD BY THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR DDS -- THAT MAKES SENSE AND
IN ADDITION -- THESE RATE
INCREASES WOULD SUNSET AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND IN
FACT THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
A NUMBER OF SUNSETS ACROSS
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS.
AND WHEN WE GET TO THE DDS ISSUE
OUR OFFICE HAS SOME CONCERNS AND
COMMENTS ABOUT THE SUN SETS THAT
WILL DISCUSS AT THAT TIME.
THANK YOU.
I DO THE QUESTION IS THIS
APPROPRIATION A PART OF THE DDS
TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
ANALYZE NUMBER ON THE RATE
INCREASES -- IT'S IT'S TO ALIGN
WITH THAT PROPOSAL -- AND I
THINK OVERALL IF YOU HAD
EVERYTHING UP IS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION BUT I HAVE TO DEFER TO
DDS FOR THEIR DECIDED THERE --
THEIR BUDGET -- FINANCE YES IS
PART OF THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
PENALIZED.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
YES MY QUESTION OUT OF ORDER.
SEEING NO PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER THREE LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
THE AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT CERTAIN MARK
BECKLEY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES IS REQUESTING A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO ITS
FEDERAL TRUST FUND AND ITS
SHELLS FOR RECOVERY FUND -- TO
FORTY AT PURSUANT TO FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AT APARTMENT MUST
FIRST FULLY EXPAND ITS FEDERAL --
AND SURE OF COLLECTIONS BEFORE
DRAWING DOWN FEDERAL TRUST FUND.
SINCE OUR COLLECTIONS US MAKE
CAME IN SLIGHTLY LOWER THAN --
THE PROJECTIONS WE HAD AT OUR
NOVEMBER ESTIMATE WE ARE
EXPECTING WE ARE REQUESTING AN
INCREASE IN OUR FEDERAL -- TRUST
FUND AFFORD -- DECREASE IN OUR
FEDERAL TRUST FUND AUTHORITY
INCREASE IN OUR RECOVERY FUND A
THORNY -- TO REFLECT -- THE NEW --
PROJECTS ON COLLECTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
PLEASE FOR YOUR APARTMENT
FINANCE NOTHING ADDED HAPPY
ANSWERING QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT BAKER.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT WAS AS WAS
MENTIONED LARGELY BASED OFF OF
REVISED CASELOAD AND COLLECTIONS
ADJUSTMENT TO BE RES NO CONCERNS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ON ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR VERY GOOD TO BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THE CONNECTION
IN THE SYSTEM A CHANGE TO THE
CASTLE DYNAMIC.
IN CAL WORKS.
WHY SO THE -- COLLECTIONS TEND
TO TRACK WITH OUR CALORIES
CASELOAD IN THAT -- THEIR
COVERAGE THAT WE DO IN THE
CHILD'S FOR PROGRAM REALLY
REFLECTS -- ASSISTANCE PAGE
ACCOUNT WORKS RECIPIENTS AS
WALLS -- FOSTER CARE RECIPIENTS
AS WELL -- SO YOU DO SEE A A
CORRELATION BETWEEN -- YOU KNOW
REDUCE CAL WORKS POPULATIONS AS
AND OUR CHANNELS FOR TRAINING AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NO COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION ON NUMBER.
FOUR WE WILL BE HOLDING THAT
OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
ADJUSTMENTS [inaudible]
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
YES THANK YOU NANCY PARCHMAN
DIRECTOR DDS -- I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GO THROUGH OF THE
ITEMS ON ISSUE FIVE AND THEN
CERTAINLY -- WELCOME ANY ANY
QUESTIONS.
SO FOR THE RELOCATION TO THE
CLIFF ALLEN BE BUILDING -- WE
ARE REQUESTING THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION AND AND ONE POSITION TO
FUND -- OUR TRANSITION AND MOVED
TO THE NEW BUILDING -- AND WE
ARE LOOKING FOR THE POSITION TO
ASSIST US EARLY INTO THE STAGES
BECAUSE OF RECORD MANAGEMENT
BEING ABLE TO DO.
THAT WORK PRIOR TO THE MOVE. FOR
THE PORT OF BILLS STABILIZATION
TRAINING AND ASSISTANCE --
SERVICES THIS IS ACTUALLY AS A
FOLLOW UP ALSO FROM THE REQUEST
THAT WE HAVE FOR THE STAR
SERVICES.
THAT WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- AND THIS IS TO REMIND
YOU IS THAT THIS IS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TWO HOMES IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA FOR A TOTAL
OF TEN INDIVIDUALS.
SO KNOWING THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE ABOUT TWO TO THREE YEARS TO
ACTUALLY DEVELOP THAT COMMUNITY
RESOURCE IN THE COMMUNITY WE
WANTED TO ACTUALLY START SERVING
INDIVIDUALS BEFORE THAT.
SO THIS PROPOSAL IS TO REQUEST
THE FUNDING FOR THE STAFFING
POSITIONS TO OPERATE.
AT PORTER BILL IN THE INTERIM ON
A TEMPORARY BASIS UNTIL WE HAVE
THE HOMES IN THE COMMUNITY READY
TO SERVE THE INDIVIDUALS.
AT THE TIME THAT WE WOULD SERVE
THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
THEN WE WOULD NO LONGER BE
OPERATING AND AT AT PORTER BILL --
IN THE GENERAL TREATMENT AREA --
FOR THE POPULATION AND STAFFING
ADJUSTMENT -- BUT WE ARE
REQUESTING AN ADJUSTMENT TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- THIS IS
RELATED TO THE TRANSITION OF THE
INDIVIDUALS FROM FAIRVIEW -- TO
THE COMMUNITY WELL WE STILL HAVE
A PROJECTION OF FIVE UNITS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE AN OPERATION
AFTER JULY FIRST.
OUR PROJECTION IS IS A MIX OF
THE POPULATION WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE TO UNITS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE OPERATING FOR ICF AND TO
FOR OUR ANNA.
ON BASED ON THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE TRANSITIONING OUT OF OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAVE TO SWITCH
THAT BECAUSE OF THE SWITCH OF
THE UNITS WERE GOING TO HAVE
THREE UNITS THAT ARE GONNA BE
OPERATING UNDER ICF AND WONDER
ONE UNDER AN US.
THAT IT DOES CHANGE OUR
REIMBURSEMENT MIX SO WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE LESS REIMBURSEMENTS
UNDER THE FEDERAL DOLLARS --
THAT WE WOULD HAVE WITH WHAT WE
HAD PROJECTED WE STILL ARE
PROJECTING EVERYBODY MOVING OUT
BY THE END OF DECEMBER -- BUT
BECAUSE OF THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL -- FUNDING
AUTHORITY -- TO PROVIDE THE
STAFFING THAT WOULD BE IN
RELATION TO THAT CHANGE OUR
POPULATION MAX. FOR REGIONAL
CENTER WITH EARLY START
COPAYMENTS -- WE ARE REQUESTING
AN INCREASE -- AB ONE MILLION
DOLLARS SO WE CAN MEET A
CONDITION OF OUR FEDERAL GRANT
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO PAY
PRIVATELY INSURED FAMILY HE'S
FOR CO PAYS.
DEDUCTIBLES AND THIS WOULD --
GET TO THE EQUIVALENT TO AN
EQUITY INTO WHAT IS REQUIRED
UNDER OUR GRANT SO CURRENTLY WE
DON'T HAVE THAT AUTHORITY TO DO
THAT THIS WOULD GIVE US THE
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE -- TO HAVE
EQUITY INTO THOSE PAYMENTS FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE UNDER
EARLY START -- PROGRAM. FOR
FAMILY HOME AGENCY OVERSIGHT WE
ARE REQUESTING FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND THE OVERSIGHT AND
TO FAMILY HOME AGENCIES THIS
WOULD PROVIDE REGIONAL CENTERS --
POSITIONS WERE -- PROTECTING
TWENTY ONE POSITIONS FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS TO EXPAND OUR
FAMILY HOME AGENCY OPTION THIS
IS THE OPTION FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ADULTS.
AND IT SIMILAR -- TO FOSTER
FAMILY TYPE AGENCY WE WOULD
PREDICT WITH THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING AT THE REGIONAL CENTERS
THAT WE WOULD IT SPANNED.
AT LEAST TEN ADDITIONAL HOMES
ACROSS THE STATE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS -- AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT AND AND EXPAND THIS
MODEL. FOR THE SPECIALIZED HOME
MONITORS THIS IS ACTUALLY A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT FROM WHAT
WE HAD IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THIS IS FOR THE FUNDING THAT WE
HAD REQUESTED FOR THE BEHAVIOR --
THE B. C. B. A.'S BOARD
CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS --
LOOKING AT THE SALARIES AND
LOOKING AT MORE OF A COMPETITIVE
SALARY IT WAS A SLIGHT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY. TO
LIKE THE MID EIGHTIES AND SO
THIS IS A SLIGHT ADJUSTMENT --
TO UPDATE FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
CASE LOADING UTILIZATION
ADJUSTMENT WE ARE REQUESTING AN
ADJUSTMENT THIS IS PRIMARILY --
TO TWO FACTORS ONE IS THAT WE
ARE PROJECTING ADDITIONAL --
CASELOAD AS COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE INDIVIDUALS IN OUR CASE
LOAD.
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S THREE
ADDITIONAL DRIVERS THAT WE SEE
IN OUR UTILIZATION OF SERVICES.
ON THEIR FIRST IS WAS SUPPORT
SERVICES WE ALSO HAVE A
MISCELLANEOUS CATEGORY THAT WERE
ALSO SEEN HIGHER UTILIZATION
THAN WHAT WE HAD AND HAD
PROJECTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
AS WELL AS WITHIN THE
MISCELLANEOUS -- RESPITE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT SERVICES
ARE THE THREE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES THAT WERE SEEN THOSE.
THOSE DRIVERS.
THE PROVIDER RATE ADJUSTMENT
THIS IS WHAT WAS JUST EARLIER --
MENTIONED UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
REHAB SO WE ARE -- REQUESTING --
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE FOR OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE ADJUSTMENT AND
SO WE'RE PER -- REQUESTING A
NINETY EIGHT MILLION FOR GENERAL
FUND AND A HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
MILLION TOTAL FUND THAT WOULD BE
RELATED.
TO DDS THIS PORTION OF THE RATE --
SUPPLEMENT THIS IS FOCUSED ON
VERY TARGETED AREAS WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOW TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE CRITICAL
AREAS THAT IS.
HAVE HEARD. ONE IS TARGETING THE
SERVICES WOULD BE COMMUNITY CARE
FACILITIES WE ARE SEEN ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS THAT ARE COMMUNITY
CARE FACILITIES THAT ARE ARM.
LEVEL IT'S A ADULT RESIDENTIAL
MODEL KATE HISTORICALLY ARE THE
FACILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
LICENSED AND HAVE BEEN VENDOR IT
FOR MANY YEARS THAT WE ARE SEEN
AN ANNUAL DECLINE IN THE NUMBER
THOSE PROVIDERS.
ALSO WAS SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT
WHERE SUPPORT SERVICES THREE
CATEGORIES UNDER SUPPORT
SERVICES ONE IS PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE.
BEEN SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT THAT
WOULD BE GOING IN TWO DAYS
SERVICES RESIDENTIAL SERVICES
TRANSPORTATION ASSISTANT THIS IS
REALLY GETTING TO A FOCUS OF
STABILIZE AND SOME WORK FORCE.
WHERE WERE SEEN WHAT THE SUPPORT
SERVICES IS USUALLY APPROVED ON
A ONE TO ONE SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WOULD THAT DO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS -- THE
PERSONAL ASSISTANTS OFTEN WILL
GO INTO SUPPORTED LIVING
ENVIRONMENT OR INTO THE FAMILY
HOME.
AND SEE IF I MISSED ANY.
A SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT AND
SUPPORTED LIVING AND FAMILY HOME
AGENCY I HAD JUST DESCRIBED THE
MODEL TO YOU ALSO FOR THE FAMILY
HOME AGENCY.
COUPLE OF THINGS REGARDING THE
THE TARGETED AREAS IS THAT WE DO
SEE THAT EACH OF THESE ARE
REALLY AN ALIGNMENT WITH C.
COMPLIANCE WITH THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES WITH
OUR FEDERAL DOLLARS.
AND BEING ABLE BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE NEW FEDERAL RULE THE
OTHER IS MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
TAKING A LOOK AT KIND OF THOE
CRITICAL AREAS FOR STABILIZATION.
NO I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
WEEDS OF EVERYTHING BUT I THINK
IT'S I DO WANT TO JUST TAKE A
MINUTE TO EXPLAIN.
HOW WE WOULD BE MOVING FORWARD
WITH KIND OF THAT ASSUMPTION
WITH THE ALLOCATION IN THE
FUNDING FOR EACH OF THESE AREAS?
BECAUSE ON AVERAGE IT IS
PROJECTED ON ABOUT 18% FOR ALL
OF THOSE PROVIDERS.
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT BEING ABLE
TO DO IT BEING INFORMED BASED ON
OUR RATE STUDY THAT WE HAD
DISCUSSED -- EARLIER -- AND AND
IN DISCUSSING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- BUT WITH THE THE THE
RATE STUDY INFORMING US WERE
ABLE TO SEE WITHIN EACH OF THESE
CTEGORIES KIND OF THIS RELATIVE
PERCENTAGE OF IF WE WE HAD
IMPLEMENTED THE RATE MODELS.
KIND OF WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE
FALLEN INTO.
AN INCREASE.
RELATIVEACROSS THE STATE OF OF
WITH THOSE IN SCOPE SERVICES AND
SO BEING ABLE TO USE THAT TO
INFORM US AND SAY OKAY USING
THAT IS KIND OF OUR FLOOR.
SO WITHIN THAT KIND OF FLOOR
THAT WE WOULD BE ESTABLISHING
THAT ANY PROVIDER THAT WITH THAT
IS WITHIN THOSE TARGETED AREAS
WOULD BE RAISED UP TO THAT FLOOR
THAT WE WOULD.
IDENTIFY THAT SENT BEING
INFORMED BY THE RATE MODELS.
BUT ANYBODY THAT'S ABOVE IT
WOULD NOT BE REDUCED.
SO WE WOULD NOT BE PROTECTING
ANY REDUCTION OF RATES FOR
ANYBODY IF THEY WERE NOT --
ANTICIPATING A RATE INCREASE SO
WE JUST WANT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
I KNOW MANY OF OUR PROVIDERS
HAVE BEEN VERY CONCERNED.
THAT THEY WOULD BE RECEIVING A
RATE REDUCTION AND SO I I DID
WANT TO PROVIDE THAT
CLARIFICATION AS WELL -- WE
WOULD BE TAKING THE INFORMATION
BACK TO OUR RATE STUDY WORK
GROUP WHO HAS BEEN VERY ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN OUR RATE STUDY -- IT
IS A PART OF OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE SO WE WILL
BE DOING THAT BECAUSE ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS FOR IMPLEMENTING.
ANY RATE ADJUSTMENT WITHIN OUR
WAIVER SERVICES IS THAT WE DO
NEED TO HAVE PUBLIC --
PARTICIPATION IN AND PUT AND
THEN THE PROCESS THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO AND TELL ON THIS IS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO GO -- TO
THE FEDERAL -- APPLY FOR CMS
APPROVAL ON IT WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE THAT WE'D BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY NOW THERE IS THIS -- A
SUNSET OF THE INCREASE THAT
WOULD BE IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE ALSO AS A PART OF
IT IS YOUR NEXT ITEM ON YOUR
AGENDA IS A UNIFORM HOLIDAY IS
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
TO SUSPEND THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT I DO WANT
TO MAKE NOTE THAT THE HALF DAY
BILLING IS -- A A COST SAVING
MEASURE THAT HAD BEEN PUT IN
PLACE IN THE PAST THAT THIS IS
NOT A PART OF THAT THAT IT WOULD
CONTINUE AS PART OF OUR PROPOSAL --
GOING INTO.
NINETEEN TWENTY THE LAST ITEM
UNDER ISSUE FIVE IS BEST BUDDIES
A REQUEST INCREASE OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND THIS WOULD MAKE
THE CONTRACT A TOTAL OF TWO
MILLION.
AS PART OF THE INCREASE AND PART
OF THE CONTRACT THAT WOULD BE
MOVING FORWARD WOULD HAVING
WOULD BE -- SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO INCLUDE BEING
ABLE TO REPORT OUT THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE RECEIVING
SERVICES.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
SENATE PADDOCK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR OFFICE HAS
POINTS TO MAKE ON FOUR OF THE
ISSUES PRESENTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
THE FIRST CONCERNS THE MOVE TO
THE NEW ALLEN BE BUILDING THIS
IS JUST A MINOR TECHNICAL POINT
ABOUT THE PROVISIONAL BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED FOR DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS AND DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES -- THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THIS --
PROPOSED WOULD EXEMPT THE
DEPARTMENT FROM HAVING TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF TO
GENERAL SERVICES ON DOCUMENT
ARCHIVAL AND SCANNING AND
DESTRUCTION BECAUSE TGS WOULD
COST ABOUT TWICE AS MUCH AS A
THIRD PARTY VENDOR. TO DO THAT
WORK -- BUT THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ALSO EXAMS THE
DEPARTMENT FROM HAVING TO FOLLOW
THE PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE IN
SETTING UP THOSE THIRD PARTY
CONTRACTS.
SO WHAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND WE
AGREE THAT IT PROBABLY MAKES
SENSE NOT TO USE THE HIGHER COST
OPTION UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES.
BUT WE PROPOSE CHANGING THE
LANGUAGE SLIGHTLY TO NOT EXEMPT
THE DEPARTMENT FROM THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE -- SIMPLY -- HAVE
IT SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE GS.
SO IT'S A MINOR POINT ON ON THE
MOVE -- THE SECOND POINT HAS TO
DO WITH THE POPULATION AND
STAFFING ADJUSTMENT AT FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER -- HERE WE
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT --
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT ONE
OF THE REASONS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS TO KEEP AN INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITY UNIT.
OPEN IN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY IS BECAUSE SEVERAL
RESIDENTS THAT HAD BEEN PLACED
IN THE COMMUNITY HAVE HAD TO
MOVE.
BACK TO THE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER AND WE
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED
TO THE DEPARTMENT WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUALS HAVE COMPLEX.
CHALLENGES -- SEVERE OF
BEHAVIORAL -- CHALLENGES TO
ADDRESS -- BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT IT'S GOING TO COST
AN ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND -- TO KEEP
THAT ICF UNIT OPEN -- AND IT'S
IT MIGHT BE WORTH HAVING SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT WHAT LED TO
THESE RESIDENTS HAVING TO MOVE
BACK AND WHAT KINDS OF LESSONS
LEARNED MIGHT BE TAKEN INTO THE
FUTURE.
OKAY ON THE ISSUE OF THE
PROVIDER RATE ADJUSTMENT -- WE
WOULD NOT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL DOES
USE FINDINGS FROM THE RECENT
READ RECENTLY RELEASED RATE
STUDY IN A BENEFICIAL WAY TO
INFORM THE DESIGN OF THE
TEMPORARY RATE INCREASES.
AS DIRECTOR BARGE MEN NOTED IT
WOULD -- TARGET PROVIDERS IN THE
CATEGORIES THAT APPEAR TO HAVE
BEEN -- MOST UNDER FUNDED IN
RECENT YEARS -- IN ATTEMPTS TO
APPLY ADJUSTMENTS FOR REGIONAL
VARIATIONS IN COST AND IT
ATTEMPTS TO CREATE SOME PARITY
ACROSS PROVIDERS -- OF THE THE
SAME TYPES OF SERVICES IN THE
SAME TYPES OF AREAS.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE FOUR KEY
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH AND
NOTE THAT IT FUNDAMENTALLY
MISSES AN OPPORTUNITY TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION OF RATE REFORM IN
THE SYSTEM.
AND IN FACT THIS WAS A
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY THAT LED TO
THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED RATE
STUDY IN THE FIRST PLACE.
FIRST OF THE FUNDING PROPOSAL IS
MODEST RELATIVE TO THE RATE
STUDIES IDENTIFIED FUNDING GAPS.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSED RATE INCREASE WHICH IS
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS.
FALLS FAR SHORT OF WHAT THE RATE
STUDY IMPLIES IS NEEDED IN THE
SYSTEM WHICH IS ABOUT ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
SECOND THE PROPOSED SUNSET OF
RATE INCREASES RAISES CONCERNS.
THE REVISED BUDGET IN EFFECT
TREATS SERVICES THAT ARE FUND OF
FUNDAMENTALLY ONGOING IN NATURE
AS TEMPORARY WHICH ULTIMATELY
CREATES PROGRAMMATIC CHALLENGES.
AND INCREASES COST PRESSURES.
THE TARGETED SERVICES FUNDED
WITH THE PROPOSED RATE INCREASES
WILL STILL BE NEEDED BY DDS
CONSUMERS AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IN ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
NOTES THAT ONE RATIONALE FOR THE
PROPOSED RATE INCREASES IS TO
STABILIZE CAPACITY IN
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES.
AND TO STABILIZE CAPACITY OF THE
WORK FORCE IN OTHER SERVICE
CATEGORIES.
ENDING THE RATE INCREASES IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WOULD HAVE A
DESTABILIZING AFFECT.
OUR OFFICE IS NOTED IN ITS
INITIAL COMMENTS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S ME REVISION -- THAT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
SUNSETS ACROSS A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS IN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES [inaudible]
IT AREAS.
AND THEY SUGGEST THIS TO
MAINTAIN A BALANCE BUDGET
THROUGH THE FORECAST PERIOD
ENDING. TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE OUR OFFICE HAS RAISED A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
APPROACH FINDING THAT THE MAYOR
REVISION UNDERSTATES THE TRUE
ONGOING COST OF ITS POLICY
COMMITMENTS.
OUR THIRD CONCERN IS THAT THE
RATE INCREASE PROPOSAL LIMITS
THE SCOPE OF WHO BENEFITS FROM
THE FISCAL RELIEF PROVIDED.
WE SEE THE MERIT OF TARGETING
RATE INCREASES AS THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
BECAUSE TARGETING IS TYPICALLY A
MORE COST EFFICIENT METHOD.
THEN ACROSS THE BOARD RATE
INCREASES HOWEVER WE DO NOTE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AND SUB
EXCLUDING A LARGE SHARE OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS -- USING THIS
APPROACH.
FINALLY WE NOTE THAT THE
PROPOSAL -- POSTPONES RATE
REFORM.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS MADE
RATE REFORM IS A EARLIER NOTED A
A PRIORITY IN THE DDS SYSTEM
IT'S THE REASON THAT IT CALLED
FOR THE RATE STUDY.
AND IT'S THE REASON THAT IT'S
DELAYED DECISIONS ABOUT
INCREASING RATES IN THE
INTERVENING YEARS.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S CURRENT
PROPOSAL WELL INFORMED BY THE
RATE STUDY DOES NOT BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT ANY OF THE RATE MODELS
SUCH AS THROUGH A STAGE ROLLOUT
OR THROUGH AND OR THROUGH PILOT
PROJECTS AS OUR OFFICE HAS
SUGGESTED TO THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IN A LETTER.
DATED MAY SECOND.
WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT IF
IMPLEMENTED IMPLEMENTATION OF
ANY KIND IS NOT IS DELAYED THE
MOMENTUM TO BEGIN RATE REFORM
WILL BE LOST -- I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT I THAT ONE QUESTION
CAME UP HIS PERMIT WAS MAKING
ITS PRESENTATION.
IT WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING ON THE
ISSUE OF THE AS THE CRISIS UNITS
THAT WOULD BE TEMPORARILY HOUSED
AT THE PORT OF BILL
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT
FUNDING WOULD BE ONE TIME IN --
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE WAY
IT IT WAS JUST PRESENTED IT
SOUNDED AS THOUGH THAT COULD
LAST FOR TWO TO THREE YEARS --
WE SUGGEST THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT ISSUE BECAUSE
AGREEING TO FUND -- THOSE
SERVICES THIS YEAR YOU MAY BE
ESSENTIALLY COMMITTING TO
FUNDING IT.
FOR FOR TWO TO THREE YEARS IN
TOTAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Q. LIKE SPEAKER PLEASE.
SOON PUBLIC POINT OF FINANCING
OF THAT ADDITIONAL TO THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT SPEAKER [inaudible]
WE'RE DONE [inaudible]
OUR WHEN WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT I WILL BE ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT TO RESPOND TO LA OWES --
CONCERNS.
THAT'S BECAUSE PUBLIC ON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND DISTINGUISHED
STAFF -- RICK ROLLINS
REPRESENTING OUR BECAUSE THE
ASSOCIATION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES ON PAGE SEVEN OF YOUR
AGENDA.
UNDER THE SPECIALIZED HOME
MONITORS ISSUE WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION -- FOR MAKING
THIS ADJUSTMENT -- A POINT THAT
WE BROUGHT OUT IN THE JANUARY OF
BUDGET REVIEW OF THIS SO
SUBCOMMITTEE ON THE PROVIDER
RATE ISSUE WE WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ITS FIRST.
FORAY INTO THE WORLD OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES SINCE
FUNDING A SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
GROSSLY UNDERFUNDED OVER.
THE YEARS BUT WE ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH MANY
OF THE COMMENTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST -- ON ON
THIS PROPOSAL IN THAT SO WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR IT BUT WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT -- AN 8% INCREASE --
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR ALL THOSE
OTHER PROVIDERS WHO HAVE BEEN --
WOEFULLY FUNDED FOR MANY YEARS
TO BE PART OF THAT -- THAT
PROGRAM -- IN PROPOSAL HAD AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD IN ON THE ISSUE
OF THE SUNSET ON THE RATE TO
INCREASES SO WE BELIEVE AT THE
VERY LEAST THAT YOU'D WANT TO
SUNSET.
IN ANYTHING ONCE -- THE FULL
RATE STUDY HAS BEEN FUNDED AND
NOT OF ESSENTIALLY POTENTIALLY
PULL THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER OUR
PROVIDER COMMUNITY WITH
TEMPORARY RATE INCREASES.
AND LASTLY OF AND THEN SKEWS ME
THE NEXT ITEM ON PAGE NUMBER
EIGHT OF THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE A SUSPENSION OF WE
APPRECIATE -- THE DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS -- WHAT
WE REFER TO AS A FURLOUGH
PROGRAM WE HAVE ALWAYS SO
STRONGLY ADVOCATED FOR THE
REPEAL OF THIS?
PROPOSAL -- THAT WAS PUT IN
DURING VERY A TOUGH BUDGET TIMES.
YEARS AGO.
AND THEN ON PAGE NUMBER -- NINE
THE REGIONAL CENTER
ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT
MONITORING WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE FUNDING.
THAT SO GOING ALONG WITH THIS TO
HELP A REGIONAL CENTERS --
IMPLEMENT THESE CHANGES AS WELL
AS IMPLEMENTING RATE INCREASES
IN THE RATE.
OF PORTION OF YOUR AGENDA THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
CARL LUNDEN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES.
A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFITS THAT.
SUPPORT THIS POPULATION IN THE
COMMUNITY AND AGAIN I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE OUR SUPPORT. FOR THE
ANALYSIS PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST -- IN
PARTICULAR ON ISSUE FOR TEN PAGE
SEVEN OF THE PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENTS.
I WOULD JUST NOTE AGAIN ALL THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE LEFT OUT IN
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
HAS HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
HOW DRAMATICALLY UNDERFUNDED.
THE COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS ARE
AND HAVE BEEN IN THE IMPACT UPON
THE PEOPLE THAT SERVE THOSE --
POPULATIONS WE HAVE WAITING
LISTS ALL OF THE STATE WE HAVE
WAITING LISTS ARE CLOSE AROUND
THE STATE.
AND I KNOW FOR A FACT THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE MAY REVISE
LEAVES OUT.
OF PROGRAMS FOR FUNDING OF EVERY
MEMBER THE SETS ON THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS WHY BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE
CLEARLY DONE YEARS HAVE
INDICATION BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO FUND
PART OF THE RATE STUDY.
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO LEAVE OTHER
PROGRAMS OUT UNTIL THEY FIGURE
OUT HOW THE ONE IMPLEMENT THE
RACE REST OF THE RATE STUDY.
WE THINK THAT'S A WHOLLY
INAPPROPRIATE WAY TO GO ABOUT
THIS WE WOULD ASK INSTEAD.
THAT YOU STRONGLY CONSIDER THE
FRAZIER HOLDEN -- HENRY STERN
AND MR MATHIS PROPOSAL TO HAVE
AT LEAST AN 8% PROPOSAL ACROSS
THE BOARD WHILE WE FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO WITH THIS
RATE STUDY.
CONVERSATIONS ARE GREAT WE CAN
HAVE IN THE SUMMER AND INTO THE
FALL BUT IF WE DON'T HAVE
FUNDING SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE PEOPLE
THE WORKERS WILL BE LOST FROM
THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND WE'LL JUST CONTINUE
EVANESCENCE SYSTEM SO WE WE LOVE
THE FIRST FORAY INTO THIS BUT WE
YOU CANNOT LEAVE OTHER PROGRAMS
BEHIND WE URGE YOU TO ADOPT.
A DIFFERENT PATH IN THAT
SECONDLY -- UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE AGAIN JUST A REMINDER
THESE A RECESSION ERA CUTS FROM
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THAT WERE
STILL LEAVING ON THE BOOKS.
AND WE'RE SIMPLY GETTING A
REPEAL FOR A YEAR OR YEAR AND A
HALF FROM THAT WOULD SUPPORTERS
GETTING ALL THE WAY REPEAL ALL
THE WAY IT LASTLY -- PGD ON THE
BEST BUDDIES THE FUNDING I HATE
TO SAY THIS WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
IT'S A GREAT PROGRAM.
BUT WE DO NOT SUPPORT THIS
AUGMENTATION THIS PROGRAM IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM IN THE
STATE.
THAT OFFER SERVICES TO THIS
POPULATION AND A SINGLE THEM OUT
FOR AN AUGMENTATION AND ALL THE
OTHER PROGRAMS.
ARE STRUGGLING FOR CRUMBS WE
JUST LEAVE IS WHOLLY
INAPPROPRIATE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M JACQUI DELUDE FOSTER
THE CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OF THE
NETWORK -- ONE IS WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT PERSONAL SUPPORT
PERSONAL SUPPORT FOR THE NETWORK
INCLUDE SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES PERSONAL ASSISTANCE
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND RESPITE
SO.
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DID NOT RECOGNIZE INDEPENDENT
LIVING OR RESPITE SERVICES WHICH
IS THAT -- SAME ARRAY OF
SERVICES.
THE OTHER IS I AM JUST AS
CONCERNED.
AROUND THE LACK OF VISION AROUND
THIS RATE STUDY THE STUDIES DONE
AND IT'S TIME FOR IMPLEMENTATION
SO WE HAVE A RATE STUDY WE'RE
GOING.
TO HOPEFULLY HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE RATE STUDY AND I'M
JUST HOPING THAT IN A YEAR'S
TIME OR TWO YEARS TIME WE'RE NOT
HERE TO TALK ABOUT A STUDY
THAT'S BEEN DONE IN. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN BECAUSE WE
NEED TO HAVE A RESOLUTION FOR
OUR COMMUNITY -- AND THE OTHER
ONE AROUND SUPPORTIVE LIVING
SERVICES I DO HOPE THAT PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION IS HOW TO MOVE
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES
TOWARD AN HOURLY RATE.
THAT MAKES SENSE PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE IS ACCESSED IN
SUPPORTED LIVING SERVICES
BECAUSE OF THE CONFUSION OF THE
RATE STRUCTURE WE HAVE NOW.
BURNSAND ASSOCIATE RECOMMENDED
AN HOURLY RATE SYSTEM THAT CAN
AND SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED AND SO
THE NETWORK LOOKS FORWARD TO
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION.
AS WELL AND THE OTHER IS AROUND
THE SUNSET.
BECAUSE ALEJO'S OFFICE IS RIGHT
ON TARGET YOU CANNOT TELL A
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL YOU
GET A WAGE A WAGE INCREASE.
IT TILL.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT'S A IT'S
DESTABILIZING FOR OUR ENTIRE
SYSTEM NO ONE WOULD WANT TO SAY
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET
IF IT'S A STEP TOWARDS THE RATE
STUDY.
AND THIS RATE IMPLEMENTATION
LET'S BEGIN TO BRIDGE THIS AND
LET'S BEGIN TO WORK FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAN NOT HAVING US HAVE THIS
SAME CONVERSATION YEAR AFTER
YEAR BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I AM OF
THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
AND THE LAST CONVERSATION I WANT
TO HAVE ONE MORE IS AROUND THE
WORK FORCE THE ENTIRE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM DEPENDS ON EIGHT
A QUALIFIED.
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
WORKFORCE WE CONTINUE TO NOT
RECOGNIZE THEM THE LAST COMMENT
ON THIS IS I WAS LISTENING TO
SOMEONE FROM NEW YORK SAY THAT
WE CONTINUE TO SAY WE HAVE A
CRISIS WE DO NOT HAVE A CRISIS
WE TALKED ABOUT THE CRISIS.
IN THE WORK FORCE FOR FIFTY
YEARS WE HAVE A SYSTEMATIC
FAILURE YOU HAVE A RATE STUDY TO
BEGIN TO LOOK AT THE SYSTEMATIC
FAILURE FIX THE FAILURE SO WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD SO PEOPLE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES GET
THE BEST AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
DESERVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI NANCY CHANCE CHOICES PERSON
CENTERED SERVICES CALIFORNIA
PERSON CENTERED PARTNERSHIP AND
A PATH TOWARD COLLABORATIVE -- I
AM.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK -- THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PUTTING
FORWARD SOME SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING I THINK THAT IT'S A GOOD
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
BUT I WOULD ALSO I ALSO SUPPORT
THE IDEA OF IMPLEMENTING THE
RATE STUDY EVEN IF WE HAVE TO
PHASE IT IN THERE ARE SOME PARTS
OF THE RATE CITY I THINK THAT
ARE READY THAT COULD BE STARTED
NOW INSTEAD OF WAITING AND
CONTINUING TO DISCUSS IT -- BUT
SHORT OF OF IMPLEMENTING THE THE
RATE STUDY -- WE WE I SUPPORT
THAT THE THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PROVIDER RATE INCREASE BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ADDED --
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES AND
IN HOME RESPITE AS THOSE ARE
ALSO PERSONAL SUPPORT -- I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE -- TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS -- TO FIND A WAY TO
FULLY FUND HE LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGE AND THE MINIMUM WAGE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ON
GOING -- INCREASES IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE WE'VE GOT TO FIND A
WAY TO FULLY FUND THAT NOT JUST
FIND THE PEOPLE THAT.
OUR BILL ARE ARE PAYING MINIMUM
WAGE BUT PEOPLE ABOVE THAT I
MEAN WE JUST CAN'T GET AWAY FROM
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO BE LESS
MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE PROVIDERS
IF WE DON'T DO THAT -- AND WHAT
WE DO IS NOT AN ENTRY LEVEL JOB --
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO AND SAY I I
AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
SUSPENSION OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY OR THE FURLOUGHS BUT I I
TOO WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT --
REPEALED NOT JUST NOT JUST A SIX
MINUTE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
STAFF JORDAN IN THE WITH THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE Q. C. P.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE -- WE
WANT TO HOLY ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE LA --
AND STRONG'S ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE -- TO DO THE SAME --
FEW COMES JUST TO EXPAND ON IT A
LITTLE BIT -- AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE MODEST
INVESTMENTS HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
IT FALLS FAR SHORT OF SERIOUS IN
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT -- TO
CREATE SUSTAINABLE SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOP THE DISABILITIES --
WE HEARD THE ADMINISTRATION --
LINK THE THE SERVICES THAT WERE
SELECTED TO EIGHT CBS -- JUST
JUST THINGS THAT WE STILL DON'T
KNOW WHEN WE ARE CLEAR SO I FEEL
LIKE IT'S A LITTLE BIT A STAB IN
THE DARK I'M WE DON'T HAVE A
FINAL IMPROVE STATE PLAN YET.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT TO SAY
THAT NINETY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE SERVICES FOR THEIR DAY
PROGRAMS AND VOCATIONAL TRAINING
AND JOB COACHING TO THE DAY
PROGRAMS.
ARE NO LONGER GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE IN TWO YEARS I DON'T
THINK THAT'S BUT THAT'S KIND OF
THE MESSAGE WE'RE GETTING BY
SELECTING CERTAIN SERVICES -- SO
IT'S A LITTLE A STAB IN THE DARK
STILL.
SO AT WE WHILE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION WHICH IS -- TO
ENHANCE CERTAIN SERVICES UP
TOWARDS 18% WE FULLY SUPPORT
THAT AT THE SAME TIME THERE ARE
AS YOU'VE HEARD THERE ARE
CRITICAL SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THATNEED INVESTMENT NOW AS WELL
AS WITH A MINIMUM OF 8%. FOR THE
OTHERS AS WELL AS WHAT WE WOULD
PROPOSE -- JUST SINCE THE MAYBE
VICE CAME OUT I SPOKE WITH
PROVIDERS IN SAN JOAQUIN LA IN
RIVERSIDE ALL WHO SAID THOSE
STATE PROGRAMS WHICH PROVIDE
VOCATIONAL TRAINING THIS IS THE
NAIL IN THE COFFIN IF THEY DON'T
RECEIVE THE INVESTMENT THIS YEAR.
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN SHUTTING
DOWN SOME NOW NOW IT'S IT'S GONE
AFTER THIS -- FINALLY ACTUALLY
NUMBER THREE IN THE THIRD COM IS
REGARDING THE SUNSET AGAIN ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH OTHERS HAVE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A SUNSET
WE CAN'T.
WE CAN'T ALLOW SOMEBODY'S
BRAIDED LIFE OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS TO ALL OF A SUDDEN SAY.
IN TWO YEARS BY THE WAY WE'RE
NOT SURE WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK LIKE SO IN MUST BE TIED TO
A SUNSET OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE RATE STUDY.
AND FINALLY THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE WE REALLY REALLY
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE.
TO PUT THIS TO TO READ TO PUT
THIS TO TO REST FINALLY AND
DON'T SUNSET THE UNIFORMHOLIDAY
SCHEDULE BUT JUST ELIMINATE.
IT ENTIRELY WE KNOW WHAT'S NOT
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISED
THERE IS NOT THE ELIMINATION OF
HALF THE BILLING WHICH WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE IMPACTS WE WISH
THAT THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPLANTED ELIMINATED.
ALSO THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
BY THE LA OWES AN ANALYSIS OF
THE MINIMUM WAGE QUIRK -- WHICH
I THINK IS A GOOD WAY TO PUT IT
REGARDING AND STARTING JANUARY
ONE AND THEN AGAIN AFTER THAT.
SOME WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES MANY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THOSE IN
HIGH COST REGIONS WHERE THE MAN
WE JUST HIGHER WILL NOT RECEIVE
ANYTHING SO THOUGH IT THEY'RE
GONNA BE IMPACTED.
JANUARY ONE AGAIN WE WISH THAT
THAT WAS RESOLVED -- IN THIS
BUDGET WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN DO
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JIM GROSS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION THE ONLY THING I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH MEMBERS AND
STAFF.
WE ALL HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
THROUGH THE RATE STUDY THERE IS
GOING TO BE -- A DECISION MADE
ABOUT WHAT TYPES OF SERVICES
PERFORM BEST ETCETERA ETCETERA
UNFORTUNATELY YES AS MUCH AS THE
MINISTRATION HAS TRIED TO
ADDRESS.
OUR OVERALL PROBLEM IT IT CAN'T
LEAVE OUT CERTAIN SERVICES THAT
ARE STILL VERY MUCH A PART OF
THE SYSTEM AND STILL CENTRAL THE
LONG TERM DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
RATE STUDY WILL YIELD.
DISCUSSION ABOUT PARTICULAR
INVESTMENT IN PARTICULAR SERVICE
CODE WE'RE NOT THERE YET WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE
SYSTEM AS IT IS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL WILL
MAKE THINGS WORSE IN A LOT OF
ASPECTS OF THE SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TOOK ME WHAT
WHAT DOES THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM ISSUE -- FOUR
OH SEVEN THE FAMILY HOME AGENCY
OVERSIGHT AND WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ECHO MY COMMENTS ON ISSUE -- FOR
TEN FROM COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
PREVIOUSLY STATED -- THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT THE
CLIENTS AND THE SERVICE IS
PROVIDED TO THE CLIENTS AND WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
THEM IN MIND -- PICKING AND
CHOOSING WHAT WE DO AND WHAT WE
DON'T DO WAS UNFAIR WHICH IS WHY
WE SUPPORT 8% ACROSS THE BOARD
AS CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE -- TO
BE HAD SO WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEVIN
ROTH I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK I HAVE -- A DOCUMENT FOR
THE COMMITTEE AND THIS DOCUMENT
SPECIFICALLY JUST SHOWS 55%.
OF WE JUST CENTER CONSUMERS USE
PERSONAL SUPPORTS.
SO WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OF FUNDING OF
SPORT LIVING IN PERSONAL
ASSISTANTS BUT IT LEAVES OUT
RESPITE WHICH PROVIDES WHICH IS
USED BY 32% OF REGIONAL CLIENTS.
AND ALSO INDEPENDENT LIVING 6%
SAYS 38% PEOPLE AND IT'S A
SURPRISINGLY SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
CURRENTLY THERE -- THOSE FOR
THIS PERSONAL SPORTS ONLY USE UP
18% OF REGIONAL CENTER BUDGET.
THE ROLLOUT THAT SEE SOMEONE HAS
SUPPORTED AND THE RICH THE SPORT
WITH SOME FOR MINOR FIXES WOULD
JUST RESULT IN AN EXTRA 6% -- OF
THAT AND WE URGE THAT THAT --
THAT THE DEPARTMENT AND
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER THAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MARTY EMOTO FAMILY
MEMBER CALIFORNIA DISPLACING
YOUR COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK IN
THE CALIFORNIA PERSON CENTERED
ADVOCACY.
PARTNERSHIP IN THE PASSWORD --
COLLABORATIVE FIRST -- ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT THE INCLUSION
OF INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
AN IN HOME RESPITE -- IN TERMS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENT I THINK THAT MAKES
SENSE.
ECHO SO WHAT THE L. LEO HAD
PREVIOUSLY SUGGEST AS ONE OF THE
OPTIONS.
NUMBER TWO STRONGLY -- SUPPORT
THE THINGS THAT THE LA -- SIX
MENTION.
IN TERMS OF THEIR REACTION TO
THE MAY REVISE ON ON THE ISSUE
OF THE RATE STUDY.
AND STRONGLY URGE THAT.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PUT INTO
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SOME
ACTUAL ACTION DATES -- YOU NOTE
TO HAVE CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
RATE STUDY INCLUDING SOME
TEMPLATES ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED
DURING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY YEAR INCLUDING.
MOVING FORWARD ON PILOTS AND
TARGETING THOSE IMPLEMENTATIONS
TOWARDS REDUCING DISPARITIES.
AND MEETING THE OTHER STATE
PRIORITIES -- WE THINK THAT'S
THE BEST APPROACH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
LANDLORD I AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF BE BERRY INK OF SERVING NAPA
SOLANO CINEMA IN THE COUNTIES --
I'M ALSO A FORMER REGIONAL
CENTER EMPLOYEE OF FOURTEEN
YEARS SO HAVING THE OVERALL
PICTURE.
OF BEING A PROVIDER OF SERVICES
AT EXTREME CHALLENGE -- WITH THE
THE FISCAL CONSTRAINTS SO I'M
VERY EXCITED THAT WE'RE EVEN
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT
TO SIMPLY ASK THAT THERE IS NO
SUNSET TO THE INCREASE BECAUSE
THAT WILL BE COMPLETELY
DESTABILIZING.
I'M CURRENTLY HAVING -- TO WORK
REALLY HARD TO BALANCE MY BUDGET
THIS YEAR.
IN A WAY TO GET AN INCREASE TWO
YEARS LATER.
OF THAT INCREASES GONE OF I WILL
BE BACK TO THIS VERY VERY
CHALLENGING YEAR THAT I'M
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW --
SECONDLY I WOULD ASK THAT.
OF OTHER SERVICES THAT WERE NOT
CONSIDERED BE CONSIDERED AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE.
FIVE LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO ALSO -- EXPRESS THE
DISAPPOINTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
NOT INCLUDING THE PERCENT ACROSS
THE BOARD I THINK THAT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT -- FOR FOR THE
STABLE.
THAT.
STABILITY THANK YOU A SECOND
LANGUAGE LEARNER -- STABILITY OF
THE FOR THE PROGRAM BUT I ALSO
WANT -- TO INDICATE THAT -- THE
THIRTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
OTHERS SENATORS I WROTE A LETTER
ASKING FOR THE FUNDING AND I'M
HOPING THAT -- WE CAN HAVE THIS
ITEM ON THE AGENDA SO THAT WE
CAN DISCUSS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY -- TO HAVE THE STATE --
THE THE RATES -- STABILIZED AND
HOPEFULLY WORKING THROUGH WITH
THE COMMITTEE THERE'S A WAY TO
PUT IT BACK ON THE AGENDA AT
LEAST FOR ANOTHER DISCUSSION AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO SOMETHING --
ON THE TWENTY FIRST I KNOW THAT
WE'RE RUNNING UP AGAINST THE
CLOCK AT THIS POINT BY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO REALIZE
THAT THE DISABILITY OF THE ID
COMMUNITY -- IS IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE'VE INDICATED THAT YOU
KNOW ACTUALLY THIS YEAR AND LAST
YEAR AND THE YEAR BEFORE THAT
AND SO -- AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF WE CAN INCLUDE THIS ITEM
BACK ON THE AGENDA FOR THE FOR
NEXT WEEK BEFORE THE TWENTY
FIRST THANK YOU.
YES DOCTOR WOULD.
YES -- GOT A COUPLE OF THINGS
WE'VE HEARD OBVIOUS A LOT OF
COMMENTS ABOUT THE PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENT AND AND HAVING TO
SUNSET AND AND I AM AND I I
AGREE THAT I THINK THAT WOULD BE
TO STABILIZING.
THE THE RATE ADJUSTMENT IS THIS
A RESTORATION OF FROM CUTS AND I
SHOULD KNOW THIS AND I DON'T I
APOLOGIZE OR IS THIS A TRUE RATE
[inaudible]
INCREASE.
THE COMPARING IT BACK TO WHAT IS.
OVER THE YEARS I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE OUTLINED
IN THE RATE STUDY IS THE
COMPLEXITIES OF KIND OF THE
HISTORY IN THE EVOLUTION OF
RATES -- THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT EVENTS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED OVER THE YEARS WITHIN
THEIR RATES SO YOU WE HAVE.
DIFFERENT WAYS SAID OUR SYSTEM
HAS SET RATES WE HAVE OUR
DEPARTMENTS THAT RATES WE HAVE
STATUTORILY SET RATES WE HAVE
NEGOTIATED RATES -- WE HAVE SOME
NEW MODELS TO SERVICE YOU KNOW
THAT -- ACTUALLY ARE NOT WITHIN
KIND OF THE THE MEDIAN RATE
REQUIREMENTS OR THE RATE FREEZES.
SO OVER TIME THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT HAVE HAVE
SET RATES AT DIFFERENT STAGES --
WHAT THE RATE STUDY DID IS
REALLY TOOK AT A LOOK AT -- A
PROCESS THAT WAS VERY
INFORMATIVE YOU KNOW IT LOOKING
AT WHAT ARE THE COSTS THAT BUILD
WITHIN THE DIFFERENT RATES OF
THOSE IN SCOPE SERVICES.
SO IT WAS KIND OF AS ZERO BE
SEEN IF YOU WILL AND LOOKING AT
HOW TO DEVELOP A RATE MODEL --
INTO DELIVERING A SERVICE SO I
DON'T KNOW IF IT.
IS NOT ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION
IN THE SENSE OF SAYING DOES IT
GO BACK AND AND TAKE CARE OF
ACTIONS THAT WERE TAKEN IN THE
PAST OR TIMES WHERE THERE WERE
RATE FREEZES OR MEDIAN RIGHT.
BUT WHAT IT DOES DO IS KIND OF
ZERO BASED AND HAVE AN INFORMED
INFORMATIVE PROCESS OF BUILDING
A RATE MODELS.
SO I GUESS WHAT I WAS LOOKING
FOR IS I WANTED TO KNOW HOW MUCH
OF THIS.
IS A RESTORATION OF RATE CUTS IT
MAY HAVE HAPPENED DURING THE
RECESSION.
AND THAT YET BUT WHAT WOULD GIVE
YOU TELLING ME AS ANYONE ZERO
THERE WERE NO -- IT WHERE THEIR
RATE K..
AS SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS.
YOU GO TO ZERO YOU GONNA ZERO
BASE BASED ON NOW.
BUT I WANT TO I WANT TO KNOW YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH OF THE ARE THE
RATES BASED.
GOOD BE BASED ON IS ARE LOOKING
FOR HIM HOW MUCH HOW MUCH WAS
RESTORED OVER TIME -- OR OR WAS
IT.
MAYBE JUST MAYBE THE LA -- CAN
HELP ME THERE.
SO I'M NOT I MEAN I'M I'M CAN
HAVE OTHERS TRY.
TO IT IT IT MAKES TRYING TO
CLARIFY THIS BECAUSE I GUESS MY
I GUESS MY MY OVERALL POINT IS
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE SUSPENSION FOR
EXAMPLE THAT WAS A RECESSION ERA
[inaudible]
POLICY CORRECT.
THERE WAS THAT WAS A RECESSION
ERA AND THERE WAS A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WERE RELATED -- TO
ACTIONS THAT WERE TAKEN THAT
HAVE BEEN RESTORED OVER TIME
THERE WAS A REDUCTION BACK AND
DURING THE COST SAVING MEASURES
OF IF IT'S A YOU KNOW.
THERE IS A REDUCTION OF PROVIDER --
REDUCTIONS DURING THAT TIME I
THINK IT'S LIKE 4% THERE IS A
REDUCTION THOSE A RESTORED THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WERE
RESTORED -- THE UNIFORM HOLLIS
HOLIDAY IS SOMETHING THAT WERE
SUSPENDED WE'RE PROPOSING FOR
SUSPENSION RIGHT NOW THAT WAS A
PART OF THE THE TIME OF THE
ECONOMIC.
DOWNFALL -- AS FAR AS SEPARATING
OUT TO GET TO THE RATE STUDY.
BECAUSE THAT WAS ABOUT ACTUALLY
DEVELOPING RIGHT MODELS BASED ON
SERVICE -- TO GET TO HOW DOES
THAT COMPARE -- TO THE HISTORY
OF DIFFERENT ACTIONS I'M NOT
QUITE SURE THERE'S THERE'S A
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON THAT
CAN BE THERE.
WELL.
THE THEM I'M SORRY I'M NOT
TRYING TO MUDDY THE WATERS BUT I
GUESS IN GENERAL WE ARE IN.
FAIRLY GOOD ECONOMIC TIMES RIGHT
NOW.
WE HAVE -- RECORD SURPLUSES --
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SUSPENSION A
RECESSION ERA POLICY -- THAT
WE'RE GOING TO KIND TO RESTORE.
SO AS WE START SPENDING MORE
MONEY ON A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS OUT THERE MY POINT WITH
THIS IS THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF
PROGRAM'S.
WEATHER'S RELATED TO SENIORS OR
WHATEVER THAT HAVE NEVER HAD
RATE RESTORATION WITH OR ARE
FUNDING RESTORED FROM THE
RECESSION.
AND SO THE UNCERTAINTY THAT THIS
KIND OF THIS CREATES HERE YOU
HEARING FROM FROM ADVOCATES
BECAUSE THEY THEY DON'T THEY
DON'T WANT THE RUG PULLED OUT
FROM THEM IN A COUPLE OF YEARS
THEY THEY WANT SOME CERTAINTY.
I WAS WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER -- ON ON SATURDAY IN IN
EUREKA AND WE HAD A HEARING TO
HEAR FROM THE AYE DDS COMMUNITY.
AND THERE ARE SOE PRETTY SICK
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
RATE STUDY.
I THINK EVERYBODY ASSUMES THAT
BECAUSE WE ARE IN A RURAL AREA
SOMEHOW THAT'S LESS EXPENSIVE
IT'S NOT.
AND SO ONE OF MY PROVIDERS TELLS
ME THIS RATE STUDY GOES THROUGH
THE WAY IT IS HE'S GONNA LOSE
35% WAS FUNDING HAVE TO CLOSE
THIS PROGRAM.
SO THERE IS STILL SOME I STILL
THINK THERE IS CONVERSATION
NEEDS TO HAPPEN ABOUT THE RACE
STUDY.
BUT I GUESS MY POINT MY POINT
HERE AND AND IS THAT
[inaudible]
THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUT HERE WHO HAVE HAVE HAVE A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND
FUNDING.
AND GOING FORWARD IN THIS.
IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE A CUTS CUTS
THE MUSTARD QUITE FRANKLY.
LET'S LET THE LA -- I THINK --
YEAH I WAS LOOKING AT ONE COME
INTO THE POINT YOU'RE MAKING AND
WHAT DIRECTOR PARCHMAN SAID --
THIS FEELS LIKE A RATE INCREASE
NOT A RESTORATION OF RATES I
MEAN THE THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE THE HALF DAY BILLING
THE SUSPENSION OF SOCIAL RECKON
CAMP SERVICES.
THOSE A RECESSIONARY CUTS THAT
HAVE NOT YET BEEN RESTORED --
AND THERE WAS A BIG GROUP YOU
KNOW IT'S PRETTY SIZEABLE RATE
INCREASE THAT OCCURRED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AT THE SAME TIME --
THIS PARTICULAR RATE INCREASE
THIS PROPOSED THIS YEAR REALLY
BUILDS UPON EVEN THOUGH IT'S
INFORMED SOMEWHAT BY THE RATE
STUDY IT REALLY BUILDS UPON THE
CURRENT EXISTING RATE STRUCTURE
THE RATE FRAMEWORK AND RATE
SETTING METHODOLOGIES.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
IMPLEMENTING.
THE RATE MODELS.
FROM THE RATE STUDY I MEAN IF
YOU WERE TO DO THAT AND
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES IT WILL
COST MORE LIKE SIX HUNDRED AND
SOMETHING.
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
THIS IS A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR A PROPOSAL ACROSS A
VARIETY OF SERVICES.
SO IT'S IT'S NOT FULLY UTILIZING
THE RATE STUDY BUT I I WOULD SAY
IT'S A RATE.
INCREASE BASED ON OUR
UNDERSTANDING.
BUT IT IT ITSELF BUT IT IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S LEAVING OUT
SOME CRITICAL COMPONENTS SOME
SERVICES THAT.
THAT THAT ARE RELIED UPON --
THAT ARE GETTING ANY ATTENTION.
YEAH IT DEFINITELY TARGETS
TARGETS THE FUNDING INCREASES.
YEAH IT WOULD JUST I THINK I
THINK YOU HEARD FROM THE
ADVOCATES AND AND THAT THAT.
THERE'S SOME THERE'S STILL SOME
CONCERN.
YOU'VE COME TO MISTER.
THIS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WAS
TRYING TO TAKE MY TURN ON THIS --
ONE I JUST WANT TO ECHO PRETTY
MUCH WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID --
DIRECTOR BARMAN I'M I'M JUST
GONNA ASK COMING WITH IT TWENTY
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
PLUS SURPLUS.
OR ARE YOU NOT ASKING FOR MORE
FROM THE GOVERNOR I MEAN.
HE HE YOU'VE HEARD WE WERE ALL
PORTION FOR THE 8% WERE ALL
PUSHING FOR MORE.
AND WE KNOW THERE'S MORE MONEY
THERE.
SO FAR WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENED.
BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY REALLY
WANTS TO KNOW THAT.
BECAUSE WE'RE LEAVING PROGRAMS
OUT WE KNOW THE MONEY'S THERE.
THEY ARE YOU JUST GETTING TOLD
NO FROM THE GOVERNOR OR I MEAN
HONESTLY WHAT'S HAPPENED.
SO WITH THE PROPOSAL THAT WE%
HAVE FORWARD WE YOU KNOW AS AS
YEAR WHERE WE HAVE THE RIGHT
STUDY THAT THAT HAD BEEN
COMPLETED AND WE HAVE THE RIGHT
MODELS AND AND WE'RE AT THE
POINT RIGHT NOW WE'RE GETTING
THE COMMENTS BACK.
THERE'S SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS YOU KNOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND THERE REALLY
DOES NEED TO BE SOME ADDITIONAL.
KIND OF CONVERSATIONS FROM A
BROADER PERSPECTIVE ALSO ON
THERE'S ONLY BEEN TWO RATE
INCREASES IN LAST TWENTY YEARS
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
WHAT?
I MEAN WE WE CAN.
GO OVER OKAY HERE'S HERE'S THE
STUDY WHICH WE HAD ACTUALLY ASK
YOU TO BRING BACK TO US AND
MARCH WHICH HASN'T HAPPENED.
WHEN IT WHEN YOU GUYS WERE
SUPPOSED TO GO OVE THAT WITH US
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT
HEARING?
AND NOW IT'S BITS AND PIECES ITS
SUNSETS.
AND WE WE CAN GO INTO THE LOGIC
OF THE CONVERSATION I I THINK
WHAT EVERYBODY'S CONCERNED ABOUT.
ESPECIALLY ALL THE ADVOCATES AND
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT PROGRAMS BEING
DROPPED OFF FOR THEIR LOVED ONES.
IS [inaudible]
WHY?
IN THE WORLD.
ARE WE NOT JUST INCREASING IT
BACK TO WHAT IT IS.
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE IN HEALTH
AND ON A CALL ON IT? TO ENSURE
THAT OUR RACE TAKING CARE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE MONEY.
IF I IF I COULD AS WELL TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT IN
IN OUR ENTIRE.
KIND OF SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
GROWTH THAT WE'RE HAVING.
IN THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
SERVING BUT ALSO THE GROWTH AND
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
HAVE TAKEN A LOOK AT SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT DECISIONS AS FAR AS
THE FUNDING WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
THESE ARE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS SUMMER TO HAVE
THIS BROADER DISCUSSION OF
SAYING WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT
ARE INFLUENCING.
REALLY LOOKING AT THE COMMENTS
BACK WITHIN THE RATE STUDY
TAKING A LOOK AT OUR
REIMBURSEMENTS TAKING A LOOK AT
THE BIGGER PICTURE.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS FROM THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WE HAVE HAD A
YEAR OVER YEAR.
APPROVAL WITHIN OUR REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE SYSTEM IT'S A
YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASE ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
FROM SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OR PROJECTED
AT ANOTHER SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION I THINK IT'S WAS.
TO MEET MAYBE A SLIGHTLY LESS
THAN THAT FROM.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO NINETEEN
TWENTY THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT ARE CONTINUING TO
GROW WITHIN OF OUR EXPENDITURES
THAT'S GREATER THAN EVEN OUR
CASE LOW GROWTH.
I'M NOT MINIMIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT OUR COMMUNITY
SAYING.
BUT WHAT I AM SAYING IS WE NEED
TO TAKE ALL OF THIS INFORMATION
BACK HAVE A CONVERSATION.
TAKE A LOOK IN OUR TOTALITY OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE INFLUENCE IN
OUR SYSTEM.
SO WE CAN ALSO THEN HAVE SOME
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS AS TO
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS KIND OF WITHIN
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM AS
FAR AS THE OVERSIGHT WHERE THE
EXPENDITURES WHAT IS THE FUNDING
WHEN IS THE REIMBURSEMENTS.
AND THAT IS WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THIS SUMMER -- AND SO IN IN
ORDER TO SAY WHERE THAT THE
TARGETED AREAS THAT THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED AS THOSE PRIORITY
AREAS IS WHAT WE PUT FORWARD IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
DIRECTOR WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT FOR THE COMMUNITY IT FEELS
LIKE YOU'RE KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD.
AND AS THE LEGISLATIVE BODY AND
AND I AGREE WITH -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
WITH I I HOPE SOME OF THESE
MEMBER PROPOSALS ARE UP.
ON THE AGENDA FOR US TO VOTE ON
BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT OF US
SUPPORTED THAT.
AND I HOPE AS WE GET INTO
CONFERENCE.
IN THOSE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE CAN WORK SOME OF THESE
THINGS OUT AND PUT SOME MORE
FUNDING IN THERE.
BECAUSE IT PRETTY SURE IT'S THE
WILL OF THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
THAT THERE.
ARE AT LEAST A LARGE MAJORITY OF
US -- BECAUSE WE DO HAVE THE
FUNDING.
SO I DO LOOK FOR TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND I KNOW YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
ALL THE I'S ARE DOTTED IN THE
TEASER CROSSED IN AND ALL OF
THAT.
IN.
AS PRETTY GUIDE YOU PUSH HARDER
WHEN THE TIME COMES BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE THE MONEY AND I DON'T
THINK THERE'S AN EXCUSE FOR
ANYBODY. TO SIT BACK AND SAY HEY
WE'VE GOT.
OVER TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN SURPLUS.
IN SORRY WE JUST COULDN'T DO IT
THIS YEAR BECAUSE WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE I I DIRECTOR THAT'S NOT
GONNA CUT IT FOR THESE FAMILIES
THAT'S NOT GONNA CUT IT FOR
THESE PROGRAMS THAT.
ARE BARELY HANGING ON IT WE WE
CAN'T GIVE ON THAT EXCUSE YOU
YOU AND I HAVE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION FOR THREE YEARS
SEVERAL MEMBERS ON THIS.
COMMITTEE HAVE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION FOR SEVERAL YEARS
NOW.
A TOP NOW IS THE TIME TO ACT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY WE HAVE THE
FUNDING.
AND WE JUST NEED TO GET IT DONE
TO TAKE CARE OF THESE PEOPLE THE
RIGHT WAY.
CHARLOTTE FOR TO THAT AND MADAM
CHAIR I HOPE.
THAT THOSE AGENDA ITEMS ARE ON
THERE FOR US TO VOTE ON NEXT
WEEK.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT -- WE'VE
ALL HAVE HEARD FROM.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE REGARDING
THIS PARTICULAR PIECE OF THE MAY
REVISED.
I THINK THAT IT WOULD BE -- AN
UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THAT
THERE'S OUTRAGE.
AT THE FACT THAT THE 8%.
AFTER THE RATE STUDY IS NOT
BEING INCLUDED.
AS MR MATHIS SAID SPENT.
TWO THERE WERE ONLY BEEN TO RATE
INCREASES.
WHEN THIS MATTER WAS HEARD THE
HEARING ON MARCH SIXTH?
IT WAS PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS JIM FRAZIER AND CHRIS
HOLDEN.
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT A DOWN
PAYMENT.
THEN THE CONVERSATIONS CAN
CONTINUE.
BUT IT WAS THE DOWN PAYMENT
BASED UPON THE RATE STUDY TO DO
THE 8% ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND I QUOTE FROM FROM THEIR
TESTIMONY WAS TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS IN COMMUNITY SERVICES.
SUFFICIENTLY STABILIZE THE
SYSTEM AND PROVIDE A SOLID
FOUNDATION ON WHICH TO IMPLEMENT
BROADER REFORMS.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A DOWN
PAYMENT.
THE THE THE FACT THAT WE ARE NOW
LOOKING AT SUN SETTING IT.
THE FACT THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
INSTEAD OF STABILIZING IT.
WE IN ESSENCE ARE DESTABILIZING
IT.
ALL OVER AGAIN.
AND YOUR RIGHT DOCTOR WOULD IT
IT ISN'T THAT THERE WAS -- THAT
THERE WAS A REDUCTION IT'S JUST
THAT THEY WERE SO LOW.
THAT THERE WAS -- THE THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX FOR
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED MORE
THAN 8% SO EVEN AT THE 8%
EVENTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO CONTINUE AS YOU SAID WITH
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
BUT IT'S STILL AN ISSUE THAT
REQUIRES.
REQUIRED AND REQUIRES.
IMMEDIATE ATTENTION AND I THINK
IF WE HAVE A RATE STUDY.
THE PROVIDES AT LEAST THE
INFORMATION WE NEED FOR NOW FOR
THE DOWN PAYMENT I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THAT WE DO LOOK AT THAT.
OKAY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ONGOING
BENEFITS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT MEANS
IT'S ON GOING. TO PUT A SUNSET
ON IT.
NECESSARILY STATES THIS IS NO
LONGER AN ON GOING NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY WE KNOW THIS IS ONE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
THAT LEAST CAN AFFORD TO HAVE
CONTINUED DESPITE
DESTABILIZATION.
THE QUESTION IS IT BECAUSE AT
THAT POINT WE WOULD BE ROLLING
BACK WE PUT A SUNSET WE'RE
ROLLING BACK AGAIN.
I I DO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM THE LA -- AND I I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE HAVE YOU.
ADDRESS EACH OF THE THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED BY THE LA L..
I MAY NEED SOME ASSISTANCE WITH
WHAT THOSE WERE.
A COUPLE OF MY DO I AM GOING TO
<c.cyan>O TO THE COUPLE THAT I I AM --</c>
AWARE OF ONE IS THERE IS A
COMMENT ABOUT THE LENGTH OF TIME
THAT IT WOULD TAKE GOING BACK TO
THE FAIRVIEW.
OR PORTED BILL WITH THE TEN
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD STAY AT
PORTER VILLE INTEL WE HAVE THE
COMMUNITY HOMES.
YOU KNOW WHILE WE ARE VERY
CONFIDENT IN OUR ABILITY TO
DEVELOP HOMES IN THE TIME FRAME
WHEN I START TALKING ABOUT IN
GENERAL OF DEVELOPING A
COMMUNITY HOME.
I'VE HAD A LOT LAST SEVERAL
YEARS FOCUSED ON FOLKS MOVING
FROM THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
IN DEVELOPING THAT COMMUNITY
HOMES AND RECOGNIZING SOME OF
THOSE DELAYS AND SO.
I AM KIND OF IN THIS THIS
PRACTICE OF SAYING THAT IT DOES
TAKE THIS TIME PERIOD BECAUSE
THAT IS SOMETIMES THE REST THAT
HAPPENS.
HOWEVER BASED ON THE LOCATION
AND BASED ON Và HOUSING GROUPS
THAT WOULD BE LOOKING AT
DEVELOPING THOSE RESOURCES THAT
I WOULD NOT ANTICIPATE DELAYS.
AND THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
IT WITHIN THE TIME FRAME THAT WE
WOULD ANTICIPATE -- AND THEN IF
I CAN SO.
CAN YOU HELP ME OUT A LITTLE BIT
SO NOW ON THE THE WAY YOU DRESS.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
ALL OF THE ALL OF THE COMMENTS
ALL OF THE CONCERNS YOUR
QUESTIONS.
SO ON THE FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR A
MODEST RELATIVE TO THE RATE
STUDIES IDENTIFIED FUNDING GAPS --
TAKING A LOOK AT YOU KNOW AND I
I GUESS ON ON SEVERAL OF THESE
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE THE
SUNSET YOU KNOW WE'VE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WHAT WE HEAR
YOUR CONCERNS AND BASED ON THE
OUT YOUR PROJECTIONS.
YOU KNOW LOOKING AT THE PROPOSAL
AS FAR AS A LIMITED SCOPE BUT
THE BENEFITS FOR THE FISCAL
RELIEF.
I GUESS I'M GOING TO JUST KIND
OF TAKE A STEP BACK AND TALK
THROUGH SOME OF THAT THE AREAS
THAT WE DID FOCUS ON YOU KNOW
AND WHILE YOU KNOW I I I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK THAT
THE LA -- DOES YOU KNOW THESE
ARE THE PERSPECTIVES THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING TO US -- WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT BEING ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE THE AREAS THAT WE DID
IT DOES GET TO SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT WE WERE INFORMED BY -- THE
RATE MODELS THAT WAS VERY
HELPFUL AND SAYING HOW DO WE NOT
PERPETUATE.
KIND OF THE THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE HAD BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENCES OF REGIONAL CENTERS
AND PROVIDERS AND SO THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE PUT FORWARD.
AS FAR AS TAKING A LOOK AT THE
TARGETED AREAS USING THE
ALLOCATION -- THAT'S INFORMED BY
THE RATE STUDIES DOES MOVED THAT
NEEDLE INTO NOT HAVING KIND OF
THIS DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SAY ONE
REGIONAL CENTER IN ANOTHER
REGIONAL CENTER THAT MAY HAVE
HAD SET RATES.
AT DIFFERENT.
LEVELS SO I CAN GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE IN
PERSONAL ASSISTANT SOME --
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT HAVE A
RATE THAT MAY BE AT FORTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR WE HAVE OTHERS
THAT MAY BE AT THIRTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR.
THOSE ARE VERY DIFFERENT ISSUES
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH
WHAT THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE.
THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO ADDRESS
THOSE -- AS FAR AS TAKING A LOOK
AT BEING ABLE TO THE CONCERNED
THAT ELLIE -- HAS PRESENTED AS
FAR AS DELAYING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MODELS ARE
DOING A PILOT AS FAR AS BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT THAT.
I HAD SAID IS THAT WE DO WANT TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION THIS
SUMMER IS TO IS BROADER
CONVERSATION.
AS FAR AS EVERYTHING THAT'S
RELATED TO THE THINGS THAT ARE
IMPACT IN OUR SYSTEM.
AND THAT IS GOING TO INCLUDE THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE GETTING BACK
FROM THE COMMUNITY ON OUR RATE
MODELS.
IT'S INCLUDING KIND OF THE
GROWTH IN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE EXPENDITURES IN OUR
POPULATION GROWTH ARE
REIMBURSEMENTS BUT THEN ALSO
TAKEN A A TOTAL TOTAL LOOK INTO.
KIND OF THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM ARE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
ON ISSUE SIX SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT WERE WANTING TO TOUCH ON ON
THOSE AREAS AS WELL.
SO AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE TAKING THAT
THE THE STEPS INTO SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT WE SEE IS IS PRIORITY
AREAS RECOGNIZING AGAIN THE GOOD
WORK THAT THE LA ALWAYS DONE IN
THEIR ANALYSIS -- BUT THESE ARE
THE THE PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE
FORWARD TODAY.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THIS -- THE
TALKS DURING THE SUMMER.
ARE WE THEN EXPECTING A PROPOSAL
FROM THE GOVERNMENT DURING THE
SUMMER FOR CLEAN UP LEGISLATION.
WHAT'S THE PATH FORWARD FOR
AFTER THOSE TALKS IN THE SUMMER
SO.
THAT YOU KNOW AS FAR AS WHAT I
THINK THAT.
THE DISCUSSIONS THIS SUMMER IS
GOING TO INFORM US AS TO WHAT
THOSE NEXT STEPS ARE YOU KNOW SO
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE WERE NOT JUST.
I'M HAVING A BENEFIT OF A
CONVERSATION FOR THE BENEFIT OF
A CONVERSATION BUT THEY REALLY
ARE MEANINGFUL WITH A FRAMEWORK
AS TO WHAT WHAT IS GOING TO BE
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN I TALK ABOUT.
REIMBURSEMENT SO IS THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT SOME OF OUR FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT SCISSOR OTHER WAYS
BECAUSE I HAD SURE JUST A LITTLE
BIT AGO THAT.
YOU KNOW WE WE DO SEE THAT OUR
OUR ANNUAL INCREASE WORK WE'RE
SHOWING GROWTH AND I CONSUMER
POPULATION BUT WE'RE ALSO
SHOWING THAT OUR EXPENDITURE
GROWTH IS IS VERY SIGNIFICANT.
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST FOUR OR
FIVE YEARS OUR EXPENDITURE
GROWTH AS COMPARED TO THE
POPULATION IS VERY SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW AND AND WE NEED TO
REALLY ALSO HAVE FURTHER
UNDERSTANDING INTO ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT PRESSURES SO WE CAN
<c.red>AVE IT -- FORWARD AS TO WHAT</c>
THOSE NEXT STEPS ARE.
WE HAVE A RATE STUDY.
THAT IS ALREADY BEEN COMPLETED
WHAT DO YOU CONSIDER THE SHELF
LIFE OF THAT RATE STUDY.
WELL THE WHEN.
THE MODELS THEMSELF ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF THE MODELS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY THERE IS THAT IT IS A
VERY -- TRANSPARENT YOU KNOW BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
THINGS OUT AND AND AGAIN LET ME
KIND.
TO GET INTO THE WEEDS A LITTLE
BIT IS TO THE RIGHT MODELS IS
THAT IN EACH OF THE RATE MODEL
SO SAY FOR RESIDENTIAL IT BREAKS
DOWN.
SPECIFIC ELEMENTS OF IT WHAT IS
THE WAGES AND COMPENSATION WHAT
IS THE COST OF KIND OF THE
HOUSING WHAT IS THE COST OF
TRAINING WHAT IS THE COST OF YOU
KNOW THERE'S WORKER'S COMP
THERE'S DIFFERENT PIECES THAT
ARE BROKEN OUT SO YOU REALLY DO
HAVE.
ELEMENTS THAT SHOULD THERE BE A
NEED FOR UPDATES FOR DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS OF IT IT DOES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE UPDATED.
SO WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
RATE MODELS THEMSELVES THE
STRUCTURE OF THEM WERE DESIGNED
TO BE ABLE TO HELP YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
AND EVERYTHING TO HAVE FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS.
YOU KNOW IF THEY ARE IMPLEMENTED
OR EVEN WITH SAYING LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT SOME ADDITIONAL --
CONVERSATIONS IT DOES LEND
ITSELF TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ADJUSTMENTS IF THAT WAS NEEDED.
BUT THE RATE STUDY WAS
SPECIFICALLY REQUESTED. TO MAKE
THOSE RATE CHANGES NOW IT
APPEARS.
THE RATE STUDY WAS -- TO BE
REPORTED TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR -- AND TO
TO DETERMINE THAT WHAT THOSE
KIND OF DELIBERATE OF
DISCUSSIONS WOULD BE -- MOVING
FORWARD AND SO WE WERE WE WERE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT TO
LEGISLATURE THIS RATE STUDY
CORRECT.
ANOTHER COMING FROM THE LA --
WAS THAT.
THE THE PROPOSAL.
AND IF I MAY NOT HAVE TAKEN THE
NOTES CORRECTLY BUT IT TREATS
ONGOING SERVICES.
AS IF THEY WERE TEMPORARY.
BUT THEY ARE TEMPORARY AND AGAIN
IT GOES BACK TO WHAT THE MEMBERS
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE STATE
DESTABILIZATION.
OF THE DESTABILISATION PERIOD --
AND UNDERSTATES THE TRUE ON
GOING COST.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
THE FACT THAT THIS IS BEING
TREATED AS IF IT WERE.
TEMPORARY.
BUT THESE COSTS ARE NOT
SO AGAIN MADAM CHAIR I THE THE
IMPORTANCE OF BEING ABLE TO HAVE
A PROPOSAL THAT IS IS PUT
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THE THE
IMMEDIATE ISSUES.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THIS SUMMER I JUST
I DON'T WANT TO TO MINIMIZE.
THE VALUE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE IN A TOTALITY.
FROM LA -- WHAT WERE THE OTHER --
THE OTHER.
TWO PROBLEMS THERE WERE FOUR
PROBLEMS.
THE DIRECTOR IS ADDRESSED --
THREE OF THOSE THE FINAL POINT
WAS.
THE FACT THAT THE PROPOSAL
LIMITS THE SCOPE OF WHO BENEFITS
FROM THE RATE INCREASES SO IT IT
DOES PROVIDE.
TARGETED FISCAL RELIEF TO SOME
OF THE PROVIDERS THAT SORT OF
EMERGED FROM THE FINDINGS OF THE
RATE STUDY IS IN NEED OF OF RATE
INCREASES BUT IT DOESN'T PROVIDE.
ANY LEVEL OF FISCAL RELIEF TO
THE OTHER PROVIDERS IN THE
SYSTEM.
NO WOULD YOU ADDRESS THAT
CONCERN PLEASE.
YES THANK YOU -- WITH HE TAKING
A LOOK AT THE THE PROPOSAL THAT
WE HAVE WE AGAIN FOCUSED ON
REALLY THAT THE PRIMARY AREAS
THAT WE SAW INFORMED BY THE RATE
STUDY THAT HAD.
SIGNIFICANT -- KIND OF COST
PRESSURES IF YOU WILL AS I HAD
MENTIONED WITH THE RESIDENTIAL
WE HAVE SEEN.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE SERVICES THAT
HAVE BEEN DECLINING YEAR OVER
YEAR -- AND THEN ALSO WITH THE
AND I I CERTAINLY RESPECT THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SERVICES AND SERVICE MODELS THAT
ARE IN ALIGNMENT AND THAT WILL
BE IN COMPLIANCE AND CERTAINLY.
JUST WITH THAT NEW FEDERAL ROLE
WITH THE PROPOSAL OF SAYING THAT
WE HAVE THE TARGETED AREAS THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT ARE
CONSISTENT IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
FEDERAL RULE DOESN'T MEAN THAT
OTHERS WILL NOT BE -- BUT AT
THIS TIME THESE ARE THE
PROPOSALS THAT WE PUT FORWARD AS
THE PRIORITIES AND AGAIN IT'S
ADDRESSING THE RESIDENTIAL IT'S
ADDRESSING THOSE PROPOSALS OR
THOSE SERVICES THAT ARE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH EIGHT CBS -- AND
THEN THE SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
DO TOUCH THE NUMBER OF THE
DIFFERENT SERVICE MODELS AS A
SUPPLEMENTAL STAFFING -- AND
THEN MAKING SURE THAT WITH THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SUSPENSION THAT
THAT IS -- A PROPOSAL THAT DOES
TOUCH THE NON RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES.
JUST ONE POINT ON THE ON THE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THAT DOES
AFFECT THE NON WE AGREE IT DOES
AFFECT THE NON RESIDENTIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS BUT THE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE HAS BEEN
SUSPENDED SINCE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN SO TO CONTINUE
THAT SUSPENSION DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WAS
CURRENT WHAT WAS PROVIDED IN THE
CURRENT -- BUDGET YEAR.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY. TO LIKE TO
RESPOND.
THAT'S BASED ON THE NUMBER OF OF
DAYS THAT HAVE BEEN PROJECTED.
I THINK THAT IS ACCURATE THAT
MANY OF THOSE DAYS THAT ARE
PROJECTED HOWEVER THERE'S NOT
ALL OF THOSE SERVICE PROVIDERS I
THINK MANY OF THEM.
STILL MAY BE -- RECOGNIZING A
NUMBER OF KIND OF THOSE HOLIDAYS
OR OR DAYS OFF AND SO BEING ABLE
TO PROPOSE THEN LOOKING AT HOW
TO STANDARDIZE THAT THAT IS.
KIND OF LIFTING THAT.
GIVES THEM SOME ASSURANCE THAT
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
HANGING OVER THEIR HEAD -- WHICH
I THINK WE HAVE HEARD FROM OUR
COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN A GREAT
CONCERN.
WIRE THE FUNDS FOR THE STATE AND
REGIONAL CENTERS ON GOING.
SO THOSE ARE FUNDS THAT WE WOULD
SEE THAT WOULD STILL PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT TO THE SYSTEM THAT
WOULD NEED TO CONTINUE -- SO IN
THE INSTANCE OF THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER AS FAR AS
THE THAT THEY WOULD HAVE INTO
THE SYSTEM -- THAT WOULD BE AN
AREA THAT WOULD NEED TO CONTINUE
AND THEN ALSO WITH THE
PROJECTION THAT WE HAVE THAT ALL
TALK ALSO ON THE ISSUE SIX ONE
OF THE AREAS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE SUPPORT A LIVING PROVIDERS
AND A COUPLE OF THEM AS FAR AS A
REQUIREMENT FOR BACKGROUND CHECK.
THAT THE FUNDING THAT WE WOULD
REQUEST FOR THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
BE TO SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS --
TO DO THAT BACKGROUND CHECKS ON
THOSE DIFFERENT SERVICE LINES
THAT TO CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE
THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU A QUESTION TO FINANCE
[inaudible]
WHY?
WHY DID THE ADMINISTRATION
SELECT THESE LAST TWO PROGRAMS
[inaudible] FOR SUNSET.
ALL.
THAT JAKE POOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO IT -- AS AS WAS YOU
KNOW -- MENTIONED IN THE MAYOR
VISION WE DO HAVE -- A REVENUE
PROBLEM IN THE OUT YEARS THAT IS
ONE FACTOR AND I THINK THE OTHER.
FACTORS THAT THIS IS A A VERY --
FAST GROWING -- PROGRAM --
SIMILAR TO THE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED -- IN THE
MAY REVISION.
AND I THINK WITH WHAT WHAT THIS
GOVERNOR'S REALLY STRESSING
THESE ARE PRIORITIES FOR HIM BUT
WHAT HE HAS REALLY BEEN
STRESSING IS. TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE OUR FISCAL HOUSE IN ORDER
AND ARE ABLE TO WEATHER A
RECESSION -- WHICH YOU KNOW.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED YET BUT
LIKELY IS COMING AT SOME POINT
IN -- IN THE YOU KNOW NEAR
FUTURE -- AND I THINK IT'S EVEN
BEEN MENTIONED -- AS PART OF
THEIR MAY REVISION OVERVIEW HE
GAVE THAT I MEAN WE CALIFORNIA
IS STANDS TO LOSE.
IT COULD BE UP TO SIXTY BILLION
IN IN REVENUES -- DURING A
RECESSION SO.
HE WANTS TO CONTINUE WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN A A ROBUST
RESERVE FOR EMERGENCIES AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE -- YOU
KNOW WHAT THERE ARE SOME AREAS
WHERE WE'VE WE'VE HAD -- TO PULL
BACK -- ON PERMANENCY -- WE'RE
HOPING IN THE FUTURE THAT THAT
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
DOWN THIS PATH BUT AT THIS POINT --
THESE THESE SEVERAL PROGRAMS
WHERE WE'VE -- PROPOSED THAT THE
SUNSET -- YOU KNOW THERE THE IT
IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO THE TWO
ISSUES ONE IS THE REVENUES AND
ONE IS HOW CAN WE WORK START
CONTAINING COSTS IN THESE
PROGRAMS.
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE -- TO
THE PROGRAMS BUT AT A AT A
HIGHER QUALITY BUT WITH MORE
COUNT ABILITY.
THE THE THE FOR STATEMENT THAT
YOU MADE WAS RIPPED THERE'S A
REVENUE PROBLEM IN OUT YEARS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT IF WE DO HAVE
REVENUE PROBLEMS IN OUT YEARS
THERE WILL HAVE TO BE
ADJUSTMENTS JUST LIKE THERE WERE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN NOT JUST ON
THIS PROGRAM BUT ON SO MANY
PROGRAMS.
THE NEED IS NOW.
AND THE NEED FOR THE NEED FOR
THE FUNDING IS NOW ON THE NEED
FOR THE STABILIZATION IS NOW --
SO THE THE THE THE FACT THAT
THAT THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT
REVENUE IN OUT YEARS -- I'M
SORRY IT MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE I'M
NEW HERE.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
DOCTOR WOULD MAKE THAT COMMENT
THAT -- THAT WE'RE WE'RE IN
WE'VE GOT THE SURPLUS WE BELIEVE
THERE THERE WITH THIS IS THE
TIME IF WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES. TO SHOW WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS ALL ABOUT.
WE DO TAKE CARE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE WE DO TAKE CARE OF
OUR COMMUNITY THAT IS THAT HAS
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
TAKE CARE OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
HAS BEEN WAITING. FOR YEARS. FOR
US TO BE IN THE POSITION WE'RE
IN NOW.
THAT'S WHAT CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT
AND SO WHEN WHEN I GET THE THE
THE THE THE LETTERS AND THE
EMAILS AND THE CALLS.
ABOUT THE OUTRAGE SPECIFICALLY
ON THIS.
I'VE GOT TO TELL THE COMMUNITY.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I'M OUTRAGE.
TO BECAUSE THIS IS THE TIME IF
THERE'S EVER A TIME THIS IS THE
TIME TO FIND A WAY TO TAKE CARE
OF THE COMMUNITY.
THAT AS I SAID AS BEEN WAITING A
LONG LONG TIME.
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT REVENUE
PROBLEMS IN THE OUT YEARS ARE
THERE -- IT'S VERY SPECIFICALLY
THESE THESE ARE THE TWO PROGRAMS
THAT YOU FEEL THAT.
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE SUNSET OR
IS THERE GOING TO BE AN
EVALUATION TO DETERMINE WHETHER
TO REMOVE THE SUNSET.
I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS -- AN
EVALUATION PROCESS ON GOING --
AT THIS TIME THIS IS THIS IS THE
PROPOSAL I WILL SAY THAT WE ARE
I MEAN THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSINGINCREASES.
AT THIS TIME -- SO.
YOU KNOW IT IT IT REALLY COMES
BACK TO WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO
BUDGET. FOR YOU KNOW A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD CURRENT YEAR THROUGH
BUDGET YEAR PLUS -- THREE SO --
YOU KNOW THE OUTLOOK IS NOT GOOD
IN THOSE YEARS OF COURSE AS AS
WE GET CLOSER WE WILL NEED TO
SEE.
I MEAN WILL HAVE REVENUE UPDATES
WILL HAVE YOU KNOW THE
PROJECTIONS WILL CHANGE AND THAT
WILL TELL US A LITTLE BIT MORE.
I MEAN THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
WE WE CAN SAY NOW THAT WE CAN
AFFORD THESE INCREASES FOR YOU
KNOW. TWO FULL YEARS AND AFTER
THAT WE CAN'T AND THERE'S A LOT
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
OTHER.
YOU KNOW PROGRAMS THAT WILL HAVE
TO LOOK AT IF WE DO RUN INTO A
RECESSION -- YOU KNOW.
WELL I I I THINK THE IDEA THAT
WE HAVE BEEN WE STRIVE TOWARDS
IS.
YOU KNOW WE WOULD WE WOULD
RATHER BE UP FRONT NOW THAT THAT --
REDUCTIONS MAY BE MAY BE COMING
RATHER THAN HAVING TO TURN
AROUND AND MAKE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS.
IN IN FUTURE YEARS WHICH STILL
MAIN HAVE TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
YEAH I I GUESS I AM I I GUESS I
CONCEPT OF SUNSET -- UP THERE WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO BUDGET
ADJUSTMENTS GOING FORWARD THERE
I THINK PART OF THE ANGST FOR ME
IS THAT WE'RE WE'RE SAYING.
THAT THESE ARE GOING TO SUNSET
SO YOU ARE CREATING UNCERTAINTY.
WE JUST SAW. SIXTEEN POSITIONS
THAT WERE ASKED FOR BY THE
ADMINISTRATION -- FOR SUPPORT
FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN HURT SIR
SERVICES AGENCY.
ARE WE TELLING THOSE NEW SIXTEEN
EMPLOYEES THAT YOUR JOB MAY
SUNSET.
I'M I'M YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE REVENUE IS
GOING TO BE BUT YET WE'RE
TELLING OTHER PROVIDERS OUT HERE
THAT THIS THIS MAY THIS MAY
SENSE I DO YOU DO YOU SEE WHAT
THAT.
UNCERTAINTY CON BECAUSE I I I I
SEE I SEE YOUR POINT --
DEFINITELY I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
THESE ARE AGAIN AREAS PROGRAMS
THAT ARE GROWING EXPONENTIALLY.
AND I DON'T I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY AT THE TABLE AT LEAST
WOULD DISAGREE THAT THAT THIS IS
THIS PROGRAM PLACES NEVER CAN'T
PRESSURE ON ON THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND NOT TO SAY THAT
THAT IS NO WAY -- INTENDED TO
MEAN THAT IT'S NOT AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM THE ADMINISTRATION FEELS
VERY STRONGLY THAT THIS IS.
A VERY GOOD PROGRAM THAT DOES
LOTS OF YOU KNOW HELPS LOTS OF
PEOPLE BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS IS THAT WE WE HAVE TO
LIVE WITHIN.
THAT THE REVENUE STRUCTURE THAT
WE HAVE AT THIS POINT.
I'M NOT DISAGREEING WITH YOU
THAT WE WILL YOU KNOW THINGS
WILL CHANGE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WHAT I'M TELLING YOU IS AT THIS
POINT IN TIME THIS THIS IS WHAT
OUR PICTURE LOOKS LIKE?
AND THAT IS WHY YOU SEE THE
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU AND WHY
IS WHY IT IS SUNSET.
AND COULD I ASK JUST ONE
QUESTION FOR QUICK.
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
HOW MANY OTHER PROGRAMS -- HAVE
BEEN GIVEN THE HOW MANY OTHER
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN GIVEN RATE
INCREASES THAT HAVE SUNSETS.
HOW MANY OTHER PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE?
IS THE FIRST I'VE HEARD THIS SO
SO I I'M I'M JUST EITHER GIVE A
RATE INCREASE OR YOU DON'T --
YOU GIVE A RATE INCREASE YOU
KNOW THAT THE BUDGET MAY TAKE IT
AWAY AT SOME POINT.
BUT ARE THERE OTHER PROGRAMS OUT
THERE WHERE THERE ARE SUNSETS
AND PLEASE.
AND AND AND I DON'T KNOW I'M
JUST ASKING THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD JOHN
DOYLE DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
UP WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT WE HAVE
IN THE CURRENT YEAR WE HAVE THE
BRIDGE FUNDING THERE IS A ONE
YEAR RATE INCREASE AND THAT'S
WHAT THAT WAS PROVIDED.
FOR BOB AND I'M ASKING AND AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND AND I THANK
YOU FOR THAT -- BUT I'M ASKING
[inaudible]
SYSTEM WIDE.
OUT THERE HOW MANY TIMES DO WE
DO PROVIDER INCREASES.
THAT SUNSET.
I I MEAN I CAN'T ANSWER THAT
QUESTION IN TERMS OF SO I'VE
NEVER HEARD IT BEFORE I JUST SAT
ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR THREE
YEARS.
I'VE NEVER HEARD THIS BEFORE
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE A RATE
INCREASE THAT WOULD SUNSET DR
WITH THIS IS OUR FOURTH YEAR
FOURTH VEHICLE WHAT OKAY.
IT SOMETIMES IT SEEMS LIKE
LONGER.
BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW I MEAN.
BECAUSE THERE YOU'RE CREATING
INSTABILITY THROUGH THE
MESSAGING.
YOU'RE SAYING WE'RE GOING.
TO IT WILL BE OUT THERE FOR A
COUPLE YEARS AND WE WE MIGHT
APPEAL THE FORTIS WAS GOING TO
SUNSET YOUR AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO FIGHT AGAIN TO GET IT BACK --
AND AND I JUST.
SO I'M JUST ASKING HOW MANY
OTHER PROGRAMS ARE GIVEN A RATE
INCREASE.
WITH THE SUNSET BECAUSE I'VE
NEVER HEARD IT BEFORE.
I MISSED IT YOU KNOW MY
APOLOGIES MAYBE THEY'LL HAVE
CONTENT YES YES DOCTOR WITH
MARTIN WITH THE LA OUT.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME EXAMPLES OF
ACTUALLY FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS RATE INCREASES THAT ARE
ARE LIMITED TERM A TEMPORARY IN
IT KEY EXAM FOR THE PROPOSITION --
FIFTY SIX INCREASES BUT IMPART --
WITH PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX YOU
COULD LOOK AT THOSE WERE
SOMEWHAT PILOTING AND LOOKING AT
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE AND YES
ABOUT BALLOT INITIATIVE CRACKED
AND CASES WHERE THERE REALLY WAS
UP PROP SO POLICY REASON TO MAKE
THEM LIMITED TERM IN ORDER.
TO ASSESS THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
AND WHETHER THE THE RATES WERE
TARGETING SORT OF THE
APPROPRIATE TO PROVIDERS AND AND
WHETHER ACCESS WAS BEING
IMPROVED.
BUT I THINK WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH NOW AND THIS IS A THIS WILL
BE A A MAJOR QUICK.
ISSUE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER THIS ISSUE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IN TERMS OF A
SUNSET WILL COME UP THREE
ADDITIONAL TIMES FOR THIS
COMMITTEE -- WITH ME REVISION --
IT WILL COME UP ON THE ISSUE OF
THE RESTORATION OF THE 7% --
SERVICE HOURS AND I JUST ASK
THAT WILL BE SUNSET IT WILL COME
UP -- IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY MEDI
CAL PROVIDER RATE -- IN
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX THE
PROPOSAL IS TO ESSENTIALLY THE
GENERAL FUND WILL BE THE FULL
BENEFITS FOR YOUR PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX REVENUES AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YOU'LL COME UP --
AGAIN IN THE HI THE HEALTH
INSURANCE THIS SUBSIDY IS
COVERED CALIFORNIA THE AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE PENALTY
REVENUES WILL CONTINUE BUT THE
THE SUBSIDIES WILL AND AND THERE
IS YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE SO THIS
IS.
SOMETHING FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER REALLY IS -- IS THERE --
IT IS TO STABILIZE THINGS SERVE
IN THESE CASES WHEN WHAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH IS ESSENTIALLY AN
EXISTING POLICY COMMITMENT
THAT'S ONGOING I THINK IN THE
CASE OF DDS YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE SYSTEM THAT.
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAINTAIN -- NOT
INITIALLY SIR TO CREATE NEW
PROGRAMS AND AND GROW SO -- IT
IS TRUE IS FINANCE MENTIONED
ACCORDING TO THEIR PROJECTIONS
IN THE IN THE OUT YEARS THERE
WILL BE -- REVENUE -- IN BALANCE
AND IT AND NEED TO ADJUST THE
BUDGET BUT WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT --
THAT -- CREATING THROUGH THE SUN
SETS FOR HHS PROGRAMS THAT ARE
REALLY EXISTING ONGOING POLICY
COMMITMENTS IS.
IS -- PROBABLY NOT THE NOT THE
PLACE -- TO TO ADDRESS OUR TO
THE FISCAL MANAGEMENT OF THE
BUDGET STRUCTURE IS AS A WHOLE
SO WE WILL IT'S IT'S A TOUGH
CHALLENGING ISSUE BUT AS AN
OFFICE WE REALLY WANT OF
ASSISTANT AND AND HELP YOU SORT
OF THROUGH THIS.
REALLY QUITE A A CHALLENGING
SORT OF OVERALL BUDGET ISSUE BUT
BUT HAPPY TO HELP OUT.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT THE
QUESTION IS A FAIR QUESTION AND
I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU'RE CAUGHT OFF
GUARD AND TRY TO COME UP WITH AN
ANSWER.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
SO I WOULD ASK THE DEAD YOU
PROVIDING THE ANSWERS TO ANY
OTHER.
DEPARTMENTAL -- INCREASE.
THAT HOUSE A SUNSET THAT IS THAT
WE'RE THIS IS HAPPENED IN THE
PAST -- WE RECOGNIZE AND WILL BE
DEALING WITH THE OTHER ISSUES --
AS IT HAS BEEN NOTED WILL.
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS SHORTLY
BUT AS TO THE PAST I THINK IT'S
A FAIR QUESTION AND I THINK FOR
US AND HOPEFULLY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TO LOOK AT HOW
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
IS IS BEING ADDRESSED.
SO CAN WE GET THAT.
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS A
WEEK WE WILL WE WILL LOOK INTO
IT I MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF
PROPOSING INCREASES THAT THEN
SUNSET -- BUT THERE HAVE BEEN
RATE -- REDUCTIONS -- IN THE
PAST -- YOU KNOW IN A ACROSS
SEVERAL PROGRAMS -- IN ON THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AREA SO I THINK THAT
THE THE DIFFERENCE NOW IS THAT
WE ARE WE ARE ACTUALLY
PROJECTING -- A DECLINE IN
REVENUES THAT WE WEREN'T
PROJECTING -- IN BACK IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET AND THAT HAS IS
WHAT IS -- SORT OF WHY WE'VE HAD
TO PAY FOR IT -- TO TO YOU KNOW
LIVE WITHIN THOSE -- LIVE WITHIN
THE REVENUES THAT.
WE'RE PROJECTING WILL BE
AVAILABLE DURING THOSE LATER
YEARS I THINK.
I THINK THAT IT IS ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS IS THAT IT MAY SET A
PRECEDENT.
AND WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT WHEN
WE ARE LOOKING AT OUR BUDGET.
THAT.
IF WE ARE IN THE IN.
GOOD TIMES.
THAT THE BUDGET REFLECT.
THAT WE ARE IN IN THE SURPLUS --
AS OPPOSED TO BEING A SURPLUS WE
TALK ABOUT.
CUTS WHENEVER THE THE SURPLUS
WHEN WE DO THAT WE HAVE NO
SURPLUS OR THE THE REVENUES ARE
DOWN -- BUT WHEN REVENUES ARE UP
AND WE HAVE A SURPLUS.
IF DURING THAT TIME.
IN OUR HISTORY WE ARE.
PUTTING SUNSETS -- IT WE ARE
DEFINITELY SETTING A PRECEDENT
AND I THINK THAT -- IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE GIVEN
MUCH MORE TENSION [inaudible]
THEN -- THEN OTHERWISE SO IF IN
THE NEXT FEW DAYS IF YOU COULD --
GET BACK TO STEPS SO SHE COULD
THEN LET US KNOW LET THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE KNOWS WITH THE
RESPONSES.
I APPRECIATE THAT WHAT WE WILL
DO THAT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TO ANYTHING ELSE FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD SEEING NOTHING FURTHER
I DO THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
AND WE WILL HOLD THESE ITEMS
OPEN.
ALL RIGHT LET'S.
TAKE ISSUE.
SIX TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS
WELCOME BACK.
HAVE LEVY HERE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
NANCY BIRDMAN DIRECTOR DDS SO
THE FOR ITEMS HERE I'LL GO AHEAD
AND AND REVIEW THEM UNDER --
ISSUE SIX THE FIRST ONE IS
TRAILER BILL FOR THE ENHANCE BE
HERO SUPPORTS HOMES.
THE ENHANCED BE HERO SUPPORTS
HOMES IS A NEW MODEL THAT WAS
DEVELOPED TO SUPPORT THE CLOSURE
AT THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
COMPLEX NEEDS IN THE COMMUNITY --
IT WAS A NEW MODEL AND AT THE
TIME IT WAS SET UP AS A PILOT
LIMITED -- TO AND WAS PART OF A
SUNSET -- TO AS FAR AS MOVING
FORWARD OUR REQUEST IS ACTUALLY
ASKING JUST FOR AN EXTENSION FOR
ONE YEAR -- TO CONTINUE -- IN
THE DEVELOPMENT AND OPERATION OF
THE HOMES -- AND THEY'LL GIVE US
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO PROVIDE
SOME ANALYSIS TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE HOMES -- THEY HAVE ACTUALLY
PROVEN TO BE VERY SUCCESSFUL
HOWEVER WE HAVE OF ALL THE
APPROVED HOMES THAT WE HAVE --
WITHIN OUR DEVELOPMENT PLAN OWN
LESS THAN HALF OF THEM ARE IN
OPERATION AND SO WE WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE AN
OPERATION -- THE SECOND ITEM IS
FOR CANYON SPRINGS ADMISSION
THIS IS AN EXPANSION TO THE
COMMISSION AND TAKE CANYON
SPRINGS -- THIS WE WOULD SEE AS
IS KIND OF THE EXCEPTION -- TO
ANY ROLE SO TO SPEAK -- WE HAVE
CONTINUED AS WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AND TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR SAFETY NET.
IN SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
VERY VERY COMPLEX NEEDS -- WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF RESOURCES SO TO
SPEAK IN OUR TOOL CHEST SO TO TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS -- BUT AS
WERE DEVELOPED BEING TO THE
RESOURCES AND AS THEIR BECOMING
OPERATIONAL -- WE STILL HAVE
TIME THAT THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO FURTHER -- DEFINE WHAT
THOSE KIND OF GAPS ARE ONE OF
THE AREAS IS KIND OF THIS OPTION
OF WERE IN INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO
HAVE LONGER TERM THERAPEUTIC
SUPPORT SAID IS BEYOND WHAT WE
HAVE WITHIN OUR CURRENT -- A
CUTE -- CRISIS HOMES THAT IS
STATE OPERATED THEIR LIMITED TO
THIRTEEN MONTHS -- BUT WE ALSO
HAVE INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY BE AN
ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC SETTINGS AND
SO WHAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES IS
REQUESTING THE ABILITY TO ADMIT
INTOOUR COMMUNITYSTATE
OPERATED ON CANYON SPRINGS --
BUT WE ARE NOT REQUESTING --
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY -- WERE WERE
PROPOSING TO DO THIS WITHIN OUR
EXISTING CAPACITY -- AND ONLY
FOR A VERY VERY SMALL GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS AND VERY UNIQUE
SITUATIONS -- THE THIRD ITEM IS
GOES ALONG WITH WHAT WHEN WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT AN ISSUE FIVE
REGARDING THE EARLY START CO
PAYMENTS AS WE GIVE US THE
AUTHORITY TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE
THAT CHANGE.
AND THEN THE FOURTH ITEM IS THE
REGIONAL CENTER ACCOUNTABILITY
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING AND SO
IS WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT
FURTHER IN OUR EFFORTS AND THE
REGIONAL CENTER OVERSIGHT --
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MONITORING WE
WOULD BE -- PROPOSING.
ESSENTIALLY TWELVE DIFFERENT
ITEMS TWO OF THE ITEMS WOULD BE
RELATED TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
ADJUSTMENT ONE WOULD BE GIVING
US THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE THEIR
THE ASSOCIATED RATES -- CHANGES
THE OTHER WOULD GIVE US THE
AUTHORITY TO DO -- REGULATIONS
ON THE OTHER ITEMS ARE REALLY
KIND OF BROKEN UP INTO THREE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES ONE IS
MONITORING PERFORMANCE OF
REGIONAL CENTERS YEAH THERE IS
BOARD GOVERNANCE AND THEN THE
OTHER WAS REALLY IS RELATED TO
CONSUMERS -- SAFETY AND
TRANSPARENCY SO JUST QUICKLY
KIND OF GO THROUGH THEM FOR YOU
IS -- TO THE CONCEPTS OF WHAT WE
WOULD SEE -- THAT WOULD BE --
INCLUDED IN EACH OF THESE AREAS
FOR MONITORING THE PERFORMANCE
ON THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE --
WHAT'S CALLED A PERFORMANCE
CONTRACT REQUIREMENT THAT WAS --
START IN -- NINETEEN NINETY
THREE BUT WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THE PERFORMANCE CONTRACT WE DO
SEE -- THAT AS I'VE TALKED ABOUT
WITH OUR REORGANIZATION THAT
WE'RE DOING WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO DOING
ASSOCIATED UPDATING OF THOSE
PERFORMANCE CONTRACTS BUT THAT
WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS REQUIRE
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO BE --
ENGAGED MORE IN THIS PROCESS SO
WE WOULD -- HAVE INCLUDED IN
LANGUAGE THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTER BOARD OF DIRECTORS WOULD
HAVE TO ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT -- AS TO THE OUTCOMES
OF THOSE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
AND THEN WHAT ARE THE ACTION
ITEMS THAT THEY'RE DOING. TO
ENHANCE OR IMPROVE IN THE AREAS
IN WHICH THEY'RE NOT MEETING THE
TARGET AND THE MEASURES.
THE NEXT ITEM WOULD BE THE
REGIONAL CENTER PROCESS OF
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A CROSSED
REGIONAL CENTERS AND STANDARDIZE
PRACTICES -- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
COMMUNITY IS THAT WHEN YOU GO TO
ONE REGIONAL CENTER YOU MAY NOT
ALWAYS GET THE SAME EXPERIENCE
WITH ANOTHER REGIONAL CENTER.
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE'VE
REALLY LOOKED AT PRETTY STRONGLY
IS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS EXPRESSLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE JUST NEW TO
THE SYSTEM OF HAVING.
REALLY KIND OF A A STANDARD
INFORMATION IF YOU WILL THAT
WOULD BE CONSISTENT ACROSS THIS
DATE SO WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS --
WOULD -- HAVE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS WOULD
HAVE A STANDARDIZED PACKET THAT
WOULD BE INFORMATIVE TO WHOEVER
IT IS IT IS SEEKING SERVICES
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER -- AND
THAT STANDARD PACKET WOULD BE
AVAILABLE ON BOTH WITH AN EARLY
START AND THEN ALSO OUR
LETTERMAN SERVICES I'M SO AGAIN
WE WOULD -- HAD ADDITIONAL
DETAIL THAT WOULD GO INTO
LANGUAGE IN REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT IS AVAILABLE IN IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES.
AND AGAIN CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THE NEXT AYE BUT ITEM IS
PERFORMANCE DASHBOARD
REQUIREMENTS -- THAT WHAT WE
WOULD DO IS THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
HAVE THAT MACHINE READ READABLE --
SO ITEMS THAT WOULD BE A PART OF
OUR DASHBOARD THAT IT WOULD BE
ACCESSIBLE AND READABLE TO THOSE
THAT ARE ACCESSING IT.
THE OTHER IS THAT WE WOULD
REQUIRE REGIONAL CENTERS TO ALSO
POST ON THEIR WEBSITE -- THE
ITEMS THAT ARE ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S DASHBOARD SO IT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE WHENEVER
ANYBODY IN THEIR COMMUNITY IS
LOOKING FOR INFORMATION THAT
TALKS TO ANY OF THE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES AND TRANSPARENCY.
THAT THE COMMUNITY IS SEEN WHAT
IS AVAILABLE FOR THEIR REGIONAL
CENTER AND THEN A LINK TO THE
STATE TO THE DEPARTMENT.
SO THERE CAN BE A COMPARISON TO
OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS.
ON THE MOVING TO BOARD
GOVERNANCE WE WOULD BE EXPANDING
THEN THE RICK -- IMPORT
GOVERNMENT'S.
GOVERNANCE'S BOARD MEETINGS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT THAT UPON THE
REQUEST OF THE DEPARTMENT THAT
THE BOARD WOULD.
MEET WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF THE
DIRECTOR IS THAT IF IN THE EVENT
THAT WE NEED TO MEET WITH THE
BOARD WITHOUT IN ANY EMPLOYEES
AT THE REGIONAL CENTER THAT THAT
WOULD BE.
AVAILABLE TO US AND WE COULD --
COORDINATE THAT.
THE OTHER IS THE BOARD EXPERTISE --
EXPANDING THE BOARD EXPERTISE TO
INCLUDE A FINANCIAL -- EXPERT ON
THE BOARD RIGHT NOW THAT THAT IS
NOT A REQUIREMENT SO WE WOULD
NOT BE LOOKING -- TO CHANGE
ANYTHING ELSE RELATED TO THAT WE
WOULD HOWEVER PROVIDE THE OPTION
FOR THE BOARDS -- TO HAVE
SOMEBODY AT THAT HAS EXPERTISE
IN BOARD GOVERNANCE -- IN
ADDITION -- TO WITH MANAGEMENT
SO THEY COULD CHOOSE BETWEEN
MANAGEMENT BOARD GOVERNANCE SO
WE WERE JUST LOOK TO KIND OF
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE CHANGE THE
MAKEUP OF THE BOARD. TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE AREAS THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT WOULD ENHANCE ON
THE BOARD GOVERNANCE -- LEGAL
COUNSEL CONFLICT OF INTEREST
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IS THAT
THIS WOULD CLARIFY AS FAR AS THE
LEGAL REPRESENTATION OF THE
BOARD THAT THAT WOULD BE
INDEPENDENT OF AN EMPLOYEE -- OF
THEIR REGIONAL CENTER AND SO IT
COULD GOES IN ALIGNMENT WITH OUR
CURRENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
THAT THE BOARD ANYBODY THAT'S ON
THE BOARD DOESN'T HAVE ANY --
FIDUCIARY BENEFIT YOU KNOW IN
ANY RELATIONSHIP SO WE WOULD
EXTEND THATTHEN AND SAYING THAT
THE LEGAL COUNSEL TO THE BOARD
THEN WOULD ALSO HAVE -- TO HAVE
SOME -- CONFLICT FREE --
RELATIONSHIP AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE THAT AND NOT HAVING --
BE AN EMPLOYEE OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
THE LAST -- FEW ITEMS AS WITH
CONSUMER SAFETY AND TRANSPARENCY
WITH KIM CONSUMER SAFETY HADN'T
MENTIONED THAT -- EARLIER IS
THAT WE WOULD SEE TO HAVE WITHIN
SOME OF OUR SERVICES THAT ARE
NOT LICENSED ENTITIES ARE FAMILY
HOME AGENCIES THERE'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT FOR A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
SO FOR THOSE -- AREAS THAT WE
HAVE TARGETED FOR THE RATE
ADJUSTMENT -- WHILE WE ARE
FAIRLY CONFIDENT THAT MOST OF
THEM ARE HAVING THEIR STAFF --
AT A HAVE BACKGROUND CHECKS WE
DO KNOW THAT IT'S NOT PART OF
THE REQUIREMENT SO FOR THESE --
AREAS THAT DO NOT HAVE A
REQUIREMENT THAT WE WOULD BE
PROPOSING THAT AND THAT THERE
WOULD BE AT BACKGROUND CLEARANCE --
REQUIREMENTS AND A DATE SET
FORTH IN THE FUTURE -- HEALTH
AND SAFETY THAT IT WOULD GIVE
THE DIRECTOR AUTHORITY.
TO REQUIRE THE REGIONAL CENTERS
TO TAKE ACTION FOR THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
AGAIN WOULD BE MORE OF A STATE
WIDE.
ON THIS DOES TWO THINGS ONE IS
THAT HELPS US WITH COMPLIANCE
WITH OUR FEDERAL -- REQUIREMENTS --
TO COMPLY WITH RESPONDING AS A
STATE TO ANY ISSUES THAT MAY BE --
PRESSURES RELATED TO SPECIAL
INCIDENTS ARE ACTIONS -- THAT
WOULD BE INCONSISTENT WITH
DELIVERING OF SERVICES FOR THOSE
UNDER OUR A FEDERAL WAIVER
PROGRAM -- THAN SERVICE PROVIDER
QUALITY THAT FOR IN THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE THE REGIONAL
CENTER HAS A CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN WITH -- WITH THE PROVIDER
THAT THOSE WOULD BE SENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT -- WERE PART OF OUR
REORGANIZATION HAS A RISK
MANAGEMENT QUALITY MANAGEMENT
AND SO AS WERE REALLY DOING OUR
FULL ASSESSMENT TAKING A LOOK AT
A RISK MANAGEMENT PLAN.
WE WOULD WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
KIND OF FULL VISIBILITY INTO
WHAT ARE THE AREAS OF COMPLIANCE
OR NON COMPLIANCE IF YOU WILL --
SO WE CAN HELP TAKE A LOOK AT
KIND OF STATEWIDE -- STANDARDS
THAT IF THERE'S A NEED FOR
TRAINING OR ANYTHING THAT THIS
WOULD HELP INFORM US.
THE LAST ITEM IS OUR NATIONAL
CORE INDICATORS ON THIS IS THE
MEASURE THAT WE USE THAT HELPS
INFORM US ON INDIVIDUAL
SATISFACTION OF SERVICES.
THAT WE WOULD BE BROADENING THE
REQUIREMENT FOR REGIONAL CENTERS --
TO HAVE THIS POSTED ON THE WEAR
ON THEIR WEBSITE -- SO THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THEIR
COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
AS WELL SO THOSE ARE THE THE
ITEMS THAT WOULD BE A PART OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT PART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THIS SUMMER WOULD BE
INCLUDING YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE
AREAS.
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO I'M KIND
OF THE CONSISTENCY AND OVERSIGHT
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS -- THAT
WOULD -- BE PART OF OUR OUR
COULD A BROADER DISCUSSION AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE [inaudible]
SORRY.
OKAY OKAY SO ANY PARTICULAR --
SORRY ABOUT THAT -- WE'RE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING --
THESE PROPOSALS IN PARTICULAR
THE CANYON SPRINGS EXPANSION AND
THE THE LAST ONE ON REGIONAL
CENTER ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT
AND MONITORING -- SO WE MAY HAVE
SOME COMMENTS OVER THE COMING
DAYS ON THOSE -- I WOULD NOTE ON
THE LAST ITEM -- WE JUST
RECEIVED THE FACT SHEET THIS
AFTERNOON SO WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO GO SORT THROUGH THOSE DETAILS.
A LOT OF GOOD -- THERE'S A MAYOR
THERE'S MERIT IN A LOT OF THE
POINTS RAISED IN THAT IN THAT
FINAL PIECE OF TRAILER BILL --
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DEPARTMENTS
OVERSIGHT ROLE?
WE JUST HAVE TO INITIAL CONCERNS
BASED ON A PRELIMINARY A REVIEW.
OF THE FACT SHEET -- AND IT'S
PRIMARILY TO DO WITH THE FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH -- THAT PROPOSAL
SO FIRST -- AS YOU NOTED IN THE
LAST -- ISSUE IN THE IT ON THE
AGENDA -- THERE I FUNDING FOR
BECAUSE SOME OF THE TASKS THAT
WOULD BE INCLUDED BY THE FOUR
POSITIONS FUNDED IT DE DDS
CONCERN IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROVIDER.
RATE THAT WILL THEN SUNSET SO.
IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHY ALL OF
THE FUNDING NEEDS TO BE ON GOING
I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
FUNDING SHOULD BE ON GOING TO DO
SOME OF THESE OVERSIGHT TASKS
BUT IF THE RATES TRULY WERE
[inaudible]
A TEMPORARY.
A RATE THAT SUNSETS THEN WHY
WOULD THEY NEED ADDITIONAL --
POSITIONS TO HANDLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE RATES
IT'S SORT OF A RHETORICAL
QUESTION.
AND THE SECOND POINT --
REGARDING THE FOUR POSITIONS FOR
DDS WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTED FIFTY FOUR
NEW POSITIONS IN ITS JANUARY
PROPOSAL TO RE ORGANIZE THE
DEPARTMENT AND ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
OF THOSE WOULD.
DEAL WITH ISSUES RELATED TO
REGIONAL CENTER OVERSIGHT AND SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT OUR
OFFICE WILL BE DOING OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
IS TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT WHAT
WAS.
HOST OF THOSE POSITIONS IN
JANUARY VERSES WHAT'S PROPOSED
IN THIS CURRENT -- TRAILER BILL
TO SEE IF THERE'S OVERLAP AND
WHY THE DEPARTMENT WOULD NEED
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO DO -- TO
DO THIS OVERSIGHT WORK AND WHY
THOSE TWENTY FIVE POSITIONS
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED COULDN'T
HANDLE IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SYMBOLIC PART IN A FINANCE -- SO
I JUST KNOW THAT -- THERE WAS
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE SPECIAL SESSION
RATES ARE THE SAME WOULD BE TRUE
FOR EMPLOYMENT IN THE PROPOSAL
MENTAL RATE INCREASES.
IN TERMS OF THE ONGOING NATURE
OF THE RESOURCES ON THE
DEPARTMENT IS EMBARKING ON
REFORM EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN
REGIONAL REGIONAL CENTER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND ALSO IMPLEMENT BROADER FORMS --
AS WILL BE IDENTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT THIS SUMMER.
SO THIS WORKLOAD WAS NOT
ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED -- IN THE
HEADQUARTERS PC PS PROPOSED IN
THE FALL -- SO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WOULD BE NECESSARY.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE [inaudible]
WE'RE DONE.
LET'S GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
RICKROLLING TRIPS IN ARKANSAS
SHE SHE REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
ON THE ITEM -- REGIONAL CENTER
ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT
MONITORING WE WANTED OF ONCE
AGAIN -- RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE -- THE RECOGNITION OF
THE INCREASED OST -- AND SO
MANY UNFUNDED -- MANDATES ON
REGIONAL CENTERS IN THIS CASE
WE'RE FUNDING IS COMING WITH
THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA ON
THE CANYON SPRINGS PROPOSAL WE
ARE ACTUALLY QUITE SURPRISED TO
SEE THAT THAT WAS A PROVISION
THAT HAD BEEN.
I THINK SIGNIFICANTLY NEGOTIATED
LAST YEAR AND AND NOW WE THINK
THIS IS A RETREAT FROM -- THAT --
NEGOTIATION AND AND AGAIN
OPENING UP ON LIMITED --
ADMISSIBILITY WE DID RAISE THAT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE
WEEKEND AND HAVE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS AND WE'RE HOPEFUL WE
CAN CONTINUE THOSE --
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO WORK THROUGH THAT -- PROPOSED
TO BE OUT.
THANK YOU AND YOU ARE CORRECT --
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE
PEREIRA -- I'M A SERVICE
PROVIDER IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
AND I KIND OF WANTED JUST TO
DENOTE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION AS HAPPENED IN THE
LAST -- I GUESS ISSUE THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP.
AND SOMETHING RELATED TO I GUESS
IF I'M READING THIS CORRECTLY
ENHANCE BE ABLE SUPPORTS HOMES
SUNSET EXTENSION.
WELL OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE SEEING
LANGUAGE HERE WHERE THERE'S A
PROMOTION OF AN IDEAL THAT
SOMETHING IT WAS GOOD NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED.
AND YOU'RE HAVING LANGUAGE THE
LAST ISSUE RELATED TO EXTENSIONS
FOR FUNNY THEN BE CONSIDERED TO
BE REMOVED.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU
SEE THAT THERE'S SOME SIMILARITY
ABOUT THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO
TO NOTE AS A SERVICE PROVIDER --
LOOKING THROUGH THE LENS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
EVERY WORKER THAT WE ACTUALLY
EMPLOY IS BY EXTENSION THE STATE
WORKER.
WE ARE PREDICATED IN DOWN BY THE
PRACTICES THAT ARE BROUGHT UP
BROUGHT ALONG BY THE BUDGETARY
PROCESS.
AND SO THEREFORE ALL THE THINGS
WE HAVE TO DO ARE BASED UPON
WHAT THE STATE WILL ALLOW FOR US
TO DO.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THROUGH THAT
LENS THE WORK FORCE ITSELF IS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY NEEDS TO
BE ATTENDED TO BECAUSE THEY ARE
TAXPAYERS AND CONTRIBUTORS TO
THE BASE.
SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OF THE PUBLIC COMMENTS
SEEING NONE SPRING BACK DOCTOR
WOULD.
OF JUST WITH RESPECT TO THE
REGIONAL CENTER ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT -- I HEARD --
STANDARDIZATION I HEARD -- I
SOME COMMUNITIES IN SOME
REGIONAL CENTERS PROBABLY
OPERATE A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY --
I I I'M GOING AMONG.
RELY ON ONE THAT I THAT I JUST
GETTING TO KNOW BETTER IN
HUMBOLDT -- RURAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE DIFFERENT DIFFERENT NEEDS
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES DIFFERENT
WORK FORCES.
AND AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
WANT TO STANDARDIZE EVERYTHING
[inaudible]
BUT STANDARDIZATION.
IS SHOULD THERE SHOULD BE A
FLOOR THERE THERE SHOULD BE SOME
OPPORTUNITY FOR FLEXIBILITY
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND THE
OTHER PROVIDERS OUT THERE ALL
RELY ON ONE ANOTHER THROUGH A
VERY VERY COMPLEX NETWORK OF
COOPERATION.
THAT YOU DON'T ALWAYS SEE -- IN
OTHER AREAS AND SO.
IF YOU END UP CREATING SOME
STANDARDIZATION PROCESS THAT
SQUASHES THAT INNOVATION.
YOU'RE GONNA HURT MY COMMUNITIES
AND THAT'S THAT WOULD BE THAT
WOULD BE A SHAME BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING A LOT WITH A
LITTLE FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
AND IT WOULD BE A SHAME TO HAVE
THIS THIS CHANGE -- GROUP NEARLY
TO THE DETRIMENT OF SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT GET SERVICES IN MY
COMMUNITIES.
IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR YES OF
COURSE -- THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
FOR BRINGING THAT UP -- TO
FURTHER CLARIFY BECAUSE REALLY
THE UNIQUENESS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS IS SOMETHING AND THE
COMMUNITY IS IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND SO WITH THE THE INTAKE
PROCESS JUST TO THE WE'RE
LOOKING AT MORE OF KIND OF THE
STANDARD SERVICES THE MAKING
SURE THAT THE INFORMATION PACKET.
IS CONSISTENT BUT THE
INFORMATION THAT WE WOULD BE
DEVELOPING WOULD ALSO BE THROUGH
INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
WOULD WELCOME CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW MEMBERS OF YOUR
COMMUNITY TO TO ALSO BE PART OF
THAT INPUT BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT IT'S NOT THERE -- TO TAKE
AWAY THAT FLEXIBILITY AND
UNIQUENESS BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A STANDARD
COMMUNICATION OF WHAT ARE THE
SERVICES OF A REGIONAL CENTER.
YOU KNOW THAT ANYBODY CAN KIND
OF EXPECT AND THEN CERTAINLY
LOOK TO TAILOR THAT TO THOSE
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE
THAT THE VALUE OF A UNIQUE
COMMUNITY IS IS SOMETHING -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T -- GET
IN THE WAY OF WHEN I APPRECIATE
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
WHAT HAPPENS OF COURSE WITH THE
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THAT
COMES OUT OF GOVERNMENT
SOMETIMES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE
NUMBER.
SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
LET'S [inaudible]
TAKE.
AND TACKLE ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN WITH ITS.
TEN THOUSAND I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY SUB
ISSUES.
I WILL BE ASKING QUESTIONS AFTER
EACH OF THE PRESENTATIONS SO IF
YOU'LL JUST GIVE ME A MOMENT TO
CHECK MY NOTES ARE CHECK IN WITH
ME TO SEE IF THERE'S SOMETHING.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
ADDRESSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR PAT LARRY
ACTING DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND WITH ME IS
SUBJECT APPEAR DIRECTOR PETER
BANKER WHO'S GOING TO DO MOST OF
THE HEAVY LIFTING TODAY.
HAPPY TO DIE THEN.
YES.
RIGHT THE THE VERY FIRST ITEM ON
THE LIST IS THE STATE
VERIFICATION HOW PLANNING
ACTIVITIES THIS IS -- THE SAME
PROPOSAL THAT YOU HEARD UNDER
THE AGENCY BUDGET EARLIER TODAY
THAT PROPOSAL IS FOR POSITIONS
ACROSS -- THREE DEPARTMENTS TO
OF THOSE POSITIONS ARE IN OUR
DEPARTMENT.
AND AND THAT'S THAT PARTICULAR
ITEM THE THE SECOND ITEM RELATES
TO THE ATTEMPT TO REPLACE THE
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES -- LEGACY
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE BEEN USING --
WE'RE ASKING HERE TO EXTEND
EIGHT OF OUR EXISTING POSITIONS
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS THAT
THAT PROJECT IS UNDERGOING
ADDITIONAL REVIEW BY -- OUR OUR
FEDERAL FUNDING AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- ENHANCE
THE LIMITED TERM NATURE THE
EXTENSION REQUESTED FOR THOSE
EXISTING RESOURCES.
THE THIRD ISSUE IS TO INCREASE
THE SIZE OF OUR DISASTER
SERVICES BUREAU IT HAS BECOME
APPARENT -- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THAT -- THEIR
CONTINUING DISASTERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ONLY GETTING
WORSE AND MORE FREQUENT -- AND
THEIR THEIR SCOTT THEIR SIZE AND
SCOPE IS ALSO INCREASING -- WE
NEED THIS ADDITIONAL STAFF TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT CRITICAL
IMPORTANT PRE PLANNING AND
EXERCISE WORK OUT IN THE FIELD
TO DEVELOP.
THE MUSCLE MEMORY THAT'S REALLY
NECESSARY WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND OTHER RESPOND ORDERS -- IN
DISASTERS TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT TO
DO WHEN THEY NEED TO DO IT --
AND ALSO TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE STAFFING THAT NGUYEN
DISASTERS ARE OCCURRING WHICH WE
ARE FINDING IS HAPPENING NOW ON
A MORE SIMULTANEOUS SPACES WHERE
WE HAVE TO HAVE STAFF IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AT THE SAME TIME.
ALL OF OUR STAFF.
OUR STAFF RESPOND IN PERSON TO
THESE SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THE TIME REGRETTABLY
[inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
WELL AT ACTUALLY IF I MAY ASK MY
QUESTION.
WE HAVE THE PRESENTATION ABOUT
CAL FRESH THERE WAS A REQUEST
FOR IT -- 900-100-0900 THOUSAND
FOR THE AUTOMATION OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE A
DISASTER.
AND CAL FRESH IS BEING DONE --
EXTRA MEGA WHY DON'T YOU ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE I THINK.
YOU WOULD BE IN THE BEST
POSITION TO ADDRESS THEM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE STATE'S STAFF
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WE DO SUPPORT IT --
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MASS SHELTER IN
THE CASE OF EMERGENCIES AND THE
PROVISION OF EMERGENCY BENEFITS.
I'D NOTE THAT THE TWENTY
POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ARE PART OF A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY P. WISE ACROSS
STATE AGENCIES IN THE MAY
REVISION.
OVERALL THE GOVERNOR ADDED FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE MAY REVISION TO
ENHANCE THE STATE'S PREPAREDNESS.
FOR EMERGENCIES -- OVER A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS AND I THINK HE'S
TO BE COMMENDEDFOR A BUT WE
WERE MOST SURPRISED THAT A ONE
TIME INVESTMENT OF NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WE
REQUESTED.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO QUICKLY
AND EFFICIENTLY PROVIDE CAL
FRESH TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOTHING
ELSE.
SO THAT WE COULD DO IT QUICKLY
AND ACCURATELY AND THAT'S
CLIENTS MOVE THEM FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY AS MANY HAVE TO DO TO
FIND A PLACE TO LIVE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THEM BETTER
SERVICE SO.
IT IS IT IS ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ENHANCE OUR PREPAREDNESS
BUT IT IT IT.
BOGGLES THE MIND THAT THIS SMALL
ONE TIME AMOUNT.
THAT REALLY GETS LIFE SERVING
LIFESAVING BENEFITS TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THE MOST AT
THE EVER AT THE MOMENT THAT THEY
NEED IT WAS LEFT OUT OF THE
PACKAGE SO WE HOPE THAT WE COULD
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. TO
RECONSIDER THAT PIECE.
AND VERY SPECIFICALLY I WOULD
LIKE DSS AND DEPARTMENT FINANCE
TO RESPOND -- CERTAINLY I'D BE
APPRECIATE MISTER MARCUS
DESCRIPTION OF IT -- CURRENTLY
AS HE DESCRIBED THE ABILITY TO
PROCESS DISASTER CONFERENCE
APPLICATIONS IS NOT AUTOMATED
WITHIN THE WELFARE SYSTEM SO
LARGELY COUNTIES RESPONDING TO
DISASTERS -- CURRENTLY RELY ON
PAPER FORMS TO THAT -- MAKE MAKE
ALL OF THAT HAPPENED -- AND AND
THAT'S IT IN FACT THE CASE SO WE
DO THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW
AUTOMATING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AND MAKING IT AVAILABLE IS
CERTAINLY A PROCESS IMPROVEMENT
IT SIMPLY WASN'T FUNDED AS A
PRIORITY IN THE GOVERNOR'S MY
REVISION.
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT THERE
ARE LOTS OF WERE THE THINGS --
THAT PRESUMABLY WEREN'T INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISIONS.
AS GOOD AS IT IS.
FROM THE FINANCE TERRORISTS FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK WE
JUST POINT OUT THAT WE DO ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS PROVIDE A ROUGHLY
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLAR MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS -- FUNDS FOR CAL SAWS.
ARE PRIMARILY TO ALLOW COUNTY
USED TO MAKE NECESSARY PROCESS
CHANGES TO MAKE.
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCIES SUCH
AS THESE AND WHEN THERE IS A
STATE OR FEDERAL PROGRAM OR
CHANGE.
THAT FORCES MORE WORK WHAT ON
THE COUNTIES OR THE AUTOMATION
SYSTEM WE TRADITIONALLY PAY FOR
THAT.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THIS COULD BE
FUNDED WITHIN THE EXISTING A
MINNOW RESOURCES.
MISTER MAKER WOULD DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE THE MANAGER THAT ISN'T
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT COMPLETELY
ACCURATE WHAT IS TRUE.
IS THAT THERE ABOUT EIGHT
THOUSAND HOURS -- THE BETTER PER
YEAR FOR MAINTENANCE AND-OPERATIONS CHANGES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO SAUCE THAT NUMBER
HASN'T CHANGED IN YEARS PROBABLY
OVER A DECADE -- THAT
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
BUDGET HAS TO FIND NOT JUST
PROCESS CHANGES THAT THE COUNTY
FIND IMPORTANT BUT IT ALSO PROP
IT ALSO IS USED. TO AUTOMATE
POLICY CHANGES THAT THE STATE
DOES NOT BELIEVE WARRANT
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING SO IT'S
NOT.
IT IT'S NOT ACCURATE TO IMPLY
THAT IT'S IF THE COUNTIES WANTED
DUE PROCESS HE'S BETTER THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN MONEY FOR IT.
IT'S THE ERIC TO AUTOMATE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT YOU WANT AND
THAT YOU'VE ASKED FOR AND THE
RESOURCES THAT WE'VE GOTTEN HAVE
NOT INCREASED WHILE THE NUMBER
OF CHANGES THAT PEOPLE HAVE STOP
WITH ADVOCATES AND POLICYMAKERS.
HAS INCREASED CONSIDERABLY IF WE
HAD THE RESOURCES WITHIN THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
BUDGET WE WE WOULD HAVE FUNDED
IT BUT I WOULD SAY THE ARGUES
IT'S IT'S AN INTERESTING
ARGUMENT.
BECAUSE WE GIVE DSS A LOT OF
MONEY RIGHT NOW -- TO DO THEIR
WORK.
THE BUDGET DIDN'T SAY IF YOU
LOOK IF IT'S A REALLY A PRIORITY
FOR YOU TO DO ENHANCED.
DISASTER RESPONSE YOU CAN DO IT
WITHIN YOUR EXISTING BUDGET.
THE BUDGET SAYS WE'RE NOT DOING
ENOUGH AS A STATE AND THE
REALITY OF MULTIPLE.
BE.
DISASTERS ARE HAPPENING ALL TOO
FREQUENTLY ARE SUCH THAT WE NEED
TO STEP IT UP WE NEED TO ADD
MORE RESOURCES.
SO WE'VE ADDED OVER A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS TO VARIOUS
AGENCIES TO WHOM WE DIDNOT SAY
IF THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR YOU
YOU CAN USE YOUR EXISTING MONEY.
BUT FOR NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE
THE PROVISION OF FOOD TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NOTHING THE ANSWER IS
IF IF THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
COUNTIES THAT CAN DO IT WITH
THEIR MONEY SO -- I BRISTLE AT
THE SUGGESTION THAT THAT WE HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCES OR
THAT IT IS NOT THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
IS THE NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR.
PRICE TAG ON THIS IS THAT IS
THAT ESTIMATES ACCURATE.
WITH THAT TAKE CARE OF THIS
ISSUE.
I WOULD I WOULD NOTE THAT WE GET
THOSE ESTIMATES FROM THE
CONSORTIA SO IF THE CONSORTIUM
TERMINATE THAT'S THE PRICE TAG.
WE WOULD MOST LIKELY AGREE WITH
THAT.
AFTER LOOKING INTO IT.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF A
GOVERNMENT APARTMENT IF I CAN
ADD TO THAT THAT WAS THE STATE
GENERAL FUND PORTION AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT WE BELIEVE THE
ENTIRE TOTAL PRICE TAG WAS ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION WITH THAT
THE GENERAL FUND BEING MATCHED
BY FEDERAL FUNDS.
JUST FOR CLARITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF IF IT IS IN THAT YOU'RE
USUALLY AFTER LOOKING AT IT SO
IF YOU'RE ARE YOU GOING TO LOOK
AT IT AGAIN IS THIS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
I WOULD NOTE THAT KURT CURRENTLY
BASED ON THIS CONVERSATION WERE
MAINTAIN THE POSITION THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZE WITHIN COUNTY
RESOURCES FOR THE SAUCE SYSTEM.
BUT SPECIFICALLY AS TO THE
ESTIMATE.
IS THE ESTIMATE ACCURATE.
WE COULD CERTAINLY LOOK INTO
THAT ALL RIGHT THERE WOULD YOU
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO
STAFF.
DEFINITELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES START BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS
DID DID ANYBODY BOTHER TO ASK
THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE
ENCOUNTERED THESE DISASTERS
RECENTLY.
OUR POWER WENT [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THE FOR THE PROPOSAL --
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
COUNTIES DURING DISASTERS AND
AFTER DISASTERS -- IN FACT THAT
THERE ARE MOST CRITICAL PARTNERS
ALL ACROSS FROM FOR ASSISTANCE --
FOR MASS CARE AND SHELTER
ORIGINALLY INITIATED BY COUNTY
SUCCUMBS FROM COUNTY SO WE WORK
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH COUNTIES.
AND EACH AND EVERY TIME AS WE'VE
BEEN GOING THROUGH THIS WE'VE
BEEN LEARNING MORE AND MORE
LESSONS ABOUT HOW TO DO THINGS
BETTER AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
AHEAD OF TIME. TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE DOING THINGS BETTER FROM
THIS THIS PROPOSAL IS THE RESULT
OF OUR LATEST LEARNING -- AS WE
WENT THROUGH EVERYTHING FROM.
THE LAKE COUNTY FAR STARTING
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN UP
THROUGH THE DEVASTATION AND AND
CATASTROPHICFIRES IN PARADISE --
EACH TIME WE ARE LEARNING MORE
AND MORE AND EACH TIME THAT THE
RESPONSES ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT --
THE THE THE UNPRECEDENTED NATURE
OF OF PARADISE.
BROUGHT TO THE FLOOR EVEN MORE
CONCERNS THAN WE'VE EVER HAD
BEFORE ABOUT HOW WE OPERATE OUR
SHELTERS -- WE ALWAYS HAVE
CONCERNS WITH WHEN WE INITIALLY
CREATED SHELTER -- WE HAVE THIS
OUT FLOW OF PUBLIC CONCERN AND
DESIRE TO HELP THAT BRINGS --
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF ITEMS
OF DONATED GOODS FOR EXAMPLE THE
NEED TO BE MANAGED -- IN THIS
PARTICULAR DISASTER WE HAD HUGE
MEDICAL CONCERNS -- WHERE WE HAD
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE-- PRESENT IN
THE IN THE FACILITIES AND SO THE
NEED TO COORDINATE WITH THEM SO
AND THE DEPARTMENT POKE PUBLIC
HEALTH AS WELL AS LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH -- WHO PLAY A VERY
CRITICAL ROLE IN THIS AS WELL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE HAND WASHING
STATIONS AND AND TOILET AND
SHOWER FACILITIES?
IMPROPER PROCEDURES IN PLACE AS
WELL AS DEALING WITH WE
FREQUENTLY HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST
BUT NOT ON THE SAME SCALE --
TYPICALLY IN A IN A MAJOR
DISASTER THERE'S A THERE ARE RED
CROSS SHELTERS THAT ARE SET UP
WE SHOULD RED CROSS IN THEIR IN
THEIR ROLE TO SET UP SHELTERS.
FREQUENTLY THERE ALSO COUNTY
OPERATED SHELTERS THE DON'T HAVE
RED CROSS WE PROVIDE THEM ALL
THE ASSISTANCE AND PARTNER WITH
THEM TO MAKE SURE ALL THE
LOGISTICAL NEEDS ARE BEING HAPPY
HELPED.
BUT THEN THERE ARE ALSO WHAT WE
OFTEN REFER TO SORT OF POP UP
SHELTERS COMMUNITY SHELTERS --
THAT ARE A REFLECTION OF
NEIGHBORS HELPING NEIGHBORS AND
JUST TRUCK TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING NECESSARY IN SUCH A
DEVASTATING EVENT.
AND THOSE SHELTERS HAVE
TYPICALY BEEN -- PROBLEMATIC IN
AFTER THE FIRST COUPLE OF DAYS
THEIR VERY LARGE THEY'RE NOT --
ORGANIZED BECAUSE IT TRULY IS A
NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR TYPE
ORGANIZATION AND SO SEEING HOW
WE CAN HELP THEM -- SUPPORT A
BETTER MORE SUSTAINABLE
OPERATION IN TILL IT CAN BE
TRANSITION INTO SOMETHING --
THAT IS MORE SUSTAINABLE OVER
TIME IS A ROLE THAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY PLAYED BEFORE BUT WORST
WE'RE TRYING TO PLAY THAT ROLE
NOW TO MAKE SURE THAT NO MATTER
WHERE PEOPLE ARE RESPONDING TO
WIN THE IN THAT EMERGENCY WHEN
THEY'RE FLEEING FOR THEIR LIVES --
THAT THEY HAVE A SAFE DEPENDABLE
PLACE THAT THEY CAN GO TO WHERE
THERE NEEDS TO BE TAKEN CARE OF
AND THEY CAN ENSURE THAT THEY
NOT ONLY HAVE SHELTER BUT FOOD.
AND MEDICAL -- AND AS WELL AS
WHATEVER ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS THAT THEY MAY HAVE TAKEN
CARE OF AND THAT IN ORDER TO DO
THAT THAT THERE ARE ACT.
ADEQUATE STAFF AVAILABLE
ADEQUATE SUPPLIES AVAILABLE --
ADEQUATE MEDICAL -- AVAILABLE
DURING THAT -- I I I AM PROUD
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS GOTTEN
MUCH BETTER OVER TIME I WISH
THAT IT WERE NOT FOR EACH AND
EVERY DISASTER TEACHING US
LESSONS THAT'S PART OF THE THE
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
IS WORKING WITH COUNTIES AND
ESTABLISHING THOSE LOCAL
RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE ONES ACCOUNTABLE ON THE ON
THE GROUND THEY HAVE THE MOST AT
STAKE AND FREQUENTLY ARE THERE
THE MOST IMPACTED WE SAW THAT IN
THE IN THE PARADISE FIRE.
THAT MANY OF THE COUNTY STAFF
WHO WOULD NORMALLY BE RESPONDING
TO THIS WILL PERSONALLY IMPACTED
BY IT -- AND SO WHEN WE WERE
THERE TO TRY AND HELP THEM -- AS
A AS THEY MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SUPPLIES AND AND
THAT ALL THE LOGISTICS COULD BE
TAKEN CARE OF AND AGAIN
REGRETTABLY WE'VE WE'VE LEARNED
LESSONS THIS IS THE RESULT OF
TRYING TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
THE LESSONS WE'VE LEARNED.
GET AHEAD OF IT A LITTLE BIT TO
THE EXTENT WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
ON THE GROUND WE HAVE PRE
IDENTIFIED DISASTER --
RELOCATION SITE SO POTENTIAL
SHELTERS WE KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THEM WHO HAVE
SHOWERS WHERE IS WHERE EIGHTY A
FACILITIES AVAILABLE SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE OF ADA
NEEDS -- ARE TAKING CARE OF
HAVING ALL OF THAT ON THE GROUND
AHEAD OF TIME CAN MAKE THE
ACTUAL DISASTER RESPONSE GO A
LOT MORE SMOOTHLY THERE WILL
ALWAYS BEISSUES THAT COME UP
THERE'S ALWAYS NEED A NEED FOR
FLEXIBILITY.
BUT HAVING THAT AS I DESCRIBED
EARLIER MUSCLE MEMORY -- THAT
EVERY PERSON EVERY RESPONDER
EVERY LOCAL AGENCY NOTES AND AND
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES AS
WELL BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
COORDINATION -- WITH WITH --
LOCAL RESPONDERS UP TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THEM KNOW THEIR
ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES AND HAS
EVER HAVE EVERYBODY CELL PHONE
NUMBERS KNOW WHO THEIR LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVES ARE HAVE AND
HAVING ESTABLISHED NEIGHBORHOODS
WE WE ARE THAT RELATIONSHIPS WE
SAW THAT IT WAS REALLY CRITICAL
DURING THE NAPA.
AND SONOMA FIRES IS THAT THE
FOLKS WHO WERE RESPONDING FROM
OUR STAFF THERE HAD ALREADY HAD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE LOCAL
COUNTY STAFF TO KNOW THAT THAT
WAS GOING TO BE THE PERSON WHO
IS GOING TO BE ON SCENE THAT WAS
THE PERSON THAT THEY COULD CALL
AND THAT WAS.
THERE TO HELP THEM TO ME
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP THE COUNTY
GET WHATEVER THAT THEY NEEDED --
AND THAT MADE THOSE OPERATIONS
WHICH WAS ALSO ONE PRESIDENT AND
THAT IT'S TIME GO A LOT MORE
SMOOTHLY THAN IT THAN IT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE.
THAT NIGHT CRESCENTA AND THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY BEEN A LOT OF A LOT OF
WHAT THIS CON INTO THAT SO -- I
GUESS -- THE QUESTION I REALLY
WAS TRYING TO GET TO AND BUT THE
INFORMATION IS VERY VALUABLE AND
CLATTER I'M GLAD IT'S COME OUT.
WAS -- DID YOU TALK TO THE
COUNTIES ABOUT.
CALIBRATION AND THE FOODS AND
FOOD THAT WAS THE THAT WAS.
AND THE BOTTLE NECK THEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT WERE HAVING
THAT THERE HAVE WITHOUT PUBLIC
LOOK I I LIVE TO THE CINEMA
FIRES I'VE I'VE WENT TO PARADISE.
I'VE SEEN THE DEVASTATION I'VE
ALSO SEEN HOW IT IMPACTED OUR
LOCAL FOOD BANKS -- THE AND FOR
A LONG TIME -- AFTER AFTER THE
FIRES WERE OUT AND SO -- SO
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S I'M I'M
GOT KINDA BACK TO ADDRESSING
MISTER MAC IS ISSUE.
SO ABSOLUTELY WAY WHEN A
DISASTER OCCURS THERE'S A A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
HAS TO BE DONE.
WITH THE LOCAL COMMUNITY WITH
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND
OTHER -- AND ENTITIES TO
DETERMINE AFFECTED SERVICE AREAS
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS POWER
OUTAGES WE GET DISASTER CALL
FRESH EVEN WHEN THE GRID IS
TURNED OFF BECAUSE PEOPLE'S
REFRIGERATORS DON'T WORK THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS.
WE DO A LOT OF WORK IN THE
PREPARATION OF A DISASTER CAL
FRESH -- APPLICATION TO THE FADS
ONCE THEY APPROVE IT WE
DETERMINE THE THE WINDOW THE
TIME FRAME -- THAT'S FEDERALLY
DEFINED FOR FOR THAT RESPONSE
ACTIVITY THERE'S THAN AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF WORK AGAIN WITH
COUNTIES TO TALK ABOUT HOW TO
STAFF THAT EFFORT WHERE TO
LOCATE PEOPLE.
JUST ACCEPT APPLICATIONS AND
THEN THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF REPORTING BACK OF DATA TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ABOUT -- HOW
MANY HOW MUCH ALL THOSE STANDARD
TIMES OF KINDS OF QUESTIONS
AUTOMATION WOULD CLEARLY BE A
BENEFIT THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS YES WE'RE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE STRUGGLES OF?
PROVIDING DISASTER CAL
FRUSTRATED DURING AND AFTER IT'S
REALLY.
MORE OF AN AFTER FOR THE
RECOVERY -- PERIOD.
OKAY THANK YOU.
LET'S GO TO LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
THIS IS LONG YOU SAID YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY FOR FOR PROCESS I'M
HAPPY.
TO PAGE ELEVEN AS QUICK.
PAGE TWELVE DO YOU WANT ME TO
STOP FOR QUESTIONS AFTER EACH
ITEM OKAY WE CAN DO THAT -- SO
MAY REVISION OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
UPDATE YOU ON ENROLLMENT
CASELOAD FLUCTUATIONS IN OUR
PROGRAM SO YOU YEAR CHART ON
PAGE ELEVEN AS COMPREHENSIVE AS
TO THE FUNDING OF THAT.
I WON'T TALK TO AND EXPLAIN ALL
OF THESE THINGS ARE CAL WORKS
CASELOAD IS IS NEAR A RECORD LOW
ENOUGH PROGRAM IF IF NOT A
RECORD LOW PROJECTED IN THE
BUDGET.
BUDGET YEAR A FOR SSI -- S. S.
P. THE THIRD ROW -- IF IT
REFLECTS THE CONTINUED ROUGHLY
1% DECLINE IN IN THE CASE LOAD --
WE'VE SEEN THAT NOW I THINK THIS
IS OUR THIRD YEAR THAT SMEARING
THE NATIONAL TREND.
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES --
YOU'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
IN THE AGING CONTACT SAY THE
GRAYSON ARMY IS HERE.
GRAYSON ARMY IS HERE UTILIZATION
OF OUR PROGRAM IS IS INCREASING
SIGNIFICANTLY -- OTHER THINGS --
TO IT TO CALL OUT HERE THERE ARE
NUMBER OF ADJUSTMENTS AND
REALIGNED PROGRAMS AND I'D
SIMPLY MAYBE JUMP TO THE SECOND
TO LAST ONE ON THE LIST.
THE TITLE FOR A WAIVER THIS IS
THE DO THE WAIVER THAT WE HAVE
FROM THE FEDS. FOR YEARS OUR
CHILD WELFARE FUNDING STREAM --
FROM THEM AND WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING IN -- THE SEVEN
COUNTIES FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
NOW UNDER THIS WAIVER UNDER
CURRENT FEDERAL LAW THAT WAIVER
EXPIRES AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER
THIRD AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS YEAR AND
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE EFFORTS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO EXTEND THAT
THAT WAIVER -- FOR THE MOMENT WE
EXPECT THAT WAIVER TO EXPIRE I
JUST WANT TO CALL OUT THE FOR
THOSE SEVEN COUNTIES LA ALAMEDA
AND AND FIVE OTHERS -- IT'S A
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACT
TO THEM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEY'VE KNOWN THAT THEY'VE BEEN
PLANNING FOR THAT -- BUT THE
BUDGET DOES ASSUME THAT THE
WAIVER EXPIRES PURSUANT TO KERR --
CURRENT LAW I I WILL NOTE
HOWEVER THAT IN ANTICIPATION OF
A POTENTIAL EXTENSION OR SOME
OTHER MOVEMENT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THERE SOME PROPOSED BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET.
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO MAKE ANY
ADJUSTMENTS THE FUNDING
NECESSARY SHOULD THAT FEDERAL
ACTION HAPPEN THAT'S VERY
CONSISTENT WITH LANGUAGE WE WE
ALLOW DO HAVE TO ADJUST FOR
CASELOAD AND ON ANTICIPATED
FEDERAL FUNDING -- MORE
GENERALLY SO THOUGH THAT'S KIND
OF A SUMMARY OF THE CASELOAD
ADJUSTMENTS IN OUR BUDGET.
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH A LOT OF
THE DETAIL HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THERE.
JUST ELLO LA -- WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING HERE DO YOU WANT TO
WAIT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GINNY
FELLOW WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE DONE
OUR INITIAL REVIEW OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UPDATED
CASELOAD FOR THE MAJOR PROGRAMS.
AND WE WE AGREE WITH THE UPDATES
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN AND HOW THEY
ADJUST THE BUDGET NUMBERS
ACCORDINGLY OF COURSE WHATEVER
ACTIONS YOU TAKE SUBSEQUENTLY
WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
ADJUSTMENTS TO THESE NUMBERS AND
WE'LL BE MONITORING THAT AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ON THE TOP OF THE PAGE TWELVE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL AND
ADMINISTRATION BACKLOG THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF RESOURCE FAMILY --
APPROVAL FUNDING FOR FOR COUNTY
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION -- LAST
YEAR WAS INTENDED TO BE ONE TIME
AND WE'RE PROVIDING ONE TIME
MONEY AGAIN IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR NEXT YEAR TO ADDRESS
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
BACK LOG.
WE ARE TRYING -- REALLY HARD AND
AN APPRECIATE THE GREAT
PARTNERSHIP WE'VE HAD WITH
COUNTIES TO SPEED THE TIME TO
APPROVAL FOR HOMES THAT ARE ARE
THE PLACEMENTS -- FOR THE FOSTER
YOUTH -- AND SO THAT'S THAT
PARTICULAR ITEM HERE.
I DO HAVE.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ON THAT --
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE ADVOCATES --
THE REQUEST FOR THE SIX BILLION
DOLLAR SHORTFALL HERE AS A ONE
TIME -- ONE TIME INCREASE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON?
THIS REQUEST.
IF THE SAME SIX THAT I
UNDERSTAND IT TO BE IT'S
INCLUDED IN THE MY REVISION HERE
BUT SO I JUST RAISED HARM TO
FINANCE.
THROUGH THE THE ESTIMATE THE
FOURTEEN MILLION THAT WAS
INCLUDING THAT THAT WAS BASED ON
LOOKING AT THE CURRENT CASE THE
TRENDS.
OF A EMERGENCY CARE CARE GIVERS
WITH AN APPLICATION OPEN AND OUR
FABRICATION OPEN.
SO -- LOOKING AT THE FACT WITH
THE CURRENT CASELOAD IS AND THAT
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN MAKING
SUCCESSES WITH REDUCING THAT
POPULATION OR THAT CASE ALONE.
THAT'S GOING TO HOW WE BASED
WHAT SOME OF THE WORKLOAD WOULD
BE BASED OFF OF THEN WE WENT TO
GET TO THE ADMIN PORTION WE
LOOKED AT WHAT IS THE AVERAGE
MONTHLY CASELOAD -- IN NEW CAM
INCOMING APPLICATIONS LOOK AT AN
ANNUAL BASIS OF WHAT THAT WOULD
BE WE TOOK THAT CASE LOAD AND
THEN JUST UTILIZED THE CURRENT
METHODOLOGY THAT'S BEEN USED IN
THE PAST. TO COME UP WITH THAT
NUMBER SO -- I'D BE INTERESTED
I'M NOT SURE WHERE THAT SIX
BILLION SHORTFALL WOULD BE BASED
ON THIS -- BECAUSE AGAIN WE LOOK
AT ANNUAL NEW APPLICATIONS
COMING IN AND LOOKED AT THE
PREVIOUS METHODOLOGIES OF IN USE
AND APPLY THAT TO A ONE YEAR --
WITHIN TWENTY LEVEL WILL WAIT
TILL THE END AND SEE WITH THE
ADVOCATES TELL US [inaudible]
NEXT.
I'M SORRY HELLO WE WOULD JUST
SAY WE AGREE WITH THE SPIRIT OF
THE AUGMENTATION HERE IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE RAISED IN JANUARY
THAT GETTING THROUGH THAT
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS
IS VERY CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS
OF THE CONTINUUM CARE.
OF CARE REFORM WE DO HAVE
QUESTIONS ALSO ABOUT THE ACTUAL
NUMBER HERE SO WE ARE BEGINNING
TO WRITE THEM AND GET THEM TO
THE ADMINISTRATION.
OF SOME OF THAT THE DIFFERENCE
IN THE NUMBERS MAY BE RELATED TO
THE AMOUNT THAT WAS PROVIDED FOR
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR COMPARED TO
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE IT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT METHODOLOGY THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND AS WELL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
ONE SORRY PLATE PLACEMENT PRIOR
TO APPROVAL -- FOR A COUPLE
YEARS NOW -- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
FILL THE GAP FOR FAMILIES WHEN
THEY GET THE CALL IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT AND ARE ASKED TO
TAKE A KID -- WE DON'T WAIT TO
START PAYING THEM TO HELP
SUPPORT THAT CHILD UNTIL THE
HOME HAS BEEN APPROVED WE PLAY
PAY PAY NOW EFFECTIVE -- THE
DATE THAT THE CHILD CAME TO THAT
FAMILY AND SO WE'RE REALLY PROUD
TO SEE THAT POLICY CONTINUED
HERE IN THE BUDGET -- WE'RE
PROPOSING AGAIN I'M I'M GOING
FUNDING FOR THAT -- RIGHT --
UNDER CURRENT LAW AS WRITTEN IN
BUDGET YEAR STATE FUNDING FOR
THAT PURPOSE WOULD BE AVAILABLE
ONLY UP TO NINETY DAYS -- AND
WE'RE PROPOSING IN THE MAY
REVISION TO MAKE THAT STATE
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS AND THEN IF I
COUNTY CAN SHOW GOOD CAUSE FOR
NOT BEING ABLE TO APPROVE THAT
FAMILY FOR INSTANCE DELAYS IN
PROCESSING A BACKGROUND CHECK.
WELL OR OTHER REASONABLE
MEASURES -- THAT WE WOULD ALLOW --
GOOD BECAUSE PAYMENT AT STATE
EXPENSE UP TO A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS.
MA'AM SO THERE'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DOLLARS ON THE SIDE OF WONDERFUL.
I KNOW THE THIS IS HELPFUL --
BECAUSE THE PROBLEMS AND LATER
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE ADVOCATES
REGARDING THIS.
LA OVER TO PART OF FINANCE.
WE'RE STILL WAITING TO RECEIVE
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
THIS BUT ONCE WE RECEIVE THAT WE
WILL REVIEW IT AND LOOK AT IT IN
LIGHT OF THE LATEST DATA RELATED
TO THE TIME IT'S TAKING TO GET
THROUGH THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS AND KIND OF
LOOK AT THOSE.
THAT THE WHAT PROPOSED RELATED
TO THE ACTUAL.
OKAY NEXT ITEM.
WELL THE NEXT ITEM -- REFLECTS
INTO AN ONGOING -- PROGRAM AS
WELL -- THAT FOSTER CARE A
RETENTION RECRUITMENT AND
SUPPORT WE COLLEGE SHIPPERS --
AND AND THIS IS REALLY THE
FINDING THAT'S AND ENABLING
COUNTY IS TO TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES TO THE WAY THAT THEY DO
FAMILY FINDING AND THOSE KINDS
OF INVESTMENTS -- THE THAT HELP
US -- FINE PLACEMENTS AND GOOD
QUALITY PLACEMENTS FOR THE
FOSTER YOU THIS IS ONE MORE YEAR
OF FUNDING IT HAD BEEN SCHEDULED --
TO TO TO EXPIRE AND AND I'M A
REVISION INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF FUNDING FOR THAT
ACTIVITY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
HELLO WE HAVE NO CONCERNS AT
THIS PROPOSAL.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THE THE
CLARITY THAT IT'S A ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR PERMITS ON ON GOING
PROGRAM -- THE ROUTE THE ON
GOING -- PORTION OF IT WAS
REALIGNED BUT THE ME REVISION
INCLUDES A ONE TIME --
INVESTMENT -- FOR THIS PAPERS
ACTIVITY.
VERY GOOD -- MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
BEFORE SHE LEFT HAD -- A
STATEMENT SHE WANTED TO TO TO BE
SHARED WITH YOU.
SO I WANT TO SHARE THIS ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
SHE SAYS I WAS DISAPPOINTED TO
LEARN THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE DID NOT INCLUDE A BUDGET
INCREASE TO FUND FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES SOCIAL WORKERS.
FFA RATES HAVE BEEN FROZEN SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ONE WERE CUT AN
ADDITIONAL 10%.
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND THEN
FROZEN AGAIN FOR THE NEXT SIX
YEARS.
SUBSEQUENT TIME RATE INCREASES
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN TEMPORARILY HELP
ALLEVIATE THE CRISIS AND IF A
FAKE SOCIAL WORKER SALARIES BUT
ONLY BY A SMALL MARGIN.
ANSYS TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FUNDING HAS AGAIN BEEN FROZEN.
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES TAKE CARE
OF THIRTEEN THOUSAND FOSTER KIDS
DAILY WHICH IS 25% OF ALL FOSTER
KIDS.
EVER PHASE RECRUIT AND TRAIN TWO
THIRDS OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
NON RELATED FOSTER RESOURCE
PARENTS.
DSS STRONGLY BELIEVES.
FFA IS ARE CRUCIAL TO THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE SUCCESS
[inaudible]
SHE CONTINUES.
COMPLYING WITH STATE LAWS ONLY
ONE SIDE OF THE EQUATION MORE
IMPORTANTLYOUR KIDS AND
FAMILIES NEED STABILITY AND IF
WE CAN'T FIND.
WE CAN'T FUND THE SOCIAL WORKERS
TO COMPLY WITH STATE LAW.
THEN WHAT WILL WE TELL THE KIDS
WHEN THEY'RE SOCIAL WORKERS
CAN'T REMAIN IN THEIR LIVES.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE
FOR ALL THE RIGHT REASONS AND
NOW WE NEED.
TO MAKE SURE AN IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR WORK FORCE.
IS NOT OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
THIS LAW.
OUR STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT
EXEMPTS PROFESSIONAL EMPLOYEES
BE PAID DOUBLE THE MINIMUM WAGE
AND RIGHT NOW THE STATE DOES NOT
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO COMPLY WITH THE STATE
MANDATED.
MINIMUM WAGE LAW TO PAY EFFORT
FACED SOCIAL WORKERS WHO BY LAW
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE A MASTER'S
DEGREE -- SHE CONTINUES FFA
SOCIAL WORKERS NEED TO BE
AVAILABLE TO THEIR FOSTER
CHILDREN AND RESOURCE FAMILIES
WHEN THEY WHEN AND WHERE NEEDED.
DAYS EVENINGS WEEKDAYS AND
WEEKENDS. TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW STATE
BUDGET ALLOCATION OF TWENTY SIX
MILLION IS NEEDED STARTING JULY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
SHE ALLEN'S OF BY STATING I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO INCLUDE
THIS IN ONE OF OUR BUDGET
PRIORITY ASKS. TO BE INCLUDED.
FOR APPROVAL ON MAY TWENTY FIRST
THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT ITEM.
NEXT ITEM IS RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
FOR CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILY
REVISES LEGAL INTERPRETATION OF
THE ALLOWABLE USES OF TITLE.
FORTY CHILD WELFARE FUNDING TO
ALLOW THE THE FUNDING OF
DEPENDENCY COUNSEL AS WELL --
FOR FOR IT FOR THE CHILDREN --
AS IT IS IN THE IN THE SYSTEM --
FOR US -- THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL I
BELIEVE HAS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
ITS BUDGET ALREADY FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROVIDING DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL.
AND WE EXPECT THAT -- THAT THAT
EXISTING GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTION WILL PROVIDE THE
STATE MATCH FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING -- THAT WE'RE
ESTIMATING WE THINK -- THAT
BECAUSE OF THE NEED TO TRAIN --
FOLKS ON ON WHICH ALLOW WHICH
ACTIVITIES ARE ALLOWABLE AND DID
ON THE ON THE INSTRUCTIONS.
FOR ANYWAY SORRY LONG WINDED.
LOTS OF PEOPLE NEED TO BE
TRAINED ON LOTS OF THINGS TO
AVOID AUDIT FINDINGS AND DO THIS
CORRECTLY AND STILL -- GET THE
THE GET THE FUNDING AN INCREASE
REPRESENTATION FOR KIDS THIS FOR
US IS A PASS THROUGH OF THAT FOR
YOU MONEY TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FOR THEIR ALLOCATION TO
THOSE DEPENDENCY COUNCIL
PROVIDERS.
AT FULL IMPLEMENTATION WE EXPECT
OF ROUGHLY SIXTY TO SIXTY FIVE
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS
ULTIMATELY TO BE AVAILABLE
ANNUALLY FOR THIS PURPOSE.
SO THIS DOES REFLECT A RAMP UP
AT AROUND THIRTY FOUR MILLION.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
HELLO FROM THE FINANCE.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT -- TO
ATTEND I WENT -- TO DIRECTOR OF
TO MAKE IT SAID THAT THERE AT
THE FUNDING ON THE STATE
OPERATION SIDE FOR THIS WILL BE
WITHIN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH --
IT'S NOTED IN THE JUDICIAL --
BRANCHES FINANCE LETTER -- AND
SO I BELIEVE IT'S ROUGHLY ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND WHICH IS INCLUDED FOR THAT.
AND THESE WILL JUST BE PASSED
THROUGH FUNDS -- FILTER FUNDS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES TO THEM TO ADD ON TO
THE CURRENT FUNDING IS PROVIDED
ARE ARE THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
INCLUDED.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND AND
THAT MAY REVISION.
THANK YOU NEXT ITEM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT THE
TIME THAT WE RELEASED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- AND IT
INCLUDED A NEW METHODOLOGY FOR
BUDGETING AYE HSS ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES THERE WAS AN
OUTSTANDING ISSUE WITH THE
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES WE WORKED
WITH THEM OVER THE SPRING --
THEY PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DATA TO
US AND WHAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU
IS A COMBINED ROUGHLY THREE
POINT SIX THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES.
A CONSISTENT WITH AN AGREED UPON
METHOD ELEPHANT OLOGY BASED ON
THEIR BACKGROUND THE NUMBER OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS THAT THEY
PROCESS.
THANK YOU THIS IS A WORKLOAD
ADJUSTMENT THANK YOU NEXT ITEM.
SIMILARLY HOW -- WE WE HAVE DONE
SOME WORK TO SOLIDIFY OUR
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS FOR
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
WITHIN THE I JUST SAYS PROGRAM
IN JULY ONE WE WILL BEGIN
PILOTING IN A PORTION OF LA
COUNTY -- AND BECAUSE LA COUNTY
IS ONE OF THE LEADING COUNTIES
IN OUR PILOT SCHEDULE WE EXPECT --
MORE TOTAL PEOPLE BY THE END OF
THE FISCALYEAR TO BE ENROLLED
IN ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION.
THEN WE HAD NOT ORIGINALLY
ESTIMATED BACK IN JANUARY SO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IS PULLING MONEY FROM
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE AND PUTTING
IT INTO THE BUDGET YEAR WITHOUT
CHANGING.
OUR OVERALL COST OF IMPLEMENTING
THAT THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU I KNOW THAT THE
ADVOCATES OF TALKED ABOUT THE
GAP AND WILL LET THEM DISCUSS
THAT WHEN THEY DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I HSS RESTORATION OF THE 7% THE
NEXT ITEM.
OKAY -- THIS REALLY -- IS A
REFLECTION -- HERE WE'RE ASKING
FOR SOME FUNDING ADJUSTMENTS
BASED ON THE COST OF RESTORING
THE 7% AS I INDICATED EARLIER
CASELOAD IS HIGHER SO THE COST
OF IT RESTORING THE 7% IS A
LITTLE BIT HIGHER AS WELL.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MAINTAINS
THE THE I'M SORRY THE MAY
REVISION MAINTAINS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
SUSPEND THE 7% REDUCTION.
OF IN THE CURRENT FISCAL IN OUT
OF BUDGET YEAR.
THE MAYOR STREET SORRY I'D LIKE
TO HEAR FROM LA ON THIS.
JACKIE PURSUE A LEO -- WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THERE IS A CHANGE
RELATIVE TO WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
THE GOVERNOR DID PROPOSE TO MAKE
THE CONTINUED RESTORATION OF I
JUST A SERVICE HOURS ON GOING --
HOWEVER IN MAY -- THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S NOW TO TEMPORARILY
RESTORE I JUST A SERVICE HOURS --
UNTIL UP TO DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
WAS NOTED IN MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS AROUND DDS OUR OFFICE
DID RAGED RAISED -- GENERAL
BROADER ISSUES REGARDING THE
IMPLICIT PRIORITIZATION OF NEW
ON GOING -- COMMITMENTS FUNDING --
LARGELY AT THE EXPENSE OF A
EXISTING AND CONTINUING PROGRAM
COMMITMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JUST BERMAN FINANCE WANT TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS AT THIS TIME.
SITTING TEMAS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WOULD JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS MY CALLING ME EARLIER
IN REGARDS TO THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL FOR SUN SETTING THESE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS.
CLEARLY WE WILL BE HEARING FROM
THE ADVOCATES ON THIS ISSUE --
AND WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
THE JANUARY -- BUDGET PROPOSAL --
PROVIDED GREATER STABILITY IN
THIS REGARD AND NOW TO HAVE.
IT ALMOST SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
BACKTRACKING AND NOW THERE'S A
TRIGGER AND I DO NOT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS REJECTED THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE SUNSET TWICE.
BEFORE -- BUT WE'LL WAIT AND
HEAR.
FROM OUR AND FROM THE ADVOCATES
SHORTLY -- NEXT ITEM.
NEXT ITEM YOU YOU'RE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR OR WITH THE THE VOLUME
OF IMMIGRANTS THAT WE'RE SEEING
AND ENTERING THE COUNTRY --
WE'VE DEVELOPED COMMUNICATION
BOTH WITH -- SAN DIEGO RAPID
RESPONSE NETWORK AND A AND A
VARIETY OF OTHER PROVIDERS -- IN
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AS WELL --
WE ARE -- FINDING SOME SHELTER
OPERATIONS AND MEDICAL
SCREENINGS -- SOME ASSISTANCE
WITH TRANSPORTATION TO FINAL
DESTINATIONS ON THOSE KINDS OF
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES -- IN IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THERE WAS
A PROPOSAL NOT JUST FOR FIVE
MILLION IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR THAT WE'RE NOW IN BUT ALSO
TWENTY MILLION INTO THE BUDGET
YEAR -- THIS NUMBER THAT YOU SEE
HERE OF SEVEN POINT THREE
REFLECTS COMMITMENTS WE'VE MADE
TO SHELTERS ALREADY FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR AND OUR ONGOING
OPERATIONS.
AND SO RATHER THAN LEAVE ALL
TWENTY MILLION WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO ALLOCATE TO US THE
BEEN TRANSFERRED DIRECTLY INTO
OUR BUDGET AND THE MAYOR
REVISION -- TO AVOID THAT AND
AND THAT BALANCE IS STILL
REMAINS TWENTY MILLION IN TOTAL --
WITH THEIR THE BALANCE OF THIS
ITEM -- REMAINING IN THE IN THE
PROPOSED RAPID RESPONSE FUND FOR
DO F. ALLOCATION.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S RESPONSE WAS --
IMMEDIATE AND VERY HUMANE.
AND WE WE WE THE ASSEMBLY
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT.
AND I KNOW THAT WE WILL BE DOING
THE SAME MAKING SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE REFLECTS THAT --
ANYTHING FROM LA YOU.
CHAS ALOE WITH THE LA -- WE'VE
YOU THIS ADJUSTMENT AS LARGELY
TECHNICAL IN NATURE SO I'VE OF
COMMENTS [inaudible]
NEXT ITEM.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
LAST ONE MADAM CHAIR -- OUR TEAM
IS REALLY PHENOMENAL ON THIS
ITEM YES -- AS YOU'RE PROBABLY
AWARE A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS OF
HAD REVISED ADMIN BUDGETING
METHODOLOGIES IN THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS I I JUST MENTIONED
EARLIER WE IMPLEMENTED ONE FOR
IHS US -- AND WE DID -- THE NEXT
ITERATION OF THAT THE CAL WORKS
A METHODOLOGY HERE.
I WE FOCUSED ON BIG CASE
MANAGEMENT AND WILL BE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE DIRECT
SERVICES PORTION OF THE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES BUDGET.
THIS IS THE PORTION OF THE
BUDGET IN THE IN THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES THAT SUPPORTS PEOPLE'S
EFFORTS TO EITHER PURSUE
EDUCATION OR WORK ACTIVITIES --
AND SO REFLECTING THAT NEW
BUDGET METHODOLOGY AND IN THE
BUDGET HERE'S A A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT IN THE SUPPORT OF
THOSE POPULATIONS AND THE
COUNTIES THAT DO THAT VITAL WORK.
AND I AND I KNOW THAT FROM --
COUNTIES I THINK THE THE BIGGEST
ISSUE AND WE'LL HEAR FROM THEM
LATER.
IS THE START TIME THE START DATE --
ONE MORE TIME AND PERHAPS HAVING
A START DATE JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY RATHER THAN AS
NOTED.
I WOULD HEAR FROM THE ADVOCATES
LATER ON THAT.
THE PIECE THAT I DIDN'T HEAR
THAT YOU DID REFER TO WAS THAT
THE PROPOSAL TO SEPARATE CHILD
CARE WITHIN A SINGLE ALLOCATION
INTO ITS OWN DEDICATED FUNDING
POT WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH
THE NEW BUDGETING METHODOLOGY.
AND SO THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS FROM COUNTIES
APPRECIATE THEM BRING INTO US IN
THAT CONVERSATION CAN CONTINUE
OF COURSE.
THANK YOU NEXT ITEM.
CAROL WORKS OUT COMES AN
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW WE CALL
THIS CAL OR THIS IS THE
CULMINATION OF ABOUT A YEAR AND
A HALF OF STAKEHOLDER ACTIVITIES --
DETERMINING A NUMBER OF MEASURES
THAT CAN BE USED -- IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROGRAM IS IS
PERFORMING THE WAY THAT WE WANT
TO DO IT REQUIRES COUNTY REVIEW
OF ITS PROGRAM PERIODICALLY AND
THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU HERE.
IS INITIAL FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
TO BEGIN -- THE THE EFFORT TO
IMPLEMENT CAL OR BOTH IN TERMS
OF DATA REPORTING AND AND ALSO
SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATION
CHANGES THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE.
SO REALLY HAPPY TO SEE THAT
EFFORT MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU NEXT ITEM.
NEXT ITEM THIS IS NOT NEW WE
HAVE A CONTRACT THAT WE USE WE
CALL IT WORK NUMBER IT'S THE
NUMBER.
THAT COUNTIES CALL TO VERIFY
THAT PEOPLE ARE WORKING AND WHAT
THEIR INCOME IS IT ALLEVIATES
THE BURDEN ON CLIENTS ARE HAVING
TO BRING PAYCHECK STUBS INTO THE
OFFICE SENATE FACILITATES A MORE
RAPID VERIFICATION ON THE SIDE
OF ELIGIBILITY WORKERS.
IT'S PROVEN TO BE USEFUL ENOUGH
THAT IT'S COSTS OF MORE THAN
DOUBLE BECAUSE OF WITH THE
UTILIZATION AS PER CALL HE
SENSUALLY -- OR PER CLICK --
THERE'S AN ONLINE OPTION AS WELL
SO WE HAVE A BUCKET OF CAL WORKS
CONTRACTS IN A SINGLE LINE ITEM
IN THE BUDGET AND WE'RE SIMPLY
CARVING THIS ONE OUT AND MAKING
ITS OWN AND PROVIDING US -- THE
AUGMENTATION TO REFLECT ITS
ACTUAL COST.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM.
BUT THE NEXT ONE ALTHOUGH IT
SAYS REVISED ASSUMPTIONS AND ITS
TITLE IT'S NOT REALLY REVISED
ASSUMPTIONS WHAT WE'RE DONE AND
I'M A REVISION IS OUT FUNDING TO
THE HOME VISITING PROGRAM TO
MATCH THE CURRENT STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS.
WHERE THERE'S NO LIMITATION ON
THE AGE OF THE PARENT WHO HAS A
CHILD IN ORDER FOR THEM TO GET
SERVICES?
SO THIS IS REALLY PUTTING THE
MONEY INTO MATCH WHAT THE LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES.
IF YOU ADVOCATES ARE ASKING FOR
A NO COST TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL LANGUAGE -- WHAT IS THE
RESPONSE FROM THE ADMINISTRATION?
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
THE THEIR TRAILER BILL REQUEST
THAT ANY CHILD'S AGE -- ZERO TO
TO BE BE -- ABLE TO ACCESS THE
SERVICES AS WELL.
I WOULD SAY ON A POLICY BASIS
WERE FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
THAT'S EXACTLY THE POPULATION
THAT HOME VISITING PROGRAMS
BENEFIT.
ON THE FISCAL SIDE I WOULD
SIMPLY SAY THAT WE'RE NOT FAR
ENOUGH AND IMPLEMENTATION WHERE
I HAVE ACTUAL DATA ON TAKE UP
RATES ARE BUDGET IS PURELY --
AND A BUDGET BASED ON
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE NUMBER OR
PERCENTAGE OF ALL ALL FAMILIES
THAT ARE POSSIBLY ELIGIBLE THAT
WOULD AGREED TO PARTICIPATE THIS
IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM NOT A
MANDATORY PROGRAM -- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WOULDN'T
CHANGE UNDER THE ADVOCATE
PROPOSAL SO BUT GIVEN THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO HAVE A
FISCAL COMMENT BUT WE COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THE POLICY INTENT.
WITH WITH REGARD TO THE LANGUAGE
OF WOOD.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE LAW CAN ONLY
BE INTO IMPLEMENTED TO THE
DEGREE THAT WE HAVE THE FUNDING --
SO THE THE IT SEEMS THAT THE
REQUEST OF THE ADVOCATES --
MAKING A UNIVERSAL OFFER HOME
VISITING -- WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE.
WOULD BE MORE APPROPRIATE HERE.
IS THERE A REASON WHY THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
SPECIFICALLY -- THAT THE
ADVOCATES ARE REQUESTING -- IS
THERE SOMETHING IN PARTICULAR
THAT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
ISN'T IS NOT AGREEMENT WITH.
NO I I CONFESS IT'S BEEN A FEW --
HAS BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
SINCE I PERSONALLY READ THAT
LANGUAGE BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE BUILT THIS
PROGRAM AND WE ENACTED A STATUTE
WE DELIVER LEASES SAID WE WANTED
TO PRIORITIZE HELP FOR FIRST
TIME PARENTS WITH YOUNGER KIDS.
AND NOW WITH THIS THAT LANGUAGE
WOULD GO BEYOND THAT
PRIORITIZATION TO FIND ANY CHILD
WHETHER IT'S YOUR SECOND THIRD
OR FOURTH CHILD.
IN THAT AGE RANGE -- YOU KNOW
THAT OBVIOUSLY MAKES SENSE BUT
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
FURTHERANCE A OF THE POLICY
PRIORITY WE SET FORTH WHEN THAT
WHEN THE PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY
IMPLEMENTED.
I WOULD ELSE THAT -- THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION TAKE A FRESH LOOK
AT THE LANGUAGE.
BECAUSE THERE IS.
THERE IS GREAT INTEREST IN
IMPLEMENTING THAT LANGUAGE.
INTERNET WE CAN COMMIT TO THAT
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS FROM LA -- SPECIFICALLY
ON THAT ISSUE.
YES THANK YOU -- ONE OF THE
POINTS WE BROUGHT UP LAST YEAR
IN IN JANUARY WHEN THE HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE WAS
INITIALLY PROPOSED WAS THAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME. TO TO
GET A FEEL FOR THE THE BUDGET
REQUIREMENTS IT'S A NEW PROGRAM --
THAT THE STATE WAS OPERATING AND
EVEN A YEAR.
IN THE FUTURE NOW WHERE WE ARE
TODAY WE STILL KNOW VERY LITTLE
ABOUT HOW IMPLEMENTATION IS
GOING -- THE FOR THE VERY FIRST
COUNTIES HAVE JUST NOW -- GOTTEN
THE FIRST HOME VISITING SERVICES
UP AND GOING IN THE HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE IT'LL BE
SOME TIME TO ECHO -- PREVIOUS
COMMENTS BEFORE REBEL TO TO FINE
TUNE THE BUDGET METHODOLOGY --
OUR COMMENTS REGARDING THE THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA WHETHER
UNIVERSAL OR MORE NARROW -- AS
THE MINISTRATION IS NOTED THE
PROGRAM AS IT IS IS NOT AN
ENTITLEMENT -- A COUNTIES ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES BASED
ON THE FUNDING ALLOCATION THAT
THEY RECEIVE.
AND SO THERE'S SOME FLEXIBILITY
OF THE STATE DECIDED TO MAKE A
MORE UNIVERSAL OFFER.
THE FISCAL CONSTRAINT WOULD
STILL BE IN PLACE -- COUNTY'S
ONLY BE ABLE TO OFFER SERVICES
TO THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES OUT
FOR WHICH THEY HAD -- RESOURCES
AVAILABLE -- SWEDISH SUCH POINT
OUT THAT THAT SLIGHT DISTINCTION.
I THINK I ONCE HEARD HEARD IT
SAID THAT TO VISION IS WHAT
DRIVES IMPLEMENTATION SO WE DO
KNOW THAT THE THE THE GOVERNOR
HAS TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF OF TAKING CARE THE VERY
YOUNGEST -- THAT HAS BEEN HIS
VISION WE WERE WE'RE HEARING
THIS.
DARE I SAY FOR THE FIRST TIME --
AND IT'S WE LOVE HEARING IT I
THINK THAT IF IF THIS IS A
COMMITMENT THAT WE HAVE -- THEN
LOOKING AT THAT LANGUAGE AND
MAKING SURE THAT IT IS MORE
INCLUSIVE I THINK WOULD SERVICE
ALL BETTER.
OKAY LET'S GO TO THE NEXT ITEM.
YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE THAT A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF TOWN OF
FUNDING GOES TO FIND CAL GRANTS
AT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
THIS IS A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT.
IS KIND OF WHAT WE CALL OUR
BALANCE OR IN THE TOWN OF BUDGET
AND SUBJECT TO THE LIMITATIONS
OF THE ELIGIBLE POPULATION THERE
SO THAT THAT'S A SMALL AND
RELATIVELY SMALL ADJUSTMENT --
IN THAT FUNDING IS A C. RIGHT
SIZING.
OF FEDERAL MONEY. FOR FEDERAL
FUNDS OKAY.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT ITEM OKAY
BUT THE NEXT -- ONE YOU MAY
RECALL IN THE IN THE RESPONSE TO
THE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
COUNTIES RAISED CONCERNS WITH
THE ESTIMATED AMOUNT OF SUN FOR
A FUNDING AVAILABLE.
FOR COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES TO SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT WE CALLED IT THEN ****
I CASH OUT WE NOW CALL IT THE IT
CAL FIRST EXPANSION TO SSI
POPULATIONS -- MORE
APPROPRIATELY DESCRIPTIVE O
WHAT IT IS -- IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH COUNTIES WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CONCERN THERE THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY FORTY TWO
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS -- IN
pTO BE AVAILABLE FOR TWO COUNTIES --
SINCE THE MAYOR REVISIONIST COME
OUT AND I'VE SEEN THE LANGUAGE
PRINTED AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
THIRTEEN IN YOUR AGENDA COUNTIES
OF RAISE CONCERNS SO THAT MIGHT
BE.
A PROPOSED ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS THAT'S TOO COMPLEX AND
NOT TIMELY ENOUGH FOR SUCCESS --
THAT WAS NOT THE INTENT AND SO
THAT THAT CONVERSATION CAN
CONTINUE WITH COUNTIES.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE MAKE THAT
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO THEM -- AND
WHEN COUNTIES CAME WITH THE
CONCERN ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING IT CAME
WITH CONCERNS ABOUT -- THE
AMOUNT OF THE NUMBER OF HOURS IT
WOULD TAKE TO HANDLE CASES THE
COST PER HOUR -- AND THOSE THOSE
KINDS OF OF THINGS AS WELL --
AND WE'VE -- MADE A VERBAL
COMMITMENT TO COUNTY IS THAT IN
THE COMING FALL WE WOULD TO TAKE
A FRESH LOOK AT HOW WE THERE
WOULD BE MAYBE THE NEXT PROGRAM
WE WE MODERNIZE THE METHODOLOGY
FOR ADMINISTRATION BUDGETING ON
BUT NOT WITHSTANDING THAT WE
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT THESE.
FORTY ALMOST FORTY THREE MILLION
AND RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE --
THIS EARLY IN THE BUDGET YEAR
FOR SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS IMPORTANT POLICY CHANGE WE
DIDN'T WANT.
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RATES AND
HOURS AND THINGS LIKE THAT TO TO
GET IN THE WAY OF GETTING PEOPLE
THROUGH THE DOOR AND PROCESSED
ACCURATELY.
I THINK I THINK THE WHAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
COUNTIES.
THERE'S A GREAT OBJECTION TO THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT IT'S THAT SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE.
MAKING IT ALMOST CONTINGENT --
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
INCREASED WORKLOAD WE ALREADY
KNOW THE WORK HAS TO BE DONE.
THIS IS THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE -- IS.
SO THE THE THE PART OF THE
SENTENCE MAY BE EXPANDED FOR
UNANTICIPATED COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
I THINK IT'S IT'S GOING TO BE
EXPENDED FOR THAT SO. TO TO
REMOVE THAT PERHAPS BUT
CONVERSATIONS I'M SURE WILL
CONTINUE.
AS TO THE LANGUAGE -- SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE THE TRAILER BILL.
TIGER WOODS FARMER FAST MA'AM
CHAIR WE WERE WILLING TO HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS WE RECOGNIZE
THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY NEXT
ITEM.
I DID LA -- DID YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS.
I JUST GONNA SAY WE WOULD ALSO
BE TRACKING THE LANGUAGE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS WOULD HAVE
ON COUNTY ADMIN.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
I'M NOT TRYING TO EXCLUDE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YOU KNOW YOU JUST LET US KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO SAY SOMETHING --
NEXT ITEM.
ON THE TOP OF PAGE -- FOURTEEN
CAL WORK STAGE -- STAGE ONE
TWELVE MONTH ELIGIBILITY -- YOU
YOU'RE PROBABLY FAMILIAR THAN A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS NOW WHEN YOU.
COME COME TO THEM YOU HAVE A
TWELVE MONTH ELIGIBILITY -- AND
WE'RE SIMPLY -- EXTENDING THAT
POLICY INTO STAGE ONE WHERE DOES
NOT UP TO THIS POINT EXISTED --
IN THE PROGRAM SO WE VIEWED AS
VERY POSITIVE CHANGE PROVIDING
WHEN YOU COME INTO STAGE ONE
THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE MOST UNSTABLE
ACROSS ALL OF THE CAL WORK
STAGES IT MAKES THE MOST SENSE
ON A POLICY BASIS.
AND PARTICULARLY ON A CHILD
BASIS THAT WOULD THEY PREFER TO
HAVE THAT -- STABILITY -- AND
THERE'S SOME TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT OF
COURSE TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE.
VERY GOOD SITE AND I APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR BRACING CENTER
MITCHELL'S -- BILL AND AND WHAT
SHE'S TRYING TO DO HERE.
I DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES WITH THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SO THAT WILL BE FOR THE
DISCUSSION -- LA -- ANY COMMENTS.
ONLY ONLY TO ADD THAT THIS IS
ONE OF THE MAJOR PROPOSALS --
NEWLY IN THE MAY REVISION AND AS
I UNDERSTAND IT THE TRAILER BILL
WAS JUST RELEASED I THINK SINCE
THIS HEARING BEGAN SO WE'LL BE
REVIEWING THAT WHEN WE GET.
AN OPPORTUNITY -- TO HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF AND
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT IT AND PROVIDE OUR
COMMENTS AND SUCH A WONDERFUL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT ITEM.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THE CAL
LEARN PROGRAM THIS IS FOR
PREGNANT AND PARENTING TEENS --
THAT IT IT -- FALL OF FOLLOW AS
CERTAIN CASE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES PRESCRIBED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
IT RECENTLY CHANGE THE STANDARDS --
FOR FOR CASE MANAGEMENT TO TO
INCREASE THEM.
WE DON'T EXPECT COUNTIES TO JUMP
TO THAT NEW STANDARD IMMEDIATELY
SO THAT THIS IS AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT IN PHASING IN THAT
POLICY CHANGE -- IT WE VIEW THIS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE
THE SUPPORT -- FOR CALIFORNIA.
FORGET THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT ITEM.
WELL OUR DEPARTMENT AMONG OTHERS
IS PROUD TO THIS -- ADMINISTER
THE TAX -- CHECK OFF OF FUND FOR
SPECIAL OLYMPICS AND THE GUY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS IN
ADDITION TO THAT TAX CHECK OFF
WORK IN ADDITIONAL A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO PASS THROUGH TO THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS.
PURSUANT TO THE LANGUAGE THAT
YOU SEE HERE WHICH SAYS WHAT I
JUST SAID.
VERY GOOD -- I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY ISSUE ON THAT
PARTICULAR -- ONE IT NEXT ITEM
PLEASE -- THIS ONE I'M PROBABLY
NOT THE BEST EQUIPPED BUT I'LL
TRY TO SUMMARIZE IT FOR YOU --
WE MAINTAIN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGETS -- PROPOSED MAINTENANCE
OF EFFORT OBLIGATION THIS IS
SIMPLY AN UPDATE.
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND IN RECOGNITION OF
FLUCTUATIONS IN REALIGNMENT
REVENUES SO THIS IS.
KEEPING THE AMMO WE WHERE WE
PROPOSE A FOR COUNTIES BUT THE
STATE'S PICKING UP A SLIGHTLY
LARGER SHARE DUE TO REALIGNMENT
REVENUE -- BEING SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT [inaudible]
THEM PREVIOUSLY.
COMMENTS FROM ILLEGAL.
AS WAS MENTIONED THIS IS
MAINTAINING THE JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO REDUCE
THE I JUST A SEMI WE FOR
COUNTIES IT'S JUST GONNA COST US
MORE TO DO IT.
PER MAY REVISION ESTIMATES OF
THE TOTAL I JUST AS PROGRAM
COSTS -- THIS IS SOMETHING ALSO
THAT WE WOULD -- BE TRACKING FOR
REVISED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS
WELL WHICH HASN'T BEEN --
UPDATED YET -- BUT SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE WE WILL BE TRACKING.
DURING THE HEARING ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE WE HEARD FROM
LABOR.
ABOUT TYING THE INCREASE
[inaudible] TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF CLICK TO BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS WITH SO MANY OF THE
COUNTIES.
AND I AM SURE WILL BE HEARING
FROM THEM AS WELL.
AND I WOULD ASK THAT THAT THAT
BE LOOKED AT IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
OKAY NEXT ITEM.
THE NEXT ITEM IS IS REALLY WHAT
WE VIEW AS A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM WE THINK IN THE EFFORTS
TO REUNIFY FAMILIES IT'S THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME -- THERE
WAS A I BELIEVE IN A PRIOR
HEARING AND I ADVOCATE REQUEST --
FOR FOR FOR ADDITIONAL MONEY AND
BUY G. YOU'RE THE MAY REVISION
DOES NOT INCLUDE THAT BUT WHAT
IT DOES INCLUDE IS THIS PROPOSED
LANGUAGE -- HERE THAT WOULD
ALLOW UNSPENT FUNDS FROM THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET AXE TO ROLL FORWARD AND
BE AVAILABLE IN BUDGET YEAR. FOR
PURPOSES OF THE PROGRAM.
WHEN THE PROGRAM WAS BROUGHT UP
IT WAS A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM AND WE EXPECT TO DURING
THE BUDGET YEAR THAT THE
EVALUATION OF THAT EFFORT WILL
BE COMPLETED?
WE COULD THANK YOU.
THAT'S REYES PART OF FINANCE HI
THIS IS JUST PURELY TACTICAL
ADJUSTMENT FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALREADY
INCLUDED -- THE FUNDING FOR THIS
IT JUST WASN'T A FORTUNE THIS --
THIS APP WHERE THE REVERBERATION
LANGUAGE WASN'T INCLUDED.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU NEXT ITEM.
WELL THE NEXT ITEM -- IS LARGELY
REFLECTED ON PAGE FIFTEEN OF
YOUR AGENDA -- IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THERE WAS A PROPOSAL FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR LEGAL
SERVICES FOR UNACCOMPANIED
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS -- IN
REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS AND ALSO --
PERSONS WHO ARE  PAST
BENEFICIARIES OF IN FEDERAL TPF
TEMPORARY.
PROTECTED STATUS -- IN THE IN
THE MAY REVISION WERE PROPOSING --
BAY BASED ON UTILIZATION OF THAT
FUNDING POT TO REDUCE THAT TO
FIVE MILLION AND USE THE OTHER
FIVE MILLION.
ALSO FOR A PURPOSE BUT DO A WHAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED FROM OUR LEGAL SERVICES
CONTRACTORS AND EXPERIENCE HERE.
IS THAT TO JUSTIFY AN ASYLUM
PETITION OR OTHER IMMIGRATION
REMEDIES OFTEN YOU HAVE TO SHOW
EVIDENCE OF TRAUMA.
AND THAT'S DONE THROUGH MENTAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS SO WE'RE NOT.
ENDING HERE -- TO TO DO TOO MUCH
EXCEPT CONTINUE OUR EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE THE
LEGAL REMEDIES THAT THEY NEED.
OR OR THE INFORMATION TO SUPPORT
THE LEGAL REMEDIES SO WE'RE
PROPOSING FIVE MILLION -- BOTH
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS AS WELL AS
NAVIGATION SERVICES TO CONNECT.
PEOPLE -- TO WHERE WHERE THOSE
ASSESSMENTS CAN OCCUR -- AND WE
WOULD BE DOING THAT OF COURSE
THROUGH THE QUALIFIED NONPROFIT
LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDERS ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHICH WE WHICH
WE FUND -- TO SERVE THESE
POPULATIONS.
I THINK THE STATISTICS
STATISTICS ARE CLEAR THAT IF YOU
TRY TO GO. TO IMMIGRATION -- TO
COURT.
ON IMMIGRATION STATUS WITHOUT
COUNSEL YOUR CHANCES OF
SUCCEEDING ARE.
VERY LOW SO -- THE COMMUNITY
SINCERELY APPRECIATES THE
GOVERNOR AGAIN -- STEPPING UP ON
ON THAT ISSUE. TO IF I MAY MAKE
THAT CONCRETE WE IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WITHOUT
COUNSEL ABOUT 15% OF CASES ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN WITH COUNSEL THAT
NUMBER'S CLOSER.
TO NINE ZERO THAT IS TRUE.
THANK YOU BYE MAKES A VERY LARGE
DIFFERENCE IT DOES AND IF YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT INFORMATION AND
THAT'S WHY THOSE.
MENTAL ASSESSMENTS ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT -- TO HAVE GREATER
SUCCESS THEN YOU'RE ABLE TO
PROVE THE PARTICULAR CASE THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO PROVE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU -- NEXT ITEM.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE FIRST ITEM
ON PAGE SIXTEEN OF THE AGENDA
APPRECIATE HAVING THE LANGUAGE
RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF US -- THE
AS A STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEMS ARE SAWS SYSTEMS ARE --
PROJECTS -- WHERE A LARGE PART
OF THE FUNDING FOR THEM COMES
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF PENDING FEDERAL
FUNDING DOCUMENTS AND SO IN THE
UNCERTAINTY ASSOCIATED WITH WHAT
THEY WILL OR WANT TO PROVE AND
THE TIMING OF THAT -- WE'RE
PROPOSING SOME PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE HERE IN THE BUDGET WILL
ALLOW ADJUSTMENTS TO REFLECT
BOTH THE FEDERAL APPROVAL AS
WELL AS WHAT SUBSEQUENTLY --
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE APPROVED
AS WELL AND YOU'LL SEE HERE THAT
THERE'S NOTIFICATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE --
THE THIRTY DAY -- NOTICED IT TO
THEM AS WELL SO THE
LEGISLATURE'S INVOLVED IN THE
REVIEW OF THOSE ADJUSTMENTS AS
WELL -- WE DON'T SEE ANY ISSUES
WITHTHAT -- NEXT ITEM THE NEXT
ITEM IS SIMILAR TO THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME ITEM THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER HERE WERE
AGAIN PROPOSING LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD ALLOW -- PRIOR YOUR MONEY
TO TO THAT HAS NOT BEEN SPENT TO
BE RE APPROPRIATED FOR
EXPENDITURE AND UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THAT HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM
WITHIN CAL WORKS.
THANK YOU NEXT ITEM -- BOTTOM OF
SIXTEEN YEAH BOTTOM OF PAGE
SIXTEEN THE CASH DISBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY AGAIN.
THAT -- BASICALLY WENT WHEN
THERE'S A SHORTFALL OR A
DISRUPTION IN THE COLLECTION OF
FEDERAL OR OR COUNTY FUNDING WE
HAVE SOME ABILITY TO DRAW FUNDS
THAT WE CAN THEN -- FROM THE
STATE TREASURY THAT WE CAN THEN
REIMBURSE -- THOSE EXPENDITURES --
AND THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE ITSELF
IS ON PAGE.
SEVENTEEN OKAY -- LA -- ON ANY
OF THE ADDITIONAL ITEMS THAT YOU
HAVEN'T SPOKEN ON OUR ROOM WITH
REGARD TO THE LAST FEW ITEMS NO
WE'VE WE'VE YOU THEN AS LARGELY
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND AND
DON'T HAVE -- SPECIFIC COMMENTS --
I DID MISS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT THE NEW METHODOLOGY FOR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES WITHIN A
SINGLE APPLICATION WHICH I
BELIEVE IS ITEM FOUR ONE FIVE
FROM A FEW MINUTES AGO -- WE
POINT OUT THE NEW METHODOLOGY%
TAKES PROMISING STEPS TO MORE
ACCURATELY ASSESS THE CASE
MANAGEMENT NEEDS OF OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN AND THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM -- SO IN THAT
SENSE WERE WERE -- GENERALLY
SUPPORT OF OF OF THE DIRECTION
THAT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE COUNTIES HAVE MOVED WITH
THIS PROPOSAL I'M GOING FORWARD
WE THINK THERE ARE PROBABLY SOME
KEY QUESTIONS THAT REMAIN
OUTSTANDING -- ONE OF THE MAJOR
ONES IS WHETHER OR NOT THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED IN.
SORT OF PROVIDING THIS CUSTOMIZE
LEVEL OF FUNDING BASED ON THE
THE NEED THAT INDIVIDUAL --
WELFARE TO WORK PARTICIPANTS OR
OR CALPERS PARTICIPANTS HAVE AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL. FOR WHETHER
WE'RE ASSESSING -- SORT OF THE
STATE LEVEL AND BASING THE
OVERALL BUDGET METHODOLOGY ON
THAT SO THERE'S A QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER THE THE STATE WIDE
ALLOCATION THAT GOES OUT TO THE
COUNTIES WILL BE REFLECTIVE OF
THE BUDGET METHODOLOGY OR
WHETHER THE BUDGET METHODOLOGY
IS IS.
STRICTLY A STATEWIDE VIEW AND
THE ALLOCATION IS IS MADE.
DISTINCT LATE -- BUT WILL BE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON ON THAT QUESTION AS THIS THIS
NEW FUNDING METHODOLOGY SORT OF
EVOLVED AND WE LEARN MORE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
EVERYTHING DEPARTMENT FINANCE
WOULD LIKE TO ADD.
I ALSO HAD A MISSED OPPORTUNITY
TIME HOODS FARMING OF FINANCE
JUST WANT TO MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT ABOUT THE HOME VISITING
LANGUAGE THAT WAS DISCUSSED
PREVIOUSLY -- FINANCE DOESN'T
YET HAVE A POSITION ON THAT
LANGUAGE WERE HAPPY TO ENGAGE
WITH THE ADVOCATES OF WRITTEN
THAT LANGUAGE.
HOWEVER WE WOULD HAVE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND -- ANY IMPLICATIONS
FROM REMOVING THAT
PRIORITIZATION -- BUT AGAIN WE
WILL HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELL LET'S GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF SCA ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
ARE FOR SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES -- ON
ISSUE FOR ELEVEN THE PUBLIC
AUTHORITY ADMINISTRATION FUNDING
WE SUPPORT THAT.
ON ITEM FOR TWELVE THE EEVEE V..
MOVING FORWARD WHEN TOTAL
SUPPORTER THAT THAT'S GOOD.
IN.
TERMS OF THE WRIST RESTS FOR
THIRTEEN THE RESTORATION OF THE
7% I KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
EARLIER ASKED IF THERE.
WAS ANY OTHER.
PROGRAMS WERE REYES WORK IS
GIVEN TO DD AND THEN AND THEN A
TREND OF TAKING OF THE WAY TO BE
CLEAR A THIRD OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE LATTER MEN SYSTEM ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE PEOPLE ALSO GET AYE
HSS.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRESUPPOSING
WHO GETS CUT WHEN A DOWNTURN
HAPPENS.
AND IT'S ALL IN THE HUMAN
SERVICE AREA AND IT'S MOSTLY IN
THIS PROCESS.
OLD PEOPLE AND DISABLED PEOPLE
AND THAT POPULATION.
WAY BACK WHEN THESE CUTS WERE
MADE [inaudible]
WE AGREED. TO HELP RESTORE THOSE
CUTS.
BY HELPING PASSED THE MCO
ATTACKS.
AND WE DID THAT.
BUT THAT LANGUAGE NEVER WENT
AWAY.
BECAUSE THEY CONTINUE TO HOLD IT
OVER THE HEAD.
A POOR AND DISABLED FOLKS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHERE THE CUTS COME
THAT'S WHAT THE INDICATION OF
THE EXPIRATION DATE OF THIS IS
AND THAT'S WHERE THE INDICATION
OF THE EXPIRATION DATE.
OF THE DEVIKA.
BRACES HAPPEN.
SO WE TOTALLY OPPOSE THIS WEEK
REJECT THE PREMISE.
THAT HE PRESUPPOSES AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN.
THAT THE CUTS HAPPEN THE POOR
AND DISABLED PEOPLE IT'S WRONG
IT'S IMMORAL AND IT SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION
IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY KINDLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
LAYING OUT THESE ITEMS MY NAME
IS TONY PENNETTA AND I REPRESENT
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP -- WE
ARE A AN EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING PROGRAM SO I'M HERE TO
SPEAK TO THE HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE -- ITEM ON THE AGENDA
TODAY -- WE CURRENTLY ARE ONE OF
THE MODELS THAT IS BEING USED BY
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT THE HOME
VISITING OFFERING TO CAL WORKS
BENEFICIARIES AND WE ARE VERY
EXCITED TO SEE.
THE REVISED HAVE FIGURED THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET.
WE ARE PART OF THE ADVOCATE
COMMUNITY THAT DID IT REQUEST
SOME ADDITIONAL -- REVIEW OF IT
THE ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLDS FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND IN PARTICULAR
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE
WE DO SERVE FIRST TIME EXPECTANT
LOW INCOME WOMEN.
ARE SEEKING CLARIFICATION AND
EXPLICIT -- CLARIFICATION ABOUT
WHAT WE WOULD REFER TO AS A
PREGNANCY FIX.
SUCH THAT ARE PREGNANT WOMEN WHO
ARE PRESUMPTIVELY ELIGIBLE FOR
CAL WORKS BASED ON THEIR INCOME
DO NOT HAVE TO WAIT.
UNTIL THEIR SECOND TRIMESTER TO
BE ELIGIBLE TO ENROLL IN THIS
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL --
FOR WOMEN WHO ARE PREGNANT EARLY
IN THEIR PREGNANCIES TO BE ABLE
TO BE OFFERED THE SERVICE.
AND SO WE ALSO WILL BE
SUPPORTING REQUEST OF THE
ADVOCATES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
PERSONAL GET US HERE ON BEHALF
OF SAN JOAQUIN.
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON I. H. S.
S. AND MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
STEVE CONEY ON BEHALF OF A
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA AND THERE ARE SOME
UNMISTAKABLE BRIGHT SPOTS IN THE
BUDGET THIS IS THE DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL ITEM FISH BEFORE NINE AS
ONE OF THE IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENT IF WE CAN BRING
THIS OFF THIS YEAR AND SO.
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND
VERY GRATEFUL TO EVERYONE IN
THIS BUILDING AND AND
PARTICULARLY MOST RECENTLY FOR
THE HELP FROM THE DSS STAFF IN
THE JOINT -- JUDICIAL COUNCIL
STAFF FOR HELPING MAKE THIS WORK
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING WOULD DEPLORED
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BABY EVERY
BUT OF FOR THE MOMENT
REPRESENTING THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THE SUN SETTING OF THE RATE.
INCREASE -- AND IN DOING SO I'D
LIKE TO USE BABY AREAS AN
EXAMPLE VERY PROVIDE SUPPORTED
LIVING SERVICES.
OF THE TWO OF ABOUT EIGHTY
PEOPLE WE EMPLOY ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY OF INDIVIDUALS.
AND FIGHTING IN AGES WORKER IS
REALLY REALLY OF A CHALLENGE.
SO -- LET'S SEE.
STUFF TO ORDER WORK THOSE HOURS
BECAUSE THE RATES ARE SO LOW.
AND SO -- MOST REGIONAL CENTERS.
MANY REGIONAL CENTERS ACTUALLY
OF THE TELL US THAT THEY WILL
NOT FUND THOSE HOURS EVEN IF.
THE CLIENT WHO WITH OUR SYSTEMS
CANNOT FIND A WORKER.
AND SO THAT LEAVES THE BURDEN ON
THE PROVIDER OF SERVICE.
SO ADDED TO THE OTHER SUNSET
WITH THE THE I. D. D. RATE
INCREASE -- THIS IS VERY VERY OF
IT'S IMPORTANT TO INCREASE THE
RATES RIGHTEOUS US WORKERS SO
THAT WE CAN FIND WORKERS.
OF MY STUFF AS WE ARE JOINT
EMPLOYERS CAN WORK I JUST AS
ALWAYS BUT NONE OF THEM WANT --
TO BECAUSE THE RATE IS LESS.
WHAT THAT DOES IS LEAVE THE
PROVIDER WITH ONE TO THREE
CHOICES NONE OF THEM ARE GOOD?
OF THE FIRST ONE BEING THAT.
WE PROVIDE THE HOURS WITHOUT
FUNDING.
AND WITHOUT A CONTRACT BE A
PURCHASE OF SERVICE WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS.
WHICH PUTS US IN OF GREAT
LIABILITY.
IF SOMETHING WERE TO HAPPEN
DURING THOSE HOURS -- SECONDLY
WE CAN LEAVE THE CAR IN ATTENDED.
OF WHICH PUTS THEM AT RISK
HEALTH AND SAFETY RISK.
AND THEN ALSO WE ARE THEN TOLD
THAT WERE ABANDONING OUR CLIENT.
THIRD OPTION IS TO GIVE NOTICE A
NOT PROVIDE THE SERVICE
[inaudible]
SO -- I WOULD SIMPLY REQUEST
THAT YOU NOT ALLOW WITH THE RATE
INCREASE TO SUNSET I DON'T GIVE
YOU A FINAL EXAMPLE A HOUSEHOLD.
WITH THREE INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING
SERVICES FROM BABY VERY I DID
HAVE TO GIVE NOTICE EVERY SINGLE
MONTH ON BECAUSE WE COULD NOT
FIND A WORKER FOR FIVE HUNDRED I
AGES US HOURS.
WE WERE LOSING FOURTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED FIVE DOLLARS PER
MONTH AND THAT'S WHY.
I'M HAVING TO CUT -- THE SEVERE
SEVERE CUTS IN MY BUDGET THIS
YEAR LOSING EMPLOYEES KEY
EMPLOYEES.
OFTEN SIMPLY NOT BEING ABLE TO
FILL THE HIND THEM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
ARE ON BEHALF OF A COALITION FOR
QUALITY REPLICA REPRESENTATION
AND DEPENDENCY COURTS WE ARE
VERY VERY GRATIFIED TO SEE THE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
DEPENDENCY.
COUNCIL FUNDING THROUGH THE
TITLE FOR E. A REIMBURSEMENT
PROCESS AND ARE VERY THANKFUL
FOR FOR THOSE NEW RESOURCES
BRING -- BEING BROUGHT TO BEAR
FOR THIS PROGRAM THE PROVIDERS
OF COURSE ARE VERY PLEASED TO
SEE THIS DEVELOPMENT WE DO THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME WORK TO
BE DONE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING PART OF THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH.
DSS AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
AND OTHER FOLKS IN THIS BUILDING
TO MAKE SURE THE MECHANICS ARE
IN PLACE -- SO THAT WE CAN --
SEEK REIMBURSEMENT FOR CLAIMS
STARTING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUT THIS IS A REALLY A
GREAT DEVELOPMENT WE'RE VERY
PLEASED AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK MAC
WITH CWD A WITH RESPECT TO THE
C. C. R. INVESTMENTS RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL -- DIPPERS CANS
OF PLACEMENT AT THE TIME OF A
PAYMENT AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT --
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE MAY REVISION
THERE'S BEEN SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS FROM THE JANUARY BUDGET
THERE STILL SOME DAYLIGHT
BETWEEN WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
NECESSARY AND WHAT WAS PROVIDED --
AND WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF THESE INVESTMENTS NEED
TO BE ON GOING NOT ONE TIME WE
APPRECIATE WHAT WAS PUT IN THE
MAY REVISION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE TO SPEAK
WITH THE NEW ADMINISTRATION.
ABOUT THE ON GOING UP PERMANENT
NEEDS OF THAT CONTINUE WITH CARE
REFORM WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BRING
ATTENTION TO A REQUEST A FORMAL
REQUEST -- THAT WE'VE PUT FOR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO EXTEND
FOR ONE MORE YEAR HE ABILITY --
TO UTILIZE GROUP HOMES THAT HAVE
NOT YET MADE IT THROUGH THE S.
T. R. T. P. APPROVAL PROCESS WE
TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT THIS.
IN A IN A COMMITTEE HEARING AND
WE PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE AND I WOULD -- UP FOR
THE GOOD -- IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THE OUTCOMES OF THE
C. R. LIKE TO RENEW OUR REQUEST.
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO FIND
FIRST THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM THE MODES MOBILE RESPONSE.
FOR YOUTH IN THEIR CARE GIVERS
WERE -- IN CRISIS WITH RESPECT --
TO THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING OF ONE
TIME -- ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
EXISTING PROVIDERS AND
RECIPIENTS BUT WE POINT OUT THAT
THERE IS NO FUNDING.
IN THE BUDGET ONGOING FOR NEW
PROVIDERS AND NEW RECIPIENTS AND
IT IS OUR BELIEF BASED ON OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE COUNTY
FOLKS WHO WERE ADMINISTERING THE
PROGRAM.
THAT THE PROCESS IS JUST MORE
COMPLICATED AND THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE HELPING -- THE AB
DIFFICULTY NAVIGATING THIS VERY
COMPLICATED PROCESS -- AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON WHAT WE
BELIEVE TO BE OF THE ON GOING.
COSTS OF ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION WITH RESPECT THE
CALVERTS EMPLOYMENT SERVICES WE
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THE WORK
ON THE NEW METHODOLOGY --
THERE'S ONE DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE COUNTIES
AND THAT IS HOW INTENSIVE NEED
CASE WORK BE FOR CLIENTS WHO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS PEOPLE
OF HAD DOMESTIC VIOLENCE --
PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OUR
MEMBERS HAVE TOLD US BASED ON
THE WORK WE'VE DONE AND CAL
WORKS TO PLAY NOW THAT IT'S AT
LEAST TEN HOURS A MONTH WITH THE
BUDGET PROVIDES -- IS FIVE HOURS
PER MONTH AND SO WE'RE
SUGGESTING LANGUAGE THAT
EXPRESSES LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO
GET TO TEN HOURS PER MONTH.
IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS -- ONE BUT
WE ARE EXTREMELY THANKFUL FOR
THE EXCELLENT WORK WE DID WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES -- WE'VE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN THE AGREE ON 90% OF
OF WHERE WE NEED TO GO -- WITH
RESPECT TO CHARACTER AND ALSO
LIKE TO RENEW OUR REQUEST TO
UPDATE THE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LEAVING CAL WORKS HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO STAY OFF
OF CAL WORKS.
WE APPRECIATE THE ONE TIME
INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA ADMIN
FOR SSI -- FOR SS I CASH OUT AND
WE APPRECIATE FINANCING HERE
TODAY THAT THE WORK WITH US SO
THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF PREVENTING US
FROM BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE THAT --
CAO WORK STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
TWELVE MONTHS CONTINUOUS THE
ELIGIBILITY WE REALLY LIKE IT --
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT PREMATURELY SEPARATING CAL
WORKS STAGE ONE CHILD CARE FROM
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION THAT
FLEXIBILITY HAS BEEN PART OF THE
PROGRAM FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AND OUR BUDGETS.
BEEN ADOPTED IN THE FISCAL YEAR
STARTS JULY FIRST IT'S JUST TO
SAY IT'S TOO LATE TO HAVE THE
COUNTIES -- ADOPT A BUDGETING
CHANGE OF THIS MAGNITUDE WITH SO
LITTLE TIME SO WE'RE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GIVE US A YEAR
TO PHASE THAT IN SO AND BUDGET
YOUR PLUS ONE WE WOULD SEPARATE
CHILD CARE FROM THE SINGLE
APPLICATION.
AND FINALLY I WOULD ASK THE THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO REALLY CONSIDER
RE AUTHORIZING.
EVEN ON A ONE TIME BASIS THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM
THE BEEN A THOUSAND CHILDREN
WHO'VE BEEN SAFE THE REUNIFIED
WITH THEIR PARENTS BECAUSE OF
THAT PROGRAM IT'S A PROGRAM THAT
YOU PAY HALF THE COUNTIES PAY
THE OTHER HALF.
AND BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE
PROBLEMS CAUSED BY EXTRAORDINARY
HOUSING IT ON AFFORDABILITY.
THIS IS A SERVICE THAT WE CANNOT
SIMPLY FIND WITHIN OUR BASE LINE
IT WAS JUST IT'S A PROBLEM THAT
WE DID NOT ANTICIPATE WHEN WE
DID OUR A REALIGNMENT.
AND IT WOULD BE A SHAME IF
COUNTIES HAVE TO CLOSE DOWN
PROGRAMS WITH A THOUSAND PERSON
WAITING LIST WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THAT PROGRAM IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN KIDS GOING HOME SAFELY
WITH THEIR PARENTS WERE GROWING
UP IN FOSTER CARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
BLOODY SANTOS ON BEHALF OF SCA
YOU -- I WANT TO START BY
ALIGNING MYSELF WITH THE COMP
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
PREVIOUSLY MADE BY MISTER MAC --
REGARDING THE AN AGENDA IZED
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR CAL FROM ASH ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION ENROLLMENT AND
PANNED OUT -- BUT PROVIDING --
TO FOLKS IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS --
ALSO WANTED EXPRESSED SINCERE
APPRECIATION TO THE COMMITTEE
AND MISTER.
THANK GOD FOR BRINGING UP THE
TITLE FOR EASY WAY FOR
EXPLORATION THAT WERE
ANTICIPATING IN OCTOBER AND THE
DRAMATIC IMPACT THAT'S GONNA
HAVE ON COUNTIES AS WAS
MENTIONED COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
AWARE OF THIS AND HAVE BEEN
ANTICIPATING THAT.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE ARE
PREPARED PARTICULARLY IN A
COUNTY LIKE I'LL A WHICH IS
GOING TO HAVE BETWEEN A TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN MILLION AND
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IT -- IT
DOESN'T MEAN WE HAVE THAT SO
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT MISTER JOVANKA
MENTIONED -- TO ANTICIPATE IN
THE EVENT THAT THE FED STONE'S --
DON'T ADDRESS THAT SHORTCOMING --
I WANT TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH MANY
OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER
MAC UP -- I ALSO WANT TO RESPOND
TO A QUESTION POSED BY THE CHAIR
REGARDING THE DELTA THAT WE
BELIEVE EXISTS BETWEEN THE
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION FOR
RESOURCE FAMILY ASSISTANCE
APPROVAL.
I'M IN THE MAY REVISED -- THAT
ADDRESSES EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE TWENTY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE REASON WHY WE
HAVE BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL IN
ADDRESSING THE BACKLOG.
AND GETTING KIDS PLACED
APPROPRIATELY IS BECAUSE WE DID
HAVE THE TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED AND
SO IF WE WANT TO CONTINUE.
MAKING THAT SHORTFALL AND
BACKLOG SMALLER THE WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO GIVE US THE FULL
FUNDING ALLOCATION THE SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR IS NOT
IN I CURRENT EIGHTEEN POINT --
FOUR ADDITION IN THE MAY REVISE
AND SO WE'RE ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION DOLLARS --
ALSO WANT -- TO EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THE AMENDMENTS TO A
COUPLE OF PROPOSALS THAT MISTER
MAC ARE ALSO MENTIONED
PARTICULARLY AS IT REGARDS AS IT
RELATES TO THE TWELVE MONTH
ADDITIONAL EXTENSION.
FOR MOVING THE CHILD CARE OUT OF
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY AS HE MENTIONED --
WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TIMING OF THAT -- SO TO PROVIDE
US WITH THE ADDITIONAL TWELVE
MONTHS WILL BETTER ENSURE THAT
WE WILL BE ABLE TO EFFECTUATE
THAT -- WITHIN THE BUDGET
CONFINES.
ON WE ADDITIONALLY WANT TO
EXPRESS -- OOPS I JUST POINT ON
WHAT MY NEXT UNLESS -- I WILL
SKIP NOW -- TO ALSO SAY THAT --
ON BEHALF OF KAPPA.
HOME WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE WORK THAT WAS ON UNDERTAKEN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT -- TO GET TO
A SHARED UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE CORRECT FUNDING METHODOLOGY
FOR ON PUBLIC AUTHORITIES WAS WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND EFFORT THAT WAS PUT INTO ALL
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND WE'RE ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF
THE ADDITIONAL -- BUDGET
ALLOCATION IN THERE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT I'M CHAIR MARTHA GUERRERO
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
AND WE ALSO LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER MECCA
AND THERE ARE SOME AREAS WHERE
WE HAVE TAKEN A POSITION AND AND
SOME AREAS THAT WHERE WE WERE
REVIEWING AND ARE PENDING
OPPOSITION IS PENDING AND ALL.
GO OVER THOSE RIGHT NOW ON THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
ADMINISTRATION AND BACKLOG WE
SUPPORT -- THE BUDGET ITEM THAT
WAS A THE MAY REVISED PROPOSAL.
AND THE PLACEMENT PRIOR TO
APPROVAL WE ALSO SUPPORT THAT
PROPOSAL AND THE PAPERS FUNDING --
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AND WE
AGREE WITH SEE TO BE DAYS
RECOMMENDATION FOR ONGOING OR
NOT ONE TIME -- RELATED TO THE
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL TOTAL FORTY
WE WILL SUPPORT THAT BUDGET ITEM
WE'RE VERY THANKFUL THAT THIS IS
MUCH NEEDED.
ON THE AYE HSS ELECTRONIC VERY
VISIT VERIFICATION COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING WE AGREE
WITH MR MECCA ON MAKING SURE
THAT -- WE HAVE ONGOING FUNDING
FOR WORKLOAD ASSOCIATE.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
RELATED TO THE CAL WORK SINGLE
ALLOCATION EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
BUDGET METHODOLOGY CHANGES MR
MAKE OF HIGHLIGHTED EXACTLY WHAT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- HAS --
REVIEWED IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
DIRECT SERVICES PORTION OF THE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF HOURS --
FOR THE BUDGETED -- INTENSIVE
SERVICES.
AND IN -- THE CAL WORKS ON
VISITING ASSUMPTION --
TERMINATION -- WE HAVE A WE WILL
HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE ONE BUT WE
ARE PENDING A SUPPORT POSITION
ON THAT.
AND ON THE ONE TIME COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING FOR THE
EXPANDED CALPERS POPULATION WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THAT
BUT WE ARE PENDING.
TO SUPPORT THAT IN ADDITION THAT
IT BE ONGOING SO THE COUNTIES BE
ALLOWED TO USE THE FUNDING
WITHOUT OBTAINING PRIOR APPROVAL
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
END ON THE CAL WORD STAGE ONE
ODD TWELVE MATILDA DEBILITY WE
WILL BE.
HAVING A SUPPORT POSITION ON
THAT BUT WE DO OPPOSE THE CARVE
OUT -- FROM THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CAM LEWIS
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW AND
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE COW WORK
SOME VISITING ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATION IN ORDER. TO BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING YOU WANT TO PUT IN THERE
AS WELL.
I'M REGARDING THAT STAKEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL WE HAVE AT IT THIS
WAY A LOT OF FOLKS TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT IT WOULD MAKE.
FIRSTLY THERE IMPLEMENTATION AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL IT IS NOT AN
ENTITLEMENT AS WAS NOTED SO LOOK
FOR THEIR CONVERSATIONS WITH
FINANCE LATER THIS WEEK TO
DISCUSS IN DETAIL -- WE ALSO
SUPPORT STAGE ONE COW WORKS
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY -- AND
THEN IF I SWITCH MY HAVE TO
SPARE NAT AND WE JUST APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS COMMENTS -- FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AROUND THE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKER INCREASED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF MARTY MODEM A
FAMILY MEMBER ALSO WITH CITY CAN
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SENIOR
COMMUNICATION NETWORK IN THE
CALIFORNIA PERSON CENTERED
ADVOCACY PARTNERSHIP.
FIRST OF ONE IS THANK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR BEING HERE
SEVEN O'CLOCK AND I THINK LAST
WEEK.
HE ADJOURNED AT ALMOST NINE SO I
DON'T KNOW FOR TRYING TO REACH
BEAT THAT RECORD BUT BUT AGAIN.
BUT A PERSON ANSWERS NO NO YEAH
GOOD.
I I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
BUT ALSO DO MINISTRATION FOR ITS
EMPHASIS ON EARLY CHILDHOOD CARE
AND EDUCATION THOSE ARE ISSUES
REALLY IMPORTANT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND PEOPLE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS -- AND SO THE
EMPHASIS OF THOSE THINGS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
PART OF THE BUDGET IS IS IS IS
APPRECIATED.
ALSO WON A SUPPORT THE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY FRANK MAC ON
THE ISSUE OF E. V. V. ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION.
I REALLY APPRECIATE A LOT OF US
DO APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND HOW THEY
WORK WITH ALL OF US. TO MITIGATE
THE CONCERNS THAT A LOT OF US
HAD ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
EVEY V..
AND WE THINK THAT ANY ANY HELP
IN TERMS OF RESOURCES TO FURTHER
MITIGATE.
ANY CONCERNS IS IS IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING IS DOING THE THINGS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT WOULD WOULD
WANT TO SEE HAPPEN -- ALSO WANT
TO MENTION SOMETHING IS NOT IN
THE MAY REVISE AND IS JUST.
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE
WASN'T A A AN INCREASE IN THE S.
S. P. GRANTS FOR PEOPLE ON SSI
THIS IS P..
AND WE WOULD URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER THAT
LASTLY -- I JUST WANT TO MAKE
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE FACT THAT
THERE IS.
A ON THE RESTORATION OF THE 7% --
ISA SAYS REDUCTION AND THAT IT
WOULD GO INTO EFFECT OR THAT'S
THE RESTORATION WOULD END
DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE THINK THAT
IS NOT RIGHT AND IT IS ALSO IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE DURING THE
BUDGET SURPLUS WE HAVE INCREASES
AND DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
AND MY SISTER BY THE WAY RECEIVE
MEDI CAL DEVELOPMENT -- SERVICES
THE REGIONAL CENTER AND I JUST
US DURING THE TIMES OF THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS WHEN.
THEIR WORK CUTS AND WE THERE
WASN'T CERTAINLY CONSTANTLY IN
MY FAMILY FIGHTING OFF THOSE
CUTS HERE WE'RE IN A BUDGET
SURPLUS IN EVEN WARMER GETTING
INCREASES THERE'S A SUNSET.
THAT.
MAYBE THERE'S A JUSTIFICATION
FOR THAT.
BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE
SENSE AT THIS POINT IN TIME. TO
HAVE A RESTORATION OF A CUT THAT
WAS MADE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION -- TO A POPULATION IS
VERY VULNERABLE.
BECAUSE THERE MAY BE A DOWNTURN
IN REVENUES TWO YEARS FROM NOW
WE THINK.
THAT CUTS SHOULD BE HARD TO MAKE.
AND THAT THE STATE IN THE
LEGISLATURE DID MINISTRATION
SHOULDGO TO A PROCESS TO
CAREFULLY CONSIDER.
A REDUCTION IF IT'S NECESSARY --
ONE OF THE THINGS IS REALLY
DIFFICULT WITH THIS IS THAT THE
CUT WOULD ACTUALLY TAKE EFFECT
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THAT WOULD MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ADVOCATES FOR FAMILIES. TO
REALLY FIGHT THE REDUCTIONS ALL
WE WOULD BE DOING IS FOR THE
NEXT PREVIOUS YEAR IS TO BE
WORRIED THAT WOULD THIS CUT
HAPPEN OR NOT.
AND THAT'S NOT FAIR I THINK WE
CAN DO THE RIGHT THING NOT HAVE
OF THIS -- YOU KNOW HAD THE
RESTORATION PERMANENT AS AS THIS
SUB ONE TOOK ACTION ON THAT
EARLIER IN MARCH WE APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU REMEMBER WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO BREAK THE RECORD FROM
NO.
I WAS JUST A LITTLE REMINDER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CRISTINA
BOSS HAMILTON WITH YOU W. I I
DON'T WANNA BE LABOR IT I I
THINK THE THE POINT ON SON
STUDYING.
NOT IDEAL YOU KNOW THIS
COMMITTEE TOOK INACTION IN MARCH
WERE PLEASE JUST STICK WITH THAT
ACTION IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO WE DON'T WANT TO BUY IN THE
FUTURE LEGISLATURE.
TO ENACT THE CUT IT YOU KNOW
JUST LIKE MARTY SAID IT SHOULD
BE REDUCE.
DEBATED A NEW WINDOW WHEN THE
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
DIFFERENT AND THAT'S THE ROLE OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO DO THAT AND
THEN ALSO TO IT TO ANSWER REALLY
QUICKLY.
WE WE BEING THE UNIONS
REPRESENTING I JUST SAYS ARE
STILL LOOKING TO CONNECT THE
REDUCTION IN THE COUNTY OF MAUI
TO LOCAL COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AND THAT IS STILL AN OUTSTANDING
ASK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
A META CHECKER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE JUST
LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH --
THE POSITION ON THE 7% TO
RETREAT FROM THE 7% INCREASE --
THAT CERTAINLY GOES AGAINST I
THINK THE NEED FOR THE STABILITY
IN THE ON GOING FUNDING IN THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING ANTI SHORTS WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RATES I JUST WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE DEPENDENCY A
COUNCIL -- INCREASE AND ALSO
ECHO ECHO I MISTER MARCUS
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED TO
REALLY FUND THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM BUT WANT TO
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT ISSUE
FOR A SEVEN PLACEMENT PRIOR TO
APPROVAL -- WE APPRECIATE THE
EXTENSION OF THE EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER FUNDING FOR UP TO A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS BUT WE
BELIEVE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THERE BE GOOD BECAUSE FOR THE
ENTIRE THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE DAYS NOT THE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS.
THAT'S IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL.
RESEARCH FAMILY APPROVAL IS
STILL TAKING ON AVERAGE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS AND SO
THAT MEANS MANY MORE FAMILIES
ARE TAKING MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DAYS TO GET THROUGH
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL.
GOOD CAUSE IS TRIGGERED UPON A
FINDING BY THE DEPARTMENT THAT
THE DELAY IS NEITHER THE CARE
GIVER OR THE COUNTY'S FAULT.
AND SO CUTTING FAMILIES OFF AT A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS WHEN
THAT'S NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
THAT IT'S TAKING LONGER TO GET
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS --
SEEMS PATENTLY UNFAIR WE DON'T
THINK THE CHILDREN AND FAMILY
SHOULD BE THE ONES THAT ARE
BEARING -- THE BRUNT OF DELAYS
THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THEIR
CONTROL AND SO WE WOULD ASK THAT
THE ENTIRE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE DAY GOOD BECAUSE BE
MAINTAINED IN THE COMING YEAR
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND THE YOU HAD A ROBUST
AGENDA DISCUSSED I'M PAUL JUDGE
NO VANCE FOR THE NUMBER OF ITEMS
I'M GOING TO RAISE -- SO -- ON
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION WERE VERY
HAPPY TO SEE THIS INCREASE IN
FUNDING WE THINK IT'S WELL PLACE
WELL USE WE WE BELIEVE IT'S
GONNA BE NECESSARY AS WE EXPAND
AND ENHANCE THE POWER SPERMS WE
GO FORWARD -- HOME VISITING
AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PUTTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING INTO THAT BUT WE SUPPORT
THE ADVOCATES PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
THAT PROGRAM OUT TO DESTROY
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY PREGNANT
WOMEN AS THE PREVIOUS ADVOCATE
MENTIONED -- WE SUPPORT THE
TWELVE MONTH ELIGIBILITY
PROPOSAL ARE WE THINK IS THAT
FOR A CRUCIAL DISABILITY FOR
HOURS FAMILIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE CHILD CARE THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO THEM ALL THE TIME
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
CONTINUALLY GO BACK.
AND TRY TO GET THAT.
APPROVED AGAIN BY THE COUNTY.
AND THEN -- BUT AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER -- YOU KNOW WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS PROPOSAL AGAIN
TO INCREASE GRANTS FOR US THE
SCIENCES BE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF DISCUSSION.
HERE TODAY ABOUT GRANT CUTS
THEY'VE BEEN TAKING MANY YEARS
AGO AND STILL NOT BEEN RESTORED
AND THIS IS PROBABLY THE SINGLE
LARGEST ONE THAT HAS NOT BEEN
RESTORED -- WE DO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS AROUND
THE SMB IN TMB LANGUAGE TO MAKE
THAT -- TO GET RID OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT MADE IT ONLY A
TEMPORARY PROGRAM AND TO REMOVE
THE LANGUAGE THAT BARRED THE
ENTITLEMENT WE'RE STILL LOOKING
FORWARD TO TALKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
ABOUT -- INSURING THAT -- WE
DON'T -- WE CAN FIX RULES THAT
MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO RETURN BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT IN THE CALPERS PROGRAM. 25%
OF THE CASELOAD TURNS OVER AT
REED'S TERMINATION AND THEN
LASTLY WE JUST KNOW THAT WE'RE
STILL HOPING TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
SIXTY MONTH TIME CLOCK FOR CAO
WORKS.
THE ASSET TAPS REMOVAL FOR CAL
WORKS AND IN THE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR CAL WORKS
TO GET RID OF THE ONCE YOUR
LIFETIME.
A ONCE A YEAR REQUIRE A LIMIT
AND TO ALLOW FOR THE SIXTEEN
DAYS COULD BE USED IN -- CHUNKS
AND NOT HAVE ALL -- SIXTEEN
CONSECUTIVELY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JUST GARRETT I CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- TO
START WITH THIS -- ONE REITERATE
OUR GRATITUDE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S ISIS AND WE
PROPOSAL ON IN PARTICULAR --
THAT IT'S THIS STATE GENERAL
FUND COMMITMENT IS STRENGTHENING
THE MAY REVISE ON WITH THE COST
OF THE PROGRAM'S GOING OUT SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
ADDITIONAL STATE GENERAL FUND SO
THAT COUNTIES -- HAVE FISCAL
STABILITY MOVING FORWARD -- WE
ALL SHE'LL -- WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE REQUEST TO LINK
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING -- AND THE
REDUCE INFLATION FACTOR WE KNOWS
A LOT OF DISCUSSION ON THIS WITH
THE ISLAND ARE REASONS IN THE
LETTER I THINK WHAT I WOULD JUST
ADD TO THE CONVERSATION TODAY IS
IT.
WE ARE SEEN -- INCREASING
PROGRESS FROM COUNTIES ON LOCAL
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING NUMBER
RECENT SURVEYS WE CONDUCTED
SHOWED THAT.
THERE'S BEEN EIGHTEEN NEW
AGREEMENTS UNDER THE NEW MOE
OTHERS TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY NEGOTIATING OR IN
SOME FORM OF ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT --
WE HAVE THREE COUNTIES THAT HAVE
THAT AGREEMENTS THAT PREDATE THE
MOE.
I HAVE A COUNTIES WHERE THE
PROVIDING HAS NOT YET REACHED
OUT TO START NEGOTIATIONS SO WE
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH COUNTIES
AND ENCOURAGE ON THIS FRONT TO
THE BEST WE CAN AND JUST DON'T
THINK THE TIME IS RIGHT OR THE
APPROACH IS RIGHT FOR A PUNITIVE
MEASURE -- OUR PRINT OF APPROACH
ON THIS ISSUE BUT I CERTAINLY --
REMAIN AS STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
PARTNERING WITH -- THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION ON THIS ISSUE THE
GREAT PARTNERS ON ACCESS AND
THINK IF THERE MAY BE SOME
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS IT DON'T
TAKE THIS TYPE OF APPROACH TO IT --
OKAY -- OTHER ISSUES AS A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD STRONG INVESTMENTS
HERE -- ON THE CHILD WELFARE
SIDE WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INCREASE INVESTMENTS FOR
FLIPPERS -- FOR THE RFA APPROVAL
FOR PAYMENT AT TIME OF
PLACEMENTS -- AND WE JUST
ADVOCATE AND SIMILAR ITEMS TO
MAKE OUTLINED FOR CONTINUE
CONVERSATION ON THE RIGHT AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THERE AS WELL AS SOME
OF THE OTHER GREAT INVESTMENTS --
IN NEED INVESTMENTS IN THE CHILD
WELFARE FRONT.
AMONG THE SINGLE APPLICATION WE
APPRECIATE THE INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
COMPONENTS.
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE THE
APPROACH TO TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY AND I'M. FOR THE
CHILD CARE COMPONENT AND WOULD
JUST REITERATE THE CONCERNS
ABOUT -- THE WRAPPING THIS WITH
WHICH THAT CHANGE -- TO AT SIX
SIGNALING OUT THAT -- COMPONENT
WOULD COME UP AND JUST ASK --
FOR THE THE ONE YEAR EXTENSION
OF THE ONE YEAR DELAY SO THAT
COUNTIES GONNA PURPOSELY BUDGET
MANAGE THAT A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT -- ON
DISASTER DEFINITELY APPRECIATE --
THE THE COMMITMENT TO INCREASE
RESOURCE FOR THE PARMA SOCIAL
SERVICES IN ORDER TO
APPROPRIATELY RESPOND AND
PARTNER WITH COUNTIES IN THE AND
HIS OFFICE SITUATIONS -- BUT
WOULD ALSO REITERATED SUPPORT
FOR A DEFINING RELATED TO CAL
FOR ASH SO THAT -- THAT CAN BE
AUTOMATED DISASTER HOW FRESH --
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND THE LAST THING -- ON THE A
CHILD A CAL FRESH EXPANSION --
WE WE APPRECIATE AND I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE INCREASE
pADMINISTRATION AND THE OPENNESS --
TO MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE OF THE
COUNTIES CAN USE THIS FUNDING AS
EFFICIENTLY AS EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE A QUESTION
YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE
MORE COUNTIES THAT NOW HAD
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS.
HOW MANY COUNTIES ARE LEFT
WITHOUT A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT YES SO THERE ARE --
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES WITH THE
CURRENT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT ALL THE COUNTIES WHERE
IT'S NOT A CURRENT AGREEMENT
THERE'S STILL PAIN.
THE WAGE FROM THE LAST --
AGREEMENTS AND YOU KNOW FROM
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM COUNTY
IS THERE ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE -- IN GOOD FAITH -- ON
THESE AGREEMENTS TO CARRY OUT
THE RESPONSIBILITIES THE STATE
HAS MANDATED UPON COUNTIES.
AND WE ARE REALLY SEEN --
PROGRESS MOVING FORWARD I THINK.
THE LAST TWO YEARS COUNTIES WERE
NEGOTIATE UNDER REALLY AYE
LOOMING FISCAL CLIFF WITH A
REALIGNMENT WITH THE CURRENT
ACCESS FISCAL STRUCTURE AND NOW
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY -- OF THE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WERE COUNTIES WILL HAVE A MUCH
MORE STABILITY AND I SAYS COSTS.
AS WELL AS THE OPTION TO PREVENT
CUTS TO HEALTH THE MENTAL HEALTH
WE I REALLY BELIEVE WE'LL SEE --
THAT THIS PROGRESS CONTINUE EVEN
MORE SO THEY WERE TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES THAT DO HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS.
YES CURRENT DEBT.
THAT HAVE YEAH THAT THE GREEN
IT'S EXTEND YOU KNOW IF THEY IF
THEIR EXPIRE THEY CONTINUE TO
PAY -- THE WEIGHT OF THE LAST
AGREEMENT BUT YES IN TERMS OF
THE THE DATES OF THE AGREEMENT
THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWENTY ONE
COUNTY CS FIFTY EIGHT ONLY
TWENTY ONE HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS YES HELLO.
YES.
YEAH OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THANKS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
HI GOOD EVENING.
JACQUI RETIRED SO THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND I'VE FIRST ONE IS
STATE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
READING ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO'S
COMMENTS -- WE APPROVE OF
EVERYTHING THAT WAS IN THERE OF
COURSE WERE DISAPPOINTED NOT TO
BE IN THE MAY REVISED BECAUSE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES ARE
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
CONTINUUM OF CARE.
AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF MONEY
PUT INTO CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
IT'S STARTING TO SUCCEED THREE
SPEED FIVE THOUSAND KIDS IN
GROUP HOMES AS HERE TO PEACE.
AND NOW THERE'S FOUR THOUSAND
WHAT FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS DO IS THEY PROVIDE CARE
425% OF ALL FOSTER CHILDREN.
THEY ALSO.
TRAIN AND RECRUIT TWO THIRDS OF
ALL THE NON RELATED FAMILIES TO
THERE'S CRITICAL PIECES THERE'S
THE RELATIVES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR THE TIME
A PLACEMENT.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT ON
GETTING RID OF THE RFA BACKLOG
BUT WE CANNOT NOT SUPPORT THIS
PIECE THAT IS SO CRITICAL AND I
DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
NOW.
BUT I BELIEVE WE HAVE A CLOSE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM
IN THE COUNTIES AND TO NOT
OF PROVIDE FOR THIS AN ADEQUATE
PAY FOR THE SOCIAL WORKERS TO
COMPLY NOT JUST WITH THE MINIMUM
LAW.
BUT TO ALSO CARE FOR THE
FAMILIES THAT RELY ON THE
STABILITY OF THE SOCIAL WORKER.
THAT IS THE PIECE THAT NEEDS TO
BE SECURE AND I KNOW YOUR SISTER
HAS A PHD IN SOCIAL WORKER AND I
KNOW WITH THE HEARING YOU
STRONGLY SAID HOW SOCIAL WORKERS
RUN THE RUN THE WORLD -- NOT
QUITE SURE LET'S WORK DO DO YOU
GOT SOURCES SAID THEY DO GOD'S
WORK THEY DO -- ALSO 85% OF
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE WOMEN.
AND I I REALLY HATE TO BE SEXIST
HERE BUT IF WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT CPA'S AND 85% WERE MEN
WOULD BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST I'M STRONGLY URGING YOU
TO MAKE THIS A PRIORITY.
IT'S PROBABLY THE ONLY SOCIAL
WORKER PRIORITY THAT I KNOW
THAT'S IN THE BUDGET.
AND I AM GOING.
TO RELY ON YOUR EXPERTISE AND
YOUR OWN KNOWLEDGE OF HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO FOLLOW YOUR HEART
AND DO THE RIGHT THING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THIS RODRIGUEZ SO
WITH THE COOPER GROUP ON BEHALF
OF CATHOLIC CHARITIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND I JUST HAVE ONE
ITEM -- BUT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATIVE OF THE
EXPANSION OF IMMIGRATION RELATED
SERVICES AS YOU KNOW WE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH OUR ORGANIZATION
AND OTHERS AND HOW MUCH WORK
WE'VE BEEN DOING THESE LAST FEW
MONTHS.
SO THANK YOU AND GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU.
BUT I'M SURE I LOOKED AT A
COUPLE OF ITEMS -- WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE -- AND GRATEFUL FOR
THE AYE HSS MOE PROPOSALS JUST
WANT TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE GENEROSITY AND THE
PROPOSAL AND ALSO -- THE CAL
WORKS EARNED INCOME DISREGARD
PROPOSAL IS IS A PRIORITY FOR
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS YOU KNOW --
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS AHEAD ON
INCREASING THE MINIMUM WAGE AND
FROM JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN TILL
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ABOUT FORTY
NINE HUNDRED CAL WORKS
PARTICIPANTS WILL BE LOSING AID.
AND SUPPORTS THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES THAT IS MUCH NEED FOR
THEM TO CONTINUE -- MAINTAINING
THE NEEDS THEY HAVE
TRANSPORTATION CHILDCARE AND
OTHER NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE TO
CONTINUE EMPLOYMENT SO.
WITH THAT JUST WANT TO ADD
ANOTHER -- FIGURE WHICH IS THAT
FOURTEEN THOUSAND CAL WORKS
FAMILIES ARE HOMELESS.
AND SO THIS DONE WITH THE COST
OF LIVING IS VERY EXPENSIVE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND WE NEED
TO DO ALL WE CAN. TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE SUPPORT TO
MAINTAIN A STRONG STABLE -- WORK
YOU KNOW -- THERE FOR THE
ABILITY TO WORK AND AND YOU KNOW
GET THEM BACK ON THEIR FEET
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN SEEING NONE.
AND I'VE ALREADY LOST ALL OF MY
QUESTIONS I THANK YOU FOR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS AS YOU WERE GIVING
YOUR PRESENTATION -- THAT
CONCLUDES ITEM NUMBER OR ISSUE
NUMBER.
SEVEN BEFORE WE GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A FIVE MINUTE BREAK
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS FOR
DSS.
BEGIN WHEN YOU LIVE.
WELL.
AS MAKING SURE IT WASN'T NINE
THIRTY APOLOGIES.
OF THE THESE THREE ITEMS A
RELATIVELY STRAIGHT FORWARD --
LAST LAST YEAR A BILL WAS
CHAPTER THAT ALLOWED AND
COLLECTIBLE CAL WORKS DEBT TO BE
TO BE WRITTEN OFF -- IN IN THE
DRAFTING OF THAT LANGUAGE -- DO
WE USE THE TERM -- EXPUNGE --
THAT THAT IS USED IN IN TERMS OF
DUMPING OFF OLD EXPIRED AB T.
BALANCES AND CREATED SOME
CONFUSION WERE SIMPLY PROPOSING
AND AND THIS.
TRAILER BILL TO REPLACE THE WORD
EXPUNGE WITH JUST CHARGE. TO TO
LET GO THOSE OBLIGATIONS US
RELATIVELY TECHNICAL.
THE OTHER THING WE MESSED WHEN
IT WHEN THE SESSION FINISH LAST
YEAR AND THIS LIES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AS AS AS WELL -- IF
YOU WERE WHEN WE THOUGHT ABOUT --
HOW HOW THAT DISCHARGE PROCESS
PROCESS SHOULD GO -- YOU KNOW
CLIENTS -- ALTHOUGH MANY STAY
WHERE THEY ARE THEY ALSO MOVE
AROUND IN WITH IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE THREE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED
WELFARE CONSORTIUMS THERE'S NO.
PRACTICAL WAY FOR PEOPLE TO
EASILY WITHOUT MAKING A LOT OF
PHONE CALLS ARE HAVING REALLY
SUPER ACCESS O MULTIPLE
COMPUTERS WHICH WE DON'T DO --
TO TO TAKE A STATEWIDE LOOK AT
THE DEBTS OWED BY A CAL WORKS
CLIENT TO SEE HOW LONG AND WHERE
THOSE DEBTS WORKER.
SO THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING WOULD ALSO
TAKE THAT PIECE OF THE BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW THAT DEBT TO BE
WRITTEN OFF AND POSTPONE IT AND
TELL DAY CAL SAWS SYSTEM WHICH
IS THE CONSOLIDATED -- THREE TO
ONE SAWS SYSTEMS ACTUALLY IS
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT STATE WIDE
LOOK AT THAT THAT SO THAT'S A
PRACTICAL IMPLEMENTATION -- THE
A AND THE OTHER THING THAT THE
BILL DID WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I WEAR MAINTAINING I'M
NOT PROPOSING TO CHANGE.
IS THAT THE AMOUNT OF THE AT THE
OVERPAYMENT THRESHOLD THAT
TRIGGERS A COLLECTION IS GOING
FROM THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AND SO THAT'S
MAINTAINED AND NOT DELAYED -- SO
WE WE WILL NOT BE ESTABLISHING
OVER PAYMENTS FOR DOLLARS LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY JUST
BASED ON A GOVERNMENT COST
EFFECTIVENESS ARGUMENT THAT IT
TAKES.
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME TO
SET THOSE UP AND THEN TRY TO
COLLECT IT SO THAT'S A DRAMATIC --
IMPROVEMENT IN GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCY AND A GOOD POLICY FOR
BOTH GOVERNMENT AND THE AND THE
CLIENT SO THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
AFFECTED.
IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT.
ONE NO ANYTHING FROM LA OVER
FROM FINANCE OKAY NEXT ITEM.
WELL THE NEXT ITEM YOU KNOW IS
REALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF OF THE
ADDITIONAL ADMIN FUNDING WE
TALKED ABOUT YOU HEARD SOME
ADVOCACY -- COMMENTS
APPRECIATING TRAILER BILL THIS
IS THAT TRAILER BILL -- THAT
REMOVES THE LANGUAGE ABOUT THE
CAT -- I'M A STILL CALLING TO
CASH OUT BEEN SUBJECT TO AN
APPROPRIATION -- AND GIVES US
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT THE A
HOLD HARMLESS OR THE MEDICATION --
PRO PROGRAMS VIA ALL COUNTY
LETTERS AS OPPOSED TO A FORMAL
RULE MAKING JUST IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME -- AND THEN THE CAT
CALIFORNIA ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
FOR FOR IMMIGRANTS OR CAPPY
BENEFIT AMOUNT -- IF FOR YEARS
HAS BEEN ALIGNED TO THE SS I SS
PM OUT -- PLUS PLUS A TEN
DOLLARS -- FOR THE FOOD STAMP
AMOUNT AND WE'RE JUST ALIGNING
THAT AGAIN AND MAINTAINING
PARITY IN THE GRANT AMOUNTS
BETWEEN THE PROGRAMS -- VERY
GOOD.
OKAY ROSELLI -- WERE ACTIVELY
LOOKING INTO THIS -- TRAILER
BILL IT JUST RECENTLY CAME OUT
SO WE'RE STILL READING IT WHILE
I'M. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF ASKING
THE ADMINISTRATION IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN JANUARY
THE MITIGATION PROGRAMS THE D.
AND B. S. AND B..
THOSE ARE INTENDED TO BE
PERMANENT PER THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY PROPOSAL HOWEVER THE
LANGUAGE STILL -- MAKES IT
SUBJECT TO FUTURE BUDGET
APPROPRIATIONS SORT I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LANGUAGE
RELATIVE TO THE JANUARY PROPOSAL.
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION WANT TO
RESPOND TO THEM.
SURE TYRANTS PERMANENT FINANCING
WE JUST NOTE THAT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS WE'RE CONTINUING TO
BUDGET FOR IT AND OUT YEARS AS
AN ONGOING PROGRAM.
SO OUR FIVE YEAR WALK CURRENT
HERE BUDGIE HERE THREE OUT HERE
SITS ACCOUNTED FOR AND BUDGET.
FOR FOR THE SMB IN TMD PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT ITEM.
AND THE LAST ITEM ON THIS PAGE
REFLECTS THE TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY -- THE PERIOD THAT
WE THAT WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
PROVIDING FUNDING -- FOR AND
THIS IS ANOTHER PIECE OF LAID
BACK BREAKING TRAILER BILL --
MAY REQUIRE SOME ADDITIONAL TIME
AND AND EYES ON BECAUSE IT'S
RELATIVELY COMPLICATED THE WAY
THE CAL WORK STATUES CRAFTED --
IN THE HOUSING AND DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM I'M SORRY I
NUMBERS.
THREE LA -- HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
JUST JUST TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT I MADE EARLIER AGAIN
COMPLEX POLICY LATE.
I WILL CALL IT PRETTY RECENTLY
PUBLISHED -- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT IT CAREFULLY
ESPECIALLY IN SO FAR AS THE
POLICIES COMPLEXITY WOULD LEAD
TO POTENTIALLY DIFFERENT FISCAL
FACTS FOR BUDGETING PURPOSES SO
WE'LL BE IN TOUCH WITH YOUR
STAFF AND AND SUBCOMMITTEE ON
THAT IN THAT REGARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY NUMBER.
FOUR NUMBER FOUR IS PRECISELY
HOW IT'S DESCRIBED IN YOUR
AGENDA -- WE DIDN'T IN IT -- IT
DELIBERATELY INCLUDE TRIBES IN
ALL THE PLACES THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED BOTH IN TERMS OF
THE NEED TO CONSULT WITH TRIBES
AS WELL AS OUR ELIGIBILITY TO
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM --
AND TO CLARIFY -- THAT THE
FUNDING CAN EITHER BE IS FOR SSI
ADVOCACY OR HOUSING SUPPORTS --
AND GIVEN THE COST OF HOUSING --
COUNTIES OF IDENTIFIED TO US
THAT -- THE REQUIREMENT -- THAT
CLIENTS SERVED BY THE PROGRAM
HAVE TO BE HOUSING UNITS THAT
WOULD BE SUSTAINABLE FOR THEIR
INCOME ONCE THEY RECEIVE A
FEDERAL DISABILITY BENEFIT HAS
BEEN A BARRIER TO THEIR ABILITY
TO ASSIST CLIENTS.
IN ACTUALLY GETTING APPROVED FOR
THOSEBENEFITS -- BECAUSE
THERE'S SO FEW PLATE PLACEMENT
OPTIONS AVAILABLE THAT MEET THAT
CRITERIA [inaudible]
HELLO.
HI THIS TRAILER BILL TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE WAS JUST POSTED TODAY
SO WILL BE REVIEWING IT AND
TRYING TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS A POLICY
CHANGE MAKING -- HOUSING
SERVICES OPTIONAL -- SO.
GOOD TO PUBLIC FINANCE
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
FIVE EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
PAYMENTS THIS IS THE ONE WE
TALKED ABOUT UNDER CURRENT LAW --
STATE EXPENSE WOULD BE NINETY
DAYS WERE PROPOSING A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY WAS GOOD BECAUSE UP
TO A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS --
SO THAT IT'S NOT COMPLICATED
LANGUAGE BUT IMPORTANT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE.
CAN WE ASK FOR A COST ON WHAT
WAS --RECOMMENDED.
BUT GOOD CAUSE FOR THE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIXTY FIVE
DAYS.
JUST REGISTERING OF FINANCE -- I
WE CAN DO WE CAN DEFINITELY LOOK
INTO WHAT THE DIFFERENCE WOULD
BE -- OBSERVE YOU'RE ASKING SO
BETWEEN -- THE PROPOSED UNDER
NINETY DAYS COULD CAUSE FOR
BUDGET YEAR -- YEAH I PERSONALLY
DON'T HAVE THAT ON ME AT THE
MOMENT.
BUT WE CAN LOOK INTO THAT FOR
YOU.
THANK YOU CAN YOU GET BACK TO
STAFF ON THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY NUMBER.
SIX CONTINUE OF CARE REFORM
CONTRACT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
AREAS -- IN WHICH WE WORK WE'VE
BEEN ASKED AND ARE PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- TO
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF CHANGING
PROCESS SEES AND ACCOMPLISHING
THINGS ARE PROVIDING TRAINING.
OR MAKING CERTAIN RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
I I BELIEVE IT'S FIVE BUT IT
MIGHT BE SIX VERY SPECIFIC
SPECIFIED PURPOSES FOR WHICH
WERE ASKING -- FOR CERTAIN
CONTRACT CODE EXEMPTIONS TO
ACCELERATE OUR ABILITY TO GET
THOSE CONTRACTS OUT THE DOOR AND
ON THE STREET IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME.
VERY GOOD HELLO [inaudible]
PUBLIC FINANCE.
OKAY NEXT ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN I BELIEVE THIS IS A
CORRECTION TO A DRAFTING
OVERSIGHT -- THERE THERE ARE --
AS YOU HEARD IN THE THE COMMENTS
IS THAT WE HAD ABOUT EITHER
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER PAYMENTS OR
PLACEMENT OF UPON APPROVAL --
WHEN YOU ENTER INTO A CAN GAP
AGREEMENT THE STATUTE
INADVERTENTLY DIDN'T INCLUDE CAN
GAP IN THE -- DATE BY WHICH
PAYMENT PAYMENTS CAN BE
[inaudible]
CAN.
YES.
RIGHT.
OKAY SORRY.
FOSTER CARE PAYMENTS AND AND THE
PAYMENT TO THE CAN GET PROVIDER
WOULD BEGAN ON ON THAT THE DATE
OF THE MONTHLY PLACEMENT.
I'M SORRY THAT STOCKWELL STATED.
ALL RIGHT.
I FINANCIAL STRAITS REGISTERED
TO CLEAR IT'S PURELY TECHNICAL
CODIFYING WITH FEDERAL LAW RIGHT
NOW THAT IS SOON AS A MEANS
PAYMENTS ARE ARE DEPENDENT
SEASON AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT --
WE'RE KIND OF FIND AND I CAN GET
CAN BEGIN IMMEDIATELY THEREAFTER.
WONDERFUL LA YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NEXT ITEM.
WITH APOLOGIES FOR THE TITLE OF
THE ISSUE -- THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FUNDS REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT PROGRAMS -- AND
THEY GENERALLY DO THAT BY
PROVIDING FUNDING TO STATES WHO
THEN ALLOCATE THEM THROUGH
COUNTIES TO TO THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS -- WENT WHEN THAT
PROGRAM IT'S BEEN OVER TWENTY
YEARS OR ROUGHLY TWENTY YEARS AT
THIS POINT WAS CREATED -- THERE
THERE WAS A DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT THAT THE FEDS FUNDED
DIRECTLY IN THE SAN DIEGO AREA --
PURSUANT TO A LEGISLATION
AUTHORED BY MEMBER THEN MEMBERS --
WILSON AND FISH -- THAT ALLOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
DIRECTLY FUND THAT PILOT PROGRAM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT INDICATED
TO US RECENTLY THAT -- AS OF
OCTOBER ONE THEY NO LONGER WANT
TO CONTINUE THAT DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT BUT FOR A
PROJECT AND INSTEAD WOULD BE
PROVIDING THE FUNDS TO THE STATE
TO CONTINUE IT.
AND SO WE'RE REQUESTING TRAILER
BILL AUTHORITY THAT WOULD ALLOW
US TO CONTRACT DIRECTLY -- AS
THE FEDS HAVE DONE WITHOUT
NONPROFIT PROVIDER -- AGAIN IN
COORDINATION WITH THE COUNTY AND
THE COUNTIES PLANNED FOR SERVING
REFUGEES.
BUT ALLOWING US -- TO TO GO
DIRECTLY TO THE NONPROFIT
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
PUBLIC FINANCE.
OKAY.
THE NEXT ITEM.
AND THE RAPID RESPONSE RESERVE
THIS IS THE FIVE MILLION CURRENT
YEAR AND THEN THOSE LAWS
LANGUAGE WOULD APPLY TO THE
TWENTY MILLION AND BUDGET YEAR
LAYS OUT THE OF HER PURPOSE FOR
WHICH THE FUNDS WILL BE
AVAILABLE AND MAKES THEM
AVAILABLE FOR A THREE YEAR
PERIOD -- TO TO ASSIST --
VARIOUS ENTITIES -- IN IN OUR
MERCHANT IMMIGRANT SITUATIONS
THIS IS WHAT'S YOU'D BEING USED
TO FUND -- HEALTH SCREENINGS AND
REFUGEES I'M SORRY IMMIGRANT
SERVICES -- TRANSPORTATION ON
WORDS THE THE SHELTERING OF OF
THEM ALL WELL THEY FIGURE OUT
WHERE THEY'RE GOING -- REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE THAT WITH THE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ALREADY TODAY
YES.
VERY GOOD LA YOU [inaudible]
FROM FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
BOB MADAM CHAIR MY CAROL AGAIN
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY -- BUT JUST A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS -- ONE IS WE SUPPORT
THE FIRST ITEM THE THE CHANGES
TO SB -- SEVEN TWENTY SIX WE
THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE WE ARE
FINE WITH THAT -- I JUST OF I'M
GOING TO TAKE BACK MY EARLIER
REMARKS ABOUT THE SS I CASH OUT
CLEAN UP LANGUAGE -- IN READING
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IT'S
POSTED ON THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES WEBSITE.
I DON'T THINK IT DOES EITHER
THING I DON'T THINK IT.
FOR IT DOESN'T PROVIDE FOR AN
ENTITLEMENT TO AID AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME THAT IT -- DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO SUBJECT THE PROGRAM
TO AN ANNUAL APPROPRIATION SO I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO
REVIEW THAT WHEN WE CAN BE IN
TOUCH WITH THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WE THINK THAT
LANGUAGE ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHES --
THE PURPOSES AND I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT I WAS ABLE TO REVIEW
QUICKLY THE HOUSING DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM LANGUAGE --
THIS SEEMS TO BE A RATHER
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE AGREED -- TO SOME
TWO OR THREE YEARS AGO I MEAN
AGAIN I THINK WE WOULD WANT TO
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO TALK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
COMMITTEE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING THERE IS IS STILL
CONSISTENT WITH THE ORIGINAL
INTO THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THE START BECAUSE
WITH THE COOPER GROUP ON BEHALF
OF CATHOLIC CHARITIES IN SUPPORT
OF ITEMS NUMBER EIGHT AND NINE
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK
ESPECIALLY TO DSS THE VERY GOOD.
IF I MAY CHAIRED JUST MAYBE MY
MISSED OPPORTUNITY AS WELL IF IF
I COULD GIVEN THE INTEREST IN
THE AUTOMATION OF THE DISASTER
CALIBRATION ISSUE THAT MISTER
MAC I MENTIONED THE NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WITH MATCHING FEDERAL
FUNDS -- I I WOULD ALSO JUST
POINT OUT ACROSS THE BOARD ON
LEGISLATION AND BUDGET ITEMS --
BECAUSE OF THE MIGRATION OF THE
SYSTEMS FROM THREE TO TWO THREE
THREE SYSTEMS TO ONE SYSTEM.
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE EXISTING
BUDGET EVEN FOR CHANGES TO BE
MADE.
AND SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
AREAS AS YOU SAW WITH OUR OWN
PROPOSAL AROUND OVER PAYMENT
COLLECTIONS WE'RE WE'RE
SUGGESTING THAT DATES BE PUSHED
OUT.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THAT
HAPPENED FOR DISASTER CAL FOR
ASH BUT I WOULD SIMPLY SUGGEST
THAT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CONVERSATION AROUND ANY ITEM
THAT IMPACTS SAWS AND
POTENTIALLY REQUIRES AUTOMATION --
THAT EITHER THERE'D BE A
PRIORITY EVEN -- CLEARLY STATED.
FOR IT IT HE ITS INCLUSION IN A
PARTICULAR YEAR TO THE EXTENT
THAT'S POSSIBLE AND I WOULD NEED
A BEER.
OF COURSE INCLUSIVE OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COUNTY --
CONSORTIA THAT OPERATE THOSE
SYSTEMS.
EITHER TO AUTOMATED OR TO
CONSIDER THAT THE COST OF THE
WORKER TIME TO DO MANUAL WORK
AROUNDS FOR THOSE THINGS OR
WHETHER IT DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE IS A MORE
FEASIBLE APPROACH.
SO IS A LITTLE BIT COMPLICATED
THE OTHER OPTION IS TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING FOR A PURPOSE.
AND ASK FOR IT TO BE DONE WHEN
IT'S FEASIBLE TO DO SO AT ANY IN
THE ALLOCATION OF THOSE FUNDS
MAKE THEM AVAILABLE FOR A MULTI
YEAR PERIOD.
SO IN IN THE INTERESTS OF OF
BEING ASSISTIVE -- I DON'T WANT
ANYBODY TO BE CONFUSED BY
REMARKS AROUND SAWS SOME THINGS
LIKE GRANT INCREASES ARE JUST
REPLACING NUMBERS AND TABLES ON
THOSE DON'T REALLY REQUIRE
CHANGES -- BUT OTHER THINGS ARE
MORE COMPLEX -- AND MAY REQUIRE
SOME TIME SO I'M JUST LAYING OUT
SOME CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
ADDITIONALLY.
THERE'S AS YOU KNOW A VERY LARGE
VOLUME.
OF ITEMS BOTH FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FROM OTHERS
ASKING FOR CONSIDERATION IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND WE SIMPLY
WANT TO PLACE HOLD THAT IT TAKES
PEOPLE TO GET SOME OF THOSE
THINGS DONE.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WE COME
TO AN AGREEMENT AROUND THE FINAL
PACKAGE THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
BE VERY INTERESTED IN HAVING A
CONVERSATION.
AROUND POSITIONS ARE CONTRACT
DOLLARS OR WHATEVER IS
APPROPRIATE TO ACTUALLY AFFECTS
YOU IT THOSE PROPOSALS SO I JUST
WANTED TO PUT THAT REMARK ON THE
RECORD AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE AT THE END OF A LONG
HEARING.
SHARE THOSE COMMENTS ON THE KILL
FRESH'S AND POSTAL MADAM TERRIFY
CAM THIS IS A VERY VERY BRIEF --
LAST SORT OF PERSONAL NOTICE I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOUR
LEADERSHIP AS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR THIS IS
PROBABLY OUR LAST TIME WE'RE
GOING TO BE APPEARING THIS YEAR
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
AND WANTED TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
STOPPING UP AND ALSO TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK OF
YOUR STAFF.
PARTICULARLY THIS TIME OF YEAR
WHEN THINGS ARE COMING AT THE
VERY FAST AND FURIOUS -- AS WAS
THE LA -- AND AND OTHERS BUT IT
YOU THE WORK THAT THEY DO IS
TRULY TRULY APPRECIATED AND WE
APPRECIATE THEIR PARTNERSHIP.
AND BELIEVE ME I APPRECIATED SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH THIS
CONCLUDES TODAY'S THOSE SUB ONE
BUDGET HEARING